OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEES WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WHAT WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS TODAY IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH ME ARE SENATORS PAN AND
HER TADO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. WE
ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATION
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATIONS
UNIT. THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE CENTER FOR PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING TODAY REMOTELY.
AS A REMINDER TO ALL PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I S. THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR. ASKING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE. POLICE
SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE LET ME ALSO ADD
THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK PLEASE
SPEAK LOUDLY. PLEASE ARTICULATE
PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY SO EVERYONE
CAN HEAR YOU- BOTH. THOSE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING OVER THE
AUDIO OR THE VIDEO AND THOSE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOMS IN THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELESCOPE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL IN OF INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT RIGHT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO NINE SIX
ONE EIGHT FOUR TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE WEBSITE OR OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA UPON THE CONCLUSION.
OF OUR PANELISTS PRESENTATIONS
AND FOLLOWING QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES
TODAY. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE. THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
IS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED. AND YOU WILL NOW BE
READY THEN BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE AND PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN INSTRUCTED TO DO
SO. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE DURING THIS.
EXTRA LAYER OF PROCESS. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED OR
BE REMOVED FROM THESE CHAMBERS.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS. AND TO CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS LIKE TODAY'S HEARING.
HELLO FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
REGULATORY AND LICENSING
PROGRAMS AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW OR
IN THE PROGRAM OPERATIONS OR
FUNCTIONS ARE NECESSARY. TODAY
WE WILL BE REVIEWING SPECIFIC
ISSUES REGARDING THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA'S
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS AND CASE
OUTCOMES THERE WILL BE ONE OR
MORE FURTHER HEARINGS INVOLVING
THE MEDICAL BOARD ON OTHER.
FUNCTIONS AND PROCESS SEES OF
THAT BOARD SCHEDULED AT A LATER
DATE. TODAY WE WILL ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. AT THIS POINT I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EVAN LOW THE
DISTINGUISHED CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO MAKE.
ANY OPENING REMARKS REGARDING
TODAY'S HEARING MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM ROTH I
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND
DEDICATION THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE SENATE PUT INTO
THIS AS WELL AS THE IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND ALSO- THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU AND I
HAVE HAD ABOUT ENSURING THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. AND THE SUNSET
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD AS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAY KNOW
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION AND OUR
DUTY TO LOOK OUT FOR THE BEST
INTEREST OF ALL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE DOING TODAY WITH RESPECT TO
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
ASKING THE DIFFICULT QUESTIONS
THAT MUST BE ASKED. AT THE SAME
TIME IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WHEN
YOU HEAR ABOUT SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS IF THERE IS A
VIOLATION OF TRUST WHO DO ALL
THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN TO ENSURE
A DUE PROCESS AS WE KNOW THAT
SIMPLY FOR LICENSEES THIS IS
ABOUT. INDIVIDUALS LIVELIHOODS-
SO I KNOW THAT WE WILL DO OUR
BEST TO ENSURE THAT WILL
ADVOCATE FOR THE INTERESTS OF
ALL IMPACTED AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND LOOKING FOR TO THE
CONTINUE DIALOGUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CHIRLA
IT'S AN HONOR TO PARTICIPATE
WITH YOU HERE TODAY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE. TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR. WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE. TWO NINE SIX. ONE EIGHT
FOUR TWO. WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
CRISTINA LAWSON PRESIDENT OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME IS AWESOME.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE HEAR ME
OKAY YES MA'AM LONDON CLEAR.
ACTUALLY GOOD MORNING OROVILLE
CHAIR ROSS ARE BOTH CHAIR LOW
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA LAUGHLIN AND IT IS MY
HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE SERVED ON
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND
I AM ONE OF SEVEN PUBLIC
MEMBERS AUTHORIZED TO SERVE ON
THE BOARD. PROFESSIONALLY I AM
A LICENSED CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
AND THE MANAGING PARTNER OF THE
HANSON BRIDGET HOPPER AND I AM
A FORMER MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
THE- CHARGED WITH PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS. AND PROMOTING ACCESS
TO QUALITY MEDICAL CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEVASTATING AND
TRAGIC IMPACT. OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ON
COMMUNITIES AND INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OUR HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES GO
OUT TO THE FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
OF THE MORE THAN FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES TO THE VIRUS.
AND WE EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
CALIFORNIA IS SPECIAL WORKERS
FOR THEIR WORK ON OUR
COLLECTIVE BEHALF. WE ARE
PLEASED TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE BOARD'S
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS
CRITICAL TO THE BOARD MISSION
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER. THE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IS ONE
COMPONENT OF THE BOARD
PORTFOLIO OF POLICY AND
REGULATORY DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES LICENSING AND
REGULATIONS THAT POSITION.
SURGEON AND CERTAIN ALLIED
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS. THEY
SENT THAT REVIEW PROCESS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BOARD AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE DIALOGUE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. INCLUDING
THE CONSTRAINTS THAT THE BOARD
SPACES IN THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. I SET FORTH IN MORE
DETAIL IN OUR SUNSET REVIEW
REPORT AND AS WE WILL DISCUSS
WITH YOU TODAY WE BELIEVE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO IMPROVE MEDICAL BOARD
PROCESS. AND ENHANCE THE
BOARD'S ABILITY TO FIRST THOUGH
IT'S IMPORTANT DUTIES AND
ENSURE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ARE
PROTECTED. WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL PARTNER WITH
US TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT
ALL HEALTHCARE CONSUMERS AND
ENSURE ACCESS TO QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE OP. TO
DISCUSS THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
WITH YOU I THINK HERE FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. WE ARE DEDICATED
TO MOVING THE MEDICAL BOARD
FORWARD TO ADVANCE ITS MISSION
AND TO BUILD TRUST WITH THE
PUBLIC. I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUES- THE
MEDICAL BOARD VICE PRESIDENT DR
HOWARD CRAP. THANK YOU MS
LAWSON FOR YOUR SERVICE WELCOME
DOCTOR CROSS. GOOD MORNING-
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO BE OF
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING MY TENURE ON
THE MEDICAL BOARD SINCE AUGUST
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN. I WILL
BE TURNED OUT ON JUNE ONE.
AFTER RECEIVING MY MASTERS IN
AERONAUTICS AND ASTRONAUTICS AT
MIT. I BECAME A SYSTEMS
ENGINEER WITH THE HUGHES
AIRCRAFT COMPANY IN LOS
ANGELES. ENGAGED IN THE DESIGN
OF MISSILES SATELLITES AND
SPACECRAFT FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. SEEKING A MORE
HUMANISTIC CAREER I LEFT FOR
MEDICAL SCHOOL. RECEIVING MY
HANDY AT THE RIPE OLD AGE OF
TWENTY SEVEN. AND THEN PURSUED
FIVE YEARS OF POSTGRADUATE
EDUCATION SINCE WHICH TIME I
HAVE SPECIALIZED IN SURGICAL
NEURO OPHTHALMOLOGY. ENGAGED IN
THE EVALUATION- AND MEDICAL AND
SURGICAL MANAGEMENT OF PATIENTS
WITH NEUROLOGIC. BRAIN FACIAL
AN ORBITAL DISORDERS WHICH
AFFECT VISION. I'M A PHYSICIAN
AND SURGEON A RESEARCHER AND
MEDICAL OFF THERE AND CONTINUE
TO TEACH AT UCLA WHERE AM
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF
OPHTHALMOLOGY AND NEUROSURGERY.
ONE OF MY MOST IMPORTANT AND
HUMBLING EXPERIENCES BEGAN IN
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
WHEN I RECEIVED A CALL FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OFFERING THIS
APPOINTMENT. BUT OVER THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS I HAVE LEARNED THAT
ROCKET SCIENCE AND BRAIN
SURGERY ARE EASIER THAN SERVING
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD. IN MY
PROFESSIONAL LIFE I HAVE BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO PATIENTS FAMILIES
STAFF STUDENTS AND COLLEAGUES.
SAYING THANK YOU. I ENJOYED MY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COLLEAGUES
AND STAFF OF THE MEDICAL BOARD.
BUT SELDOM RECEIVED THANK YOUS
FROM PHYSICIANS AT LARGE OR
FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
APPEAR OR CALL AND WORK
MEETINGS. IN MANY REGARDS IT'S
BEEN A THANKLESS TASK BUT I
HAVE PERSISTED BECAUSE I KNOW
THE VALUE OF THIS SPORT. I KNOW
THAT DESPITE THE FAILURES WHICH
MAY BE HIGHLIGHTED THE TIMES.
THAT THIS BOARD IS COMMITTED
AND DEDICATED TO PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC ABOVE ALL ELSE. AS SUCH
THE SEVEN YEARS OF TRUE PUBLIC
SERVICE. WILL CONTINUE TO BE
VALUED BY ME AS A TIME OF GREAT
SIGNIFICANCE KNOWING THAT I AND
MY FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS ARE
DEDICATED BOARD EXECUTIVES AND
STAFF AND OUR DEDICATED
COLLEAGUES IN THE AG'S OFFICE.
AND IN THE DCA HAVE LABORED
LONG AND HARD. IN BEHALF OF THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH PRESIDENT LAWSON. THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION WAS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY. AND OUR
MEMBERS AND STAFF ARE DEDICATED
TO THAT MISSION. TODAY I
PERSONALLY ASK FOR THE SUPPORT
OF THE LEGISLATURE. MORE HOPES
TO ENACT MULTIPLE CHANGES TO
THE BOARD STATUTES INCLUDING
SOME ADDITIONAL STATUTORY
ENHANCEMENTS THAT SUPPORT ITS
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. I BELIEVE
THAT THE BOARD'S PROPOSALS AND
OUR SUNSET REPORT WILL LEAD TO
INCREASED EFFICIENCY AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE BOARD
AND ITS INVESTIGATORS WORK ON
THE BOARDS MOST CRITICAL CASES
INCLUDING THOSE THAT INVOLVE
NEGLIGENT OR INCOMPETENT
QUALITY OF CARE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AND OTHER SERIOUS
MATTERS. THE BOARD APPRECIATES
INPUT FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND WAYS TO
ADMINISTER OUR LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS AS
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MISTER WILLIAM
PROCEEDS GO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR MISTER PACIFICA.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US SENATE
STAND IT YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
STAFF AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS
JOINING US TODAY AS WELL. YES
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE I'M
HERE WITH MY SENIOR MANAGEMENT
TEAM. WILL BE ASSISTING ME AND
ANSWERING ALL OF YOUR QUESTIONS
I HAVE A PRESENTATION I WILL.
THANKFULLY BE BRIEF BUT SIMPLY
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME VERY
IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. AS THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
HAVE VERY ELOQUENTLY STATED.
THAT THE PROTECTION OF
CONSUMERS IS AT THE VERY HEART.
OF EVERYTHING THAT WE DO AT THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND AS A
REGULATOR. WHO HAS HAD
EXPERIENCE IN A VARIETY OF
REGULATE READ THE FARES. CAN I
TELL YOU THAT I KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARDOF
CALIFORNIA. VALUES CONSUMER
PROTECTION AS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
HIGHEST PRIORITY. IN TERMS OF
AN OVERVIEW OF ENFORCEMENT. I
WELCOME THE FACT THAT TO DATE
WE ARE TALKING ONLY ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT. BECAUSE AS IS
QUITE APPARENT IN FORSMAN IS
THE LARGEST FUNCTION OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD LITERALLY 80% OF
OUR RESOURCES ARE DEVOTED. TO
ENFORCEMENT SO IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE THAT WE FOCUS ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT. PART OF
OUR STATUTORY MISSION. I KNOW
ONE IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT
ARE THE TIMES THAT IT TAKES TO
BRING ABOUT AN INVESTIGATION
AND TAKE A COMPLAINT THROUGH
THE ENTIRE PROCESS. THE CHART
HERE DEMONSTRATE WHAT THOSE
TIME FRAMES ARE CHARGING OUT
FROM THE TIME IN WHICH ALL
INVESTIGATION WAS HANDLED
INTERNALLY IN THE BOARD- UP
TILL- FISCAL YEAR THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND THEN AFTER THERE
WAS A SPLIT BETWEEN THE SWORN
AND THE NON SWORN-
INVESTIGATIONS. ARE WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCREASING
TIME FRAMES FROM AN
INTERNATIONAL PERSPECTIVE. I
KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT MEDICAL BOARDS ALL OVER
THE WORLD ARE STRUGGLING WITH
BECAUSE CASES ARE BECOMING MORE
COMPLEX MORE LITIGIOUS AND
THERE ARE CHALLENGES AND ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE TO
FACE. UP TO IS THE FACT THAT
THE TIME FRAMES IN TERMS OF THE
SWORN INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
CONTINUED TO RISE DR BOTH OR-
MR PACIFICO BEFORE YOU LEAVE
THAT CHART I NORMALLY DON'T DO
THIS BUT WE MIGHT AS WELL SAVE
SOME TIME HERE. COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT THAT CHART MEANS
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT ALL CASES-
THE R. I. C. YEARS AS AN ORANGE
LINE YARNS LINE OF THOSE THE
COMPLEX CASES THOSE ARE THE
CASES THAT GO TO THE SWORN SITE
WHICH TEND TO BE THE MORE
COMPLICATED CASES. ABSOLUTELY
AND THEY HAVE BEEN INCREASING
IN TIME IN RECENT YEARS. THE
LESS COMPLEX CASES ON THE NON
SWORN SIDE WE HAVE MANAGED TO
MAKE SOME PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
GETTING THE TIME FRAMES DOWN.
ON THIS THE END OF BEFORE I GO
TO MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR PAN AND
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IS TIME FROM RECEIPT OF
COMPLAINT. TO COMPLETION OF
INVESTIGATION. YES THAT'S
CORRECT. THE OTHER ISSUE IS HOW
LONG IT TAKES TO MOVE FROM
COMPLETION OF INVESTIGATION TO
RESOLUTION BUT LET ME GO TO
DOCTOR PAN CENTER PAM ACTUALLY
IT'S- BY SHE HEARS AT LEAST
SITTING FROM HERE WITH- GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE PRINCE AND
WHERE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT ITS
VERY HEART WHICH I CNNOT SEE
THE LEGENDS IN THE GRAPH SO I'M
GONNA NEED A LITTLE MORE
EXPLANATION OF FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
THE COLOR LINES ACTUALLY MEAN
BECAUSE IN THE FRENCH. POLICE I
DON'T KNOW FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHERE
I'M SITTING I HEART IT'S ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS AGO THANKS IF WE
HAVE A COPY OF THE PRINT THAT'S
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. YOU WOULD
LIKE A FULLER EXPLANATION NOW
WHICH YOU. OF THE CHAIRS
PROVIDED ME A COPY OF THE
SLIDES AND JUST ALLOWS ME TO
ACTUALLY READ WHAT'S ON THE
SLIDES- I DON'T KNOW IF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
ARE IN A SIMILAR SITUATION OR
NOT. BUT WE'LL TRY TO GET THE
COPIES OF THAT OF. FOR THE
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE ROOM AS
SOON THOSE ON THE SCREEN CAN.
HAVE A BETTER VIEW THOSE THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SO.
WE'LL TRY TO DO THAT DOCTOR
DOCTOR PAN ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS BASED ON. OKAY SIR
I'M SORRY TO HAVE INTERRUPTED
BUT I THOUGHT WE MIGHT AS WELL
GET THAT EITHER WAY PLEASE
PROCEED THAT'S FINE OKAY GOING
ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE LOOK AT
THE OVERALL STATISTICS THE
STATISTICS FOR COMPLAINTS
RECEIVED. THIS IS A VERY
FAMILIAR- STATISTIC FOR THOSE
WHO FOLLOW US CLOSELY WE HAVE
BEEN RECEIVING ON THE ORDER OF
TEN TO ELEVEN THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS- EVERY YEAR. AND AT
THE END OF THE YEAR IN TERMS OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS THERE'S A
FAIRLY LARGE CONSISTENCY THAT
WERE IN THE- THREE TO FOUR
HUNDRED- THE RATE CATEGORY. IF
YOU LOOK AT THAT. IN TERMS OF
THE NATIONAL CONTEXT. IT FINDS
OUT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD IS IF YOU WILL SLIGHTLY
ABOVE AVERAGE IN THE TERMS OF
NUMBER OF DISCIPLINES. I CASES
PER M. D.'S- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BUT THE IMPORTANT THING
HERE. IS TO FOCUS ON THAT THERE
ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS. THAT AT A
RELATIVELY EARLY PART OF THE
PROCESS- ARE CLOSED OUT FOR AS
IT SAYS THEY'RE INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE NO VIOLATION ARE NO
JURISDICTION. SOMETIMES WE GET
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE SAME
INCIDENT. AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
ONY ONE INCIDENT THERE'S
EFFECTIVELY ONLY WANT A
COMPLAINANT. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE WAY THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO OPERATE
SOMETIMES THIS CAN SEEM A BIT
STARTLING. BUT AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS WORKED IN OTHER AREAS IT'S
A- IT'S A FINAL IT'S A
FRAMEWORK WHICH IS ALL TOO
FAMILIAR. THERE ARE MANY CASES
THAT WE RECEIVED. THAT DO NOT
RAISE ISSUES OF FITNESS TO
PRACTISE AND WHAT IS NEEDED IN
A REGULATORY SYSTEM IS THE
AGILITY. TO DEAL WITH THOSE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY SO
THAT ON THE LESSER NUMBER IS A
VERY SERIOUS CASES WE HAVE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES. TO DEAL
WITH THEM IN A COMPREHENSIVE
FASHION. WHAT I WANTED TO DO
WAS TO HIGHLIGHT WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD SEES SAYS SOME OF
THE DRIVERS IN RELATION TO THE
TIMELINES AND RESOURCES THAT IT
TAKES IN ORDER TO BRING A
COMPLAINT THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS ONE THING WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE OPERATE
UNDER A VERY HIGH BURDEN OF
PROOF IN ORDER TO GET
SUBSTANTIAL DISCIPLINE THE CASE
MUST BE PROVEN. ACCORDING TO
CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WERE
HELD O. IT BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND IT
IS A HEAVY BURDEN BUT THEN
AGAIN IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY SERIOUS SANCTION THAT'S A
VERY SERIOUS MATTER AS WELL.
THEOTHER POINT THAT I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT THE
LEGISLATION. REQUIRES THAT IN
TERMS OF FRAMING A SANCTION.
YES WE LOOK AT PUBLIC
PROTECTION. AND THAT IS THE
PRIMARY. OBJECT THE PRIMARY
GOAL WE ALL AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT WE ARE ALSO DIRECTED TO
LOOK AT ISSUES OF
REHABILITATION AND PRACTICE
RESTRICTIONS WHICH WOULD ALLOW
A DOCTOR TO REMAIN IN PRACTICE.
PROVIDED THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
REMEDIATION OUR PRACTICE
RESTRICTIONS FROM SOME QUARTERS
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DRIVE
PERHAPS UNDERSTANDABLY. THAT
MOST- TIMES THERE IS A FINDING
A TRADE GROUP RESULT IN
REVOCATION THAT IS NOT WHAT THE
LEGISLATION DIRECTS US TO DO
ALTHOUGH IT DOES RECOGNIZE THAT
REPLICATION IS NECESSARY IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT IS A DRIVER IN
TERMS OF ENFORCEMENTIS THE
INSTITUTIONAL PERSPECTIVE IN
THAT EFFECTIVELY ENFORCEMENT.
CURRENTLY IS DIVIDED AMONG
THREE SEPARATE BODIES OURSELVES
THE MEDICAL BOARD THE HEALTH
QUALITY INVESTIGATIVE UNIT IN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
THIS IS I THANK AN UNUSUAL
CONFIGURATION COMPARED TO OTHER
PLACES AND IT DOES PRESENT
CERTAIN CHALLENGES WHICH WE
WILL TALK ABOUT- THE OTHER
DRIVER- THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF EXPLAINING
AND UNDERSTANDING WHY IT TAKES
SO LONG. WHAT SOMETIMES IS SO
COSTLY TO BRING A COMPLAINT ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS IS
THAT WE HAVE TO FOLLOW A VERY
CUMBERSOME LEGAL PROCESS WHICH
REQUIRES MOST CASES BEFORE ANY
SERIOUS SANCTION CAN BE.
CONSIDERED TO GO TO ACCUSATIONS
ACCUSATION IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP IT REQUIRES THE ACTION OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
PREPARING A VERY LENGTHY
DOCUMENT WHICH IS NECESSARY BUT
VERY COSTLY AND VERY TIME
CONSUMING. WE HAVE SOMETIMES
DIFFICULTY GETTING ACCESS TO
THIRD PARTY RECORDS WE ALSO HAD
DIFFICULTIES MAINTAINING OUR
OBTAINING PATIENT RECORDS IN
BOTH OF THESE THINGS CAN BE
VERY TIME CONSUMING WHERE WE
WANT TO INVESTIGATE IT TAKES
SOMETIMES A LONG TIME TO
ACTUALLY GET THE RECORDS. AND
THE OTHER THING IN TERMS OF
PROCESS IS THAT UNDER OUR
CURRENT. STATUTE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS ON ANY
NON ADVERSARIAL OPTIONS THAT WE
MAY PURSUE. THERE IS A PUBLIC
LETTER OF REGRET RECORD
REPRIMAND BUT THAT CAN ONLY BE
INVOKED IF IT'S AGREED BY THE
OTHER PARTY AND IT'S PUBLISHED
IN THE MUST BE TOO SIMPLE
DEPARTURES. IT IS VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR US IF WE HAVE A
LENGTHY INVESTIGATION. AND IT
IS DETERMINED THAT THERE IS ONE
SIMPLE DEPARTURE IN A SIMPLE
DEPARTURE MAYBE SOMETHING WHICH
IS QUITE IMPORTANT. BUT THEN WE
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN THE
REGULATE RETOOL CAT IN WHICH WE
CAN. BRING THE DOCTOR THROUGH
SOME. SOME REPEAT REMEDIATION
OUR REHABILITATION THERE'S
LITERALLY NOTHING WE CAN DO.
THERE IS A REFERENCE VERY
BRIEFLY IN OUR STATUTE TO
WARNING LETTERS BUT THEIR NON
BINDING THEY'RE NOT DEFINED AND
THERE'S NOTHING IN THEM THAT WE
CAN RELATE RELY ON IN TERMS OF.
HAVING A SERIOUS MEANS OF
DEALING WITH A COMPLAINT. SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A FEW REFORMS
WE ARE DEDICATED TO WORKING
WITHIN THE SYSTEM TO WORKING
MORE EFFECTIVELY. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IF THERE ARE
CERTAIN REFORMS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK MORE EFFECTIVELY MORE
EFFICIENTLY WE CAN BRING THE
TIME LINES DOWN WILL HAVE MORE
RESOURCES. TO FOCUS ON THE VERY
SERIOUS ISSUES WHICH REQUIRE
OFTEN A VERY SERIOUS AND SEVERE
SANCTIONS. THE FIRST IS TO
CREATE WHAT WE HAVE DEEMED TO
BE A LETTER OF ADVICE WHICH
WOULD BE NON PUBLIC BUT
BINDING. THESE WOULD BE FOR
CASES WHERE FITNESS TO PRACTISE
IS NOT AN ISSUE BUT THERE IS A
NEED FOR REMEDIATION. WE NOTE
THAT THRE ARE AT LEAST TWENTY
ONE OTHER BOARDS WITH THE IN
THE UNITED STATES THAT HAVE
SUCH A POWER. I KNOW THAT
INTERNATIONALLY THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS MOVING TOWARDS A FOCUS
ON NON ADVERSARIAL MEANS OF
RESOLUTION FOR THE VAST BULK.
OFTHE COMPLAINTS AND THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING WHICH I THINK IS
NEEDED VERY MUCH AS AN OPTION
FOR US AT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL. AS WE'VE ALSO STATED
IN OUR SUNSET PAPER THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE THINK. ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AND THEY WOULD
ALLOW US TO EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY OBTAIN THE RECORDS
THAT ARE SO VITAL FOR US IN A
TIMELY MANNER. SO THAT WE CAN
INVESTIGATE CASES IN SO WE
WOULD CERTAINLY WELCOME THEIR
CONSIDERATION. IN TERMS OF
INSTITUTIONAL REFORM WE THINK
THAT THERE IS A NEED FOR
GREATER ENGAGEMENT. BETWEEN
OURSELVES THE MEDICAL BOARD IN
THE HEALTH QUALITY
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT WE HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN TO DO THAT WE ARE
UPDATING THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE TWO
BODIES THERE IS GOOD WILL ON
BOTH SIDES. BOTH SIDES
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A NEED
TO- TO DEAL WITH THESE CASES
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND WE ARE
DEDICATED TO WORKING TOGETHER
PARTICULARLY TO BRING THE TIME
LINES DOWN AND TO PRIORITIZE.
SO THAT WERE USING MOST
RESOURCES AGAINST THE MOST
IMPORTANT CASES. AND RELATED TO
THAT WE SEE THAT THERE WILL BE
A NEED AT SOME POINT IN THE
SHORT TO MEDIUM TERM TO BEGIN
TO CONSIDER MOVING
INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES. FROM
THE SWORN TO THE NON SWORN SIDE
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS SCOPE
AGAIN. TO RESOLVE A LOT OF THE
LAST SERIOUS CASES MORE
EFFECTIVELY MORE EFFICIENTLY IN
A MORE COST EFFECTIVE MANNER.
IN THE GOAL HERE IS AGAIN TO
FREE UP THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO DEAL WITH A VERY
SERIOUS CASE. FINALLY I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS SOME INTEREST. IN THE
SANCTIONING POLICY OF THE
MEDICAL BOARDS WE HAVE
SANCTIONING GUIDELINES AND AS
TO HOW THEY ARE USED TO THE
CONCERN THAT THE GUIDELINES ARE
NOT FOLLOWED APPROPRIATELY.
WILL BE HAPPY. VOIGTS THE
GUIDELINES OUR GUIDELINES ONLY
THEY'RE MEANT THERE TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO THE BOARD THEY ARE
NOT MEANT TO BE FOLLOWED
EXACTLY IN EVERY SINGLE CASE.
AND MANY TIMES THE GUIDANCE
ITSELF IS EXPRESSED AS A
SPECTRUM. ARE OF A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SANCTIONS. SETTLEMENT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PROCESS OF DEALING WITH
COMPLAINTS IT IS ACTUALLY
MANDATED THAT WE CONSIDER
SETTLEMENTS IN LAW AS PART OF
THE PROCESS. AND THAT THE
SETTLEMENT IS. OFTEN A VERY
ATTRACTIVE OPTION FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
US TO FULFILL. OUR MISSION OF
PUBLIC PROTECTION. IF WE CAN
IDENTIFY F. A SETTLEMENT WHICH
PROTECTS THE PUBLIC IT DOES SO
QUICKLY IN A COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER AND WITH CERTAINTY. IT
IS THE GUIDANCE IS. BASED ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT ALL
ELEMENTS OF THE CASE HAVE BEEN
PROVEN. AND THAT THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN THE CASE IN THE
REAL WORLD AFTER AN
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED.
AFTER THE RESPONDENT THE
LICENSEE HAS HAD A FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO STATE THEIR CASE
SOMETIMES THINGS ARE NOT ALWAYS
SO BLACK AND WHITE SOMETIMES
THE EXPERT WITNESSES ON THE
OTHER SIDE. ARE VERY PERSUASIVE
WE MUST TAKE ALL OF THAT INTO
ACCOUNT SOMETIMES WITNESSES DO
NOT SAY WHAT WE HAD ANTICIPATED
THAT THEY WOULD SAY. SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF FAIRNESS. IN THE
CONTEXT OF PURSUING THE PUBLIC
INTEREST SETTLEMENTS ARE OFTEN
VERY EFFECTIVE AND VERY
PRODUCTIVE BUT ALWAYS THEY ARE
DONE WITH THE NOTION OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION AT THE ABSOLUTE
PRIORITY AND WE HAVE PROCEDURAL
SAFEGUARDS THAT ARE IN PLACE
SETTLEMENTS CAN GO BEFORE THE
BOARD BOARD MEMBERS CAN RAISE
QUESTIONS THEY CAN- THEY CAN
OBJECT. THOSE OBJECTIONS ARE
CONSIDERED AN IT IS FREQUENTLY
THE CASE. THAT THE SETTLEMENTS
ARE SET ASIDE AND PROPOSED
DECISIONS ARE SET ASIDE FOR
FURTHER CONSIDERATION UPON
BOARD DIRECTION WE WELCOME THAT
WE WELCOME CRITICAL ANALYSIS OF
ALL SETTLEMENTS WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WE LISTEN TO
THEIR ADVICE THEY HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
DECISION IS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD. AND I AM. BOB AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT PROCEDUES IN PLACE SO
THAT OTHER VIEWPOINTS CRITICAL
VIEWPOINTS CAN BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. THAT'S THE END OF MY
FORMAL PRESENTATION AND MYSELF
THE PRESIDENT VICE PRESIDENT
AND OUR SENIOR STAFF HERE. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MR PACIFICO- IS- IS
KATHLEEN NICHOLS GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING US AS WELL. YES
THANK YOU A MISS NICHOLS YOU
ARE THE DEPUTY CHIEF FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DIVISION OF. INVESTIGATION
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATION
UNIT FIVE CORRECT. YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S KATHLEEN
NICHOLS I AM THE DEPUTY CHIEF
FOR THE HEALTH QUALITY
INVESTIGATION UNIT ALSO
REFERRED TO AS H. YOU ARE YOU
AT THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
I MUST WARN PEACE OFFICER WITH
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION EXPERIENCE WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND THE AGE
YOU ARE YOU ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU TODAY
AND PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
EIGHT SHORT YEARS AND BEST TO
GET A PROCESS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. AS YOU MAY REMEMBER IN
JULY TWENTY FOURTEEN ALSO ONE
INVESTIGATORS AND SUPPORT STAFF
WERE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO DCAS DIVISION
UP INVESTIGATION. THE BOARD
SUNSET BILL AT THE TIME SB
THREE OH FOUR CREATED THE
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATION
UNIT AT THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION. H. YOU ARE YEAR
IS COME. OF NINETY SEVEN SWORN
POSITIONS WHICH INCLUDES
SEVENTY NINE SWORN
INVESTIGATORS. AND EIGHTEEN
SWORN SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
WHO INVESTIGATE AND SUPERVISED
CASES FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD.
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD
PODIATRY BOARD AND THE
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT WORK. EACH
YEAR YOU ALSO EMPLOYS THIRTY
THREE PART TIME MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS WHO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE INVESTIGATORS. TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL EXPERTISE AND
REVIEW OF THE EVIDENCE GATHERED
INVESTIGATION. WHAT TWELVE
FIELD OFFICES LOCATED STATEWIDE
INVESTIGATORS RECEIVE REFERRALS
FROM THE BOARDSAND INVESTIGATE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE AND PENAL CODE.
BEFORE TWENTY NINETEEN PURSUANT
TO LAW THE MEDICAL BOARD
UTILIZED A VERTICAL ENFORCEMENT
PROSECUTION MODEL ALSO KNOWN AS
B. E. FOR THE PROGRAMS WITHIN
DCA THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS THE PROSECUTOR OF THE
ENFORCEMENT CASES. ESTABLISHED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THE V.
MODEL REQUIRED THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
INVESTIGATION ACTIVITIES AS
WELL AS THE PROSECUTION
ACTIVITIES. ATTORNEYS
GENERAL AND H. SURE YOU
INVESTIGATORS WERE JOINTLY
ASSIGNED TO AN INVESTIGATION
FROM THE OUTSET. THIS TEAM
APPROACH WAS INTENDED TO
ENCOURAGE EARLY COORDINATION
AND FASTER DECISIONS AND CASE
FILINGS AS YOU MAY REMEMBER ME
IT WAS DISCUSSED DURING THE
BOARD LAST SUNSET REVIEW AND
WAS ULTIMATELY REPEALED AND
LAW. ALTHOUGH BE IT WAS
REPEALED THERE ARE CASES WHERE
AN INDIVIDUAL MAY BE A DANGER
TO THE PUBLIC WHERE THE MEDICAL
BOARD OR H. DO YOU ARE YOU WILL
REQUEST FOR THE CASE TO BE WORK
JOINT. TOGETHER IN THESE CASES
THE H. FOUR U. INVESTIGATOR
WORKS WITH THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO INVESTIGATE THE CASE
EXPEDITIOUSLY IN ORDER TO
GATHER EVIDENCE TO REQUEST A
SUSPENSION ORDER. SINCE THE
ELIMINATION OF ME AND TWENTY
NINETEEN ONCE A CASE IS
REFERRED TO ENSURE YOU FOR
INVESTIGATION BY THE BOARD
INVESTIGATORS INTERVIEWED THE
COMPLAINANT AND WITNESSES
OBTAIN CERTIFIED MEDICAL
RECORDS AND OTHER EVIDENCE.
SOME CASE TYPES REQUIRE
DRAFTING SUBPOENAS FOR RECORDS
OBTAINING URINE SAMPLES FOR
DRUG TOXICOLOGY SCREENS STUDY
NOT MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
EXAMINATIONS TO DETERMINE IF
IT'S A SESSION IS SAFE TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE. CONDUCTING
PHARMACY AUDITS UNDER COVER
OPERATIONS. AND ISSUING SEARCH
WARRANTS. AFTERTHE END IN FOR
IS JUST. ALL EVER IS A BY
DISTRICT MEDICAL CONSULTANT
PHYSICIAN WHO WORKS IN THE
FIELD OFFICES WITH THE
INVESTIGATORS AND WHO WAS ALSO
PRESENT FOR THE INTERVIEW OF
THE SUBJECT POSITION. ONCE ALL
THE EVIDENCE IS OBTAINED AND
ALL THE INTERVIEWS ARE
CONDUCTED THE CASES THEN
REVIEWED BY AN EXPERT REVIEWER
WHO IS A PHYSICIAN AND THE SAME
MEDICAL SPECIALTY OUR PRACTICE
AREA. I WAS THE SUBJECT
POSITION. THE BOARD'S EXPERT
REVIEWERS ARE PHYSICIANS IN
GOOD STANDING WHO CONTRACT WITH
THE BOARD TO PROVIDE
INDEPENDENT AND IMPARTIAL CASE
REVIEW. EXPERTS REVIEW THE CASE
MATERIALS AND EVIDENCE GATHERED
BY THE IT SURE YOU
INVESTIGATORS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT A DEPARTURE FROM
THE STANDARD OF CARE OCCURRED
AND TO PROVIDE A WRITTEN
OPINION. REDUCING INVESTIGATION
TIMELINES IT'S MY NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY. FOR EXAMPLE I
RECENTLY USED EXISTING
POSITIONS TO CREATE A NEW
EXPERT PROCUREMENT UNIT D. P.
U. THIS NEW YEAR THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AND CONSISTS OF
FOUR ANALYSTS AND A NON SWORN
SUPERVISOR. EPA NOW HANDLES THE
ENTIRE EXPERT PROCESS FOR THE
MAJORITY OF CHEESE TYPES THAT
NEED EXPERT REVIEW. I'M ALREADY
STARTING TO SEE THE BENEFITS OF
THIS DEDICATED UNIT TO THE
INVESTIGATOR CASELOADS AND
EXPERT OPINIONS RETURNING
FASTER. I AM ALSO UTILIZING
THIS NEW UNIT AS A QUALITY
REVIEW POINT. I AM PERSONALLY
REVIEW IN EVERY CASE THAT IS
SUBMITTED FOR EXPERT REVIEW
ALONG WITH THE IF YOU MANAGER
TO ENSURE THAT IT SURE YOU
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE TO
PROCEED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. AFTER EXPERT
REVIEW THE COMPLETED
INVESTIGATION IS RETURNED TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD. IF THERE IS
A VIOLATION IN THE CASE
PROCEEDS TO THE PROSECUTORIAL
PATHWAY. WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. THIS
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF H.
SURE YOU INVESTIGATION PROCESS
AND I'M ALSO HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MS NICHOLS-
WHAT WE HEAR FROM CHRISTIANITY
TO MINGUS DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WILL SHE BE SPEAKING TODAY. YES
SIR CHRIS CHRISTIE. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SURE ROCK CARILLO
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU MY NAME IS
CHRISTIANA DOMINGUEZ AND I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS WITH ME
TODAY ON THE PHONE IS ALSO
CHRIS RYAN CHIEF OF OUR
DIVISION OF OPERATIONS. I'M
PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU THIS
MORNING TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT WORK OF THE
HEALTH QUALITY ENFORCEMENT
SECTION FOR EACH HEARING AID.
WITHIN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IN PROSECUTING CASES ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR MISSION OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS TO
VIGOROUSLY PROTECT THE HEALTH
WELFARE AND SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
PROVIDE QUALITY LEGAL SERVICES
TO THE STATE AGENCY CLIENTS AND
REGULATORY BOARDS. SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THE H. Q. WE
HAS PROSECUTED MEDICAL MORE
CASES IN ADDITION TO SEVERAL
OTHER HEALTH CARE OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES. ANOTHER SECTION OUR
OFFICE PROSECUTES CASES FOR
OTHER REGULATORY BOARDS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. AS YOU ARE AWARE OUR
OFFICE PROSECUTION OF
PHYSICIANS FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD IT RECEIVES IN REVIEWS
EVIDENCE COLLECTED BY
INVESTIGATORS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATION
NETWORK YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT.
IF SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IS FOUND
IN THE CASE FILE MATTERS
ASSIGNED TO DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ADAG. WHO DROPS THE
ACCUSATION WHICH IS A DOCUMENT
SIMILAR TO A COMPLAINTS OR
INDICTMENTS. WHICH IS THEN
PRESENTED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SIGNATURE. I
HEARING BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE FOR
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS IS THEN SCHEDULED. SHE
SHE'S GENERALLY NEXT TAKE PLACE.
H. Q. WE REPRESENTS THE MEDICAL
BOARD BUT A SETTLEMENT FOSTER
APPROVED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR POSITION
WILL APPEAR WITH THEIR OWN
REPRESENTED. THE MAJORITY OF
CASES RESOLVED AT THIS STAGE
THERE ARE STIPULATED SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT IS GUIDED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES. IF NO SETTLEMENT
CAN BE REACHED THE CASE
PROCEEDS TO HEARING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
DROPPED THE PROPOSED DECISION
THAT GOES TO THE MEDICAL BOARD.
THE BOARD CAN ADOPTED THE
PROPOSED DECISION AS WRITTEN OR
INCREASE OR DECREASE THE
DISCIPLINARY PENALTY. IF THERE
IS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
SUSTAIN A FILING DISCIPLINE IN
THE CASE OF WILL EITHER BE
RETURNED FOR ADDITIONAL-INVESTIGATION AND INFORMATION
OR REJECTED. THIS IS BECAUSE
PURSUANT TO CASE LAW
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST A
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN OR REQUIRE
A CLEAR CONVINCING. EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD GIVEN THAT THESE CASES
SEEK TO REVOKE OR IMPACTED
POSITIONS LICENSE AND WHICH
THEY HAVE A PROPERTY INTEREST.
THIS IS WHY WE MUST FACE
ACCUSATIONS ON COMPLETELY
RELIABLE AND ADMISSIBLE
EVIDENCE THAT ALLOWS US TO MAKE
A REASONED AND FAIR
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER
CHARGES SHOULD BE FILED. TAGS
REVIEW VOLUMES OF COMPLEX
MEDICAL EVIDENCE TO DETERMINE
SUFFICIENCY TO SUPPORT THE
FILING OF AN ACCUSATION. RELY
MEDICAL EXPERTS WHO REVIEWED
CASES AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE'S A DEVIATION FROM
THE STANDARD OF CARE BY THE
ACCUSED PHYSICIAN. YOU SHOULD
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE COMPLAINTS
FOR SOME OF THE MOST COMPLEX
TECHNICAL AND LUMINOUS MATTERS
OF ANY OF THE CA SPORTS. EVERY
REJECT THE CASE WE PROVIDE A
DETAILED LEGAL MEMO TO THE
CLIENT DETAILING THE LEGAL
REASONS THE CASE CANNOT BE
FILED THIS IS GENERALLY DUE TO
A LACK STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
THE TIMING FOR LEGAL REVIEW
DECISIONS MADE VERY DO THE
COMPLEXITY OF CASES REQUIRE
EXTENSIVE OR COMPLICATED
MEDICAL RECORDS EXPERT OPINIONS
AND OTHER EVIDENCE. FURTHER
GIVEN THAT THE INVESTIGATIONS
ARE HANDED OFF TO US BY THE
HEALTH QUALITY INVESTIGATION
INTO DCA SOMETIMES THESE FILES
CAN TAKE LONGER TO WORK OUT IF
THEY COULD COME TO US WITH
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
PROSECUTE UNDER THE CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE STANDARD OF
LOS. SECONDLY MY OVERVIEW OF
COURSE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MR MINGUS
WE'RE- NOW I'VE BELIEVE- WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE PRESENTATIONS
UNDER PART A OF OUR AGENDA. I'M
GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
BEFORE I DO I'D LIKE TO ASK- A
FEW OF MY OWN. BEFORE I FORGET
THIS ONE- MISTER MAGOO'S IN THE
CASE OF DISCIPLINE OF
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS AND
WHETHER IT'S MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE OR OR SOME OTHER
SIMILAR ALLEGED OFFENSE OR
VIOLATION. WHY IS THERE A
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THAT
NECESSARILY APPLIES AS OPPOSED
TO A CASE IN THE CIVIL COURT
FOR MALPRACTICE FOR DAMAGES OR
PERHAPS A CRIMINAL CASE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR-
THE DOCUMENTATIONS AS
PRESCRIBED BY STATUTE SO THAT'S
OUR POLICY CHOICES. MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE- I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY-
IN FRONT OF ME TODAY FOR THAT
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO THAT AND PROVIDE YOUR
OFFICE WITH MORE INFORMATION
WHAT IS THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS I ASSUME IT'S IN
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE IS SUPPOSED TO THE- A
CIVIL CODE OR CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE. YES SIR I BELIEVE IT
IS- BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE ONE EIGHT Q. THIRTY POINT
FIVE I BELIEVE IT IS THREE
YEARS- I'M GONNA TRY TO.
BACKTRACK NOT VERY QUICKLY AS
WELL THE THING IS THAT THIS IS
NOT KNOW YOUR BIBLE I JUST
WANNA. MAKE SURE THAT- THAT WE
HAVE A IDEA ABOUT HAT AND WE
MAY NEED TO REVISIT THAT AT
SOME POINT BECAUSE IT OCCURS TO
ME THAT. IF OF POSITIONING-
COMMIT SERIOUS MALPRACTICE AND
FOR SOME REASON AND DEALING
WITH MEDICALLY ON
SOPHISTICATED- CONSUMERS THEM
THE MATTER IS NOT BROUGHT TO
THE ATTENTION OF THE OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD. TO NOT BE ABLE
TO TAKE ACTION- I WOULD THINK
SHOULD BE TROUBLESOME TO SOME
IF NOT MANY BUT YOU'VE ANSWERED
IT I APPRECIATE IT LET ME HAVE
SOME. SOME MORE GENERAL
QUESTIONS SO OFTEN THE DATA
YOU'VE PROVIDED AND CERTAINLY
THE DATA THAT WE'VE BEEN
PROVIDED IN OUR BACKGROUND
MATERIAL INDICATES THAT YOU
WILL. RECEIVE US SOMEWHERE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS HERE. WHEN
THE MEDICAL BOARD RECEIVES OF
THESE COMPLAINTS DOES SOME
AGENT OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
ATTEMPT TO REACH OUT TO THE
COMPLAINANTS AS PART OF A-
COMPLAINT CLARIFICATION PROCESS
TO. FERRET OUT ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT. AS A SET OF
PATIENTS OF A CONSUMER. MIGHT
HAVE THAT MIGHT BEAR ON THE
INITIAL DETERMINATION. AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO REFER THE
COMPLAINT. FROM THE CENTRAL
COMPLAINT UNIT. TO THE
INVESTIGATION TEAM.ANYONE US
TAKE THE- EL PROCESO QUE WILL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION DIRECTED TO OUR HEAD
OF ENFORCEMENT WHO DEALS WITH
THESE THINGS ON A DAILY BASIS
TRYING TO JONES. MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY
NAME IS JENNA JONES AND WHEN A
COMPLAINT IS INITIALLY RECEIVED
BY THE BOARD OFFICERS. IT IS
INITIALLY TRIAGE TO BUYER
COMPLAINT A CENTRAL COMPLAINT
UNIT AND- THAT IS WHEN THEY ARE
LOOKING AT THE COMPLAINT THAT
HAS BEEN RECEIVED FROM THE
PUBLIC MEMBER- OTHER AGENCY OR
MANDATORY REPORTER. AND WE
REACH OUT. TO OBTAIN A RELEASE
SO WE MAY OBTAIN THE MEDICAL
RECORDS- AND IF ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS NEEDED THAT IS
WHEN WE ALSO REACH OUT TO THE
COMPLAINANT AND ASKED FOR THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. WOULD
YOU SAY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
IS NEEDED I GUESS YOU KNOW. WE
HAD A SECRETARY OF DEFENSE ONCE
YOU USED TO SAY YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW. IS A IS A
IS A BODY AN AGENT OF THE
BOARD. ASKING SOME PRELIMINARY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMPLAINANT OR
COMPLAINTS AT THIS POINT IN THE
PROCESS. TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE IS ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
OR QUICK QUESTIONS THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ANSWERED EVEN THOUGH
NOT ASKED. AS PART OF THIS
INITIAL PROCESS- YES AND I WILL
SAY THAT A NUMBER OF OUR
INITIAL COMPLAINTS COMING
ANONYMOUSLY. SO THAT IS
DIFFICULT AT TIMES- ALSO IF WE
DON'T HAVE A PATIENT NAME
THAT'S WHEN WE MAY BE TRYING TO
REACH OUT TO DETERMINE WHO THE
ACTUAL PATIENT WAS. SO DO I
UNDERSTAND THE ANSWER TO BE%
THAT IN EVERY CASE WHERE WE
HAVE THE NAME OF A- COMPLAINANT
TOUCH TO A COMPLAINT BEFORE THE
MEDICAL BOARD. THAT IS RECEIVED
BY THE CENTRAL COMPLAINTS UNIT
THAT AN AGENT OF THE BOARD
REACHES OUT PERSONALLY. HI AND
SPEAKS TO THE COMPLAINANT TO
FERRET OUT ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT THE
COMPLAINANT. YOU MIGHT HAVE OR
MIGHT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. TO
BRITAIN THAT MAY BEAR ON THE
DECISION WHETHER OR NOT TO
REFER THE COMPLAINT TO THE
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WILL SPEAK VERY
HONESTLY THAT IF THERE IS
ENOUGH INFORMATION AND WE HAVE
A SIGNED RELEASE WITH THE
DOCUMENTATION THAT CAME IN WITH
A COMPLAINT WE MAY NOT REACH
OUT TO THEM. UNLESS IT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION OR THERE
ARE QUESTIONS RAISED BETTER IN%
THE COMPLAINT. WE DO REACH OUT
AND ADVISE THEM BY LETTER THAT
WE RECEIVED A COMPLAINT AND
THEY- SO THEY CAN REGION AND
COMMUNICATE WITH THE AN INITIAL
ANALYST IF THEY WISH. WITH JUST
A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE WITHOUT A COMPLAINANT
INTERVIEW OR AT LEAST SOME IN
PERSON CONTACT WERE SOME GIVEN
TAKE. KERR'S ISN'T IT POSSIBLE
THAT. THE CENTRAL COMPLAINT
UNIT IN MAKING THE DECISION TO
REFER NOT REFER. MAY NOT HAVE
ALL OF THE INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO WERE BEARING ON
THE COMPLAINT FOR EXAMPLE. A
PHYSICIAN'S FAILURE TO CHART A
PARTICULAR PROCEDURE OR ISSUE.
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF THE
COMPLAINT. IF THE ALLEGATION
WAS THAT EIGHTY PER SIXTY JR
WAS NOT CHARTED AND WE HAVE THE
COMPLAINT AND WE RETAIN THE
MEDICAL RECORDS AND THERE'S A
DISCREPANCY THAT WOULD MOVE
FORWARD TO OUR MEDICAL
CONSULTANT FOR REVIEW- TO
DETERMINE IF IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
MOVE FORWARD FOR A FORMAL
INVESTIGATION WELL I'M NOT
GOING TO BELABOR THIS ISSUE BUT
YOU KNOW AS A NON HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. ALBEIT OF ONCE A LONG
TIME AGO LAWYER I WOULDN'T KNOW
TO ALLEGE THAT SOMETHING AS
NOT CHARTED YOU ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD WOULD KNOW PHYSICIANS
WOULD KNOW NURSES MIGHT KNOW
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS MIGHT NOW
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IDEAS
PERHAPS AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THAT THE MOBILE MEDICAL
BOARD CONSIDER PERHAPS TAKING A
LOOK AT THIS INITIAL SCREENING
PROCESS BECAUSE IF YOU WERE
SCREENING BASED ON THE FACE OF
THE COMPLAINT. CAN YOU SEND A
LETTER TO A ROAD RELATIVELY
UNSOPHISTICATED MEDICAL
CONSUMER THE CONSUMER MAY NOT
KNOW WHAT INFORMATION IT IS
THAT YOU MIGHT NEED IN ORDER TO
PROPERLY EVALUATE THE
CONSUMER'S COMPLAINT AND
PERHAPS A MORE DETAILED- MOST
OF THE TIME IN PERSON CONTACT
MIGHT BE MORE PRODUCTIVE-
CHAIRMAN EUROCOIN IS WELL TAKEN
AND I WILL- GO ABOUT SEEING
WHAT CHANGES WE NEED TO MAKE TO
INCORPORATE THAT LET ME MOVE ON
TO- I'M TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
ON. HOW MANY CASES- ACTUALLY
PROCEED. THROUGH THE FORMAL
DISCIPLINE PROCESS AT WHAT
STAGE OF OUR NOTES AND MY
MATERIAL REFLECTED THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY.
THERE WERE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN CASES REFERRED TO
FORMAL DISCIPLINE OUT OF THAT
TEN THOUSAND PLUS. BUCKET OF
COMPLAINTS. GIVE OR TAKE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN I THINK THE
NUMBER ON YOUR POWER POINT WAS
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER I DON'T
HAVE THE POWER POINT FRONT OF
ME. BUT OF THOSE CASES REFERRED
TO FORMAL DISCIPLINE HOW MANY
OF THOSE CASES RESULTED. IN A
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY-
IF YOU CAN BEAR WITH ME I'M
SORRY I'M TRYING TO GET MY. SO.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT- OF THE CASES THAT WERE
AT THE STAGE READY FOR A
SETTLEMENT THERE WERE 84% OF
THE CASES- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT AFTER AN ACCUSATION. THERE
WERE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
CASES THAT REACHED A
SETTLEMENT- ACCORDING TO THE
DIAGRAM THAT YOU SHOWED IF I
COULD JUST CLARIFY- EVEN THOUGH
WE STARTED WITH TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED COMPLAINTS COMING
IN DURING THAT PROCESS. THE
THREE HUNDRED OR FOUR AT BOTTOM
NUMBER OF CASES THAT WERE.
RESOLVED WENT TO FORMAL
DISCIPLINE THOSE WERE AND MAY
HAVE BEEN FROM WHAT THE PRIOR
YEARS AND HAD JUST REACHED THE
POINT OF SETTLEMENT. RIGHT BUT
IF YOUR AVERAGES ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND THE- IT'S ALL SORT OF
RELATIVISM. YES SIR SO YOU HAD
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
THAT WENT TO STIPULATED
SETTLEMENT AND MY RECORDS%
REFLECT- THAT YOU HAD ABOUT
FORTY FOR OF THE TOTAL BUCKET
OF COMPLAINTS FORTY FOUR CASES
THAT ACTUALLY WENT TO TRIAL.
YES OKAY. GO. SYSTEM THE
QUESTION REGARDING THE
PROCESSING PROCESSING TIME I
UNDESTAND FROM THE POWER POINT
PRESENTATION THAT THE TIME
BETWEEN RECEIPT OF COMPLAINT
AND COMPLETION OF INVESTIGATION
VERY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED PLUS
DAYS DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE CASE. HOW
LONG DOES IT ACTUALLY TAKE TO
PROCESS THE CASE FROM
INVESTIGATION COMPLETION ON THE
AVERAGE TO- STIPULATED
SETTLEMENT. I AM I DON'T HAVE
THAT NUMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD I'M SORRY OKAY WERE YOU
CAN PROVIDE THAT TO OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE STAFFS
WHEN YOU WERE ABLE TO SECURE IT
THE SAME QUESTION FOR
COMPLETION OF TRIAL HOW LONG
DOES IT ACTUALLY HAS IT ON THE
AVERAGE DOES IT TAKE TO PROCESS
THE CASE FROM COMPLETION OF
INVESTIGATION TO COMPLETION OF
TRIAL. YOU MAY NOT HAVE THAT
QUESTION INTERNISTS I'VE DO YOU
HAVE IT. I'M SORRY I DO NOT
HAVE IT MIGHT. THAT'S FINE IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT TO THE
COMMITTEES STE THE STAFF OF OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES WHEN YOU
HAVE A CHANCE SERVICES QUESTION
OF OTHER BOARDS BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE TIME.
STANDARDS AND TIMELINES AND I
REALIZE SOME OF THESE-
TIMELINES ARE ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE SPECIFIC CONTROL THE
MEDICAL BOARD BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
TO TRACK HOW LONG IT TAKES. TO
ACTUALLY PROCESS COMPLAINTS.
THROUGH COMPLETION OF THE
PROCESS WHICH EITHER INCLUDES
REFERRAL TO FORMAL DISCIPLINE.
AND STIPULATED SETTLEMENT OR
REFERRAL TO FORMAL DISCIPLINE
AND COMPLETION OF TRIAL. ON
THE- STIPULATED SETTLEMENT
PROCESS HOW I KNOW THAT WAS
COVERED BRIEFLY DURING THE
POWER POINT PRESENTATION HOW
DOES THAT PROCESS ACTUALLY
WORK- WHO REVIEWS. AND
INITIALLY APPROVES THE
STIPULATED SETTLEMENTS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THREE- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND
MYSELF- MEET EACH WEEK TO
DISCUSS THE VARIOUS CASES AND
WE REVIEWED THE- SETTLEMENT
PROPOSAL- OF RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE. AT THAT POINT WE
DEVELOP WE REFER REFERENCE
GUIDELINES WE REVIEW THE
INFORMATION RIVER VIEW THE
DETAILS OF THE- A- STRONG
POINTS OF THE CASE AND THE
POSSIBLE WEAK POINTS AND WE-
GRANT AUTHORITY TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO- FOR
SETTLEMENT. AND THE TERMS OF AT
THAT WE WISH TO HAVE WELL IT
WAS SORT OF A SETTLEMENT ONCE
THE PROPOSED SETTLEMENT. THAT'S
PROPOSED TO BE INCLUDED IN A
STIPULATED. SETTLEMENT I GUESS
AGREEMENT WHICH I AS A MATTER
OF MY UNDERSTANDING INVOLVES AN
ADMISSION BY THE PHYSICIAN AS
TO THE COMMISSION OF THE ACT.
AND OTHER OTHER ADMISSIONS AND
STATEMENTS- REVIEWS AND
APPROVES THAT OF THE DOES THE
MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF. IN ITS
ENTIRETY OR DOES THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO DELEGATE THAT
AUTHORITY INITIALLY TWO PANELS
OR GROUPS OF BOARD MEMBERS-
ONCE THE INITIAL STIPULATION IS
ENTERED WITH THE SUBJECT AND
THE BOARD ON BEHALF OF THE AG'S.
ERNIE JOURNALS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD THAT DOCUMENT IS
FORWARDED TO A PANEL OF BOARD
MEMBERS THERE ARE TWO PANELS-
EACH OF THE PANELS REVIEWS.
BASED ON THE ALPHABET SO ONE
PANEL REVIEW THAT CASE REVIEW
THE STIPULATED SETTLEMENT AND-
MAY APPROVE. OR REJECT IT- AND
IF THEY WILL HOLD IT TO
PREFERRED FOR IF MORE TWO OR
MORE PEOPLE HOLD THE CASE IT
WILL GO TO THE- BOARD MEETING
WHERE THEY CAN HAVE MORE FORMAL
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT. CANNEL AND
THE COMPOSITION OF THE PANELS
OF. THEMSELVES HELLO HOWEVER
THOSE PANELS COMPRISED. TWO
MEMBERS FIVE MEMBERS SIX
MEMBERS FIVE DOCTORS TO PUBLIX-
THIS WEB COULD YOU HELP ME WITH
THE. THEY HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST
FOUR MEMBERS PER PANEL AND HOW
MANY MEMBERS DEPENDS ON HOW OF
FULL THE REPORT IS RIGHT NOW WE
ARE SHORT AND NUMBER OF MEMBERS
ON THE BOARD. AND SO THE PANELS
ARE NOT COMPLETE BUT THEY EACH
HAVE AT LEAST FOUR MEMBERS AND
THEY ARE- MORE PHYSICIAN NUMBER
STAND PUBLIC MEMBERS. AND TWO
WERE TWO MEMBERS OF EACH PANEL
TWO MEMBERS OF A PANEL CAN HOLD
THE STIPULATED SETTLEMENT AND
REFER IT TO. THE BOARD THE FULL
BOARD FOR CONSIDERATION. NOW
ADD INITIALLY. WHEN THE- CASE
COMES IN FOR THE MEMBERS TO
VOTE ON THEY DO THAT
ELECTRONICALLY. AND TO GIVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL HOLD IT
THEN IT GOES TO DOT PANEL FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSION. IN THE CASE
OF A PROPOSED SETTLEMENT THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
WORKED ON THAT CASE WILL BE
INVITED TO COME IN AND SPEAK TO
THE PANEL TO PROVIDE FURTHER
DETAILS. AT THAT POINT WHERE
MEMBERS CAN VOTE TO ADOPT IT-
ASKED CHANGE THE TERMS. FOUR
TWO REJECTED AND ASKED THAT THE
MATTER BE SET FOR HEARING. OKAY
PERFECT LET ME GO OVER ONE
FINAL MATTER AND THEN I'M GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS ON. SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
ENFORCEMENT BUT YOU KNOW REGARD
RIG WITH REGARD TO THE BOARDS
DESPITE PROCESS SOME OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT SOME OF US HAVE
RECEIVED STAFFERS RECEIVED THE
GO TO THE CONTENTION THAT THE
BOARD HAS BEEN. SLOW TO ACT
WHEN IT EITHER KNEW OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN OF CASES OF ALLEGED
PHYSICIAN MISCONDUCT. THERE WAS
A REPORT IN A BAY AREA
NEWSPAPER QUITE RECENTLY- WHERE
IT WAS ALLEGED THAT THE
COUNTY'S CHIEF PEDIATRICIAN.
HAD SEXUALLY ABUSED YOUNG BOYS
AGES SIX TO SIXTEEN IN HIS
FOSTER CARE ARRANGEMENT AND AS
PER AS PART OF HIS PATIENT-
CADRE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT
ALTHOUGH THE COUNTY PROSECUTOR
DIDN'T CHARGE HIM. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
NOTIFIED LOCAL CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS AS THE DA HAS A DUTY
TO DO. SINCE THIS CHIEF
PEDIATRICIAN WAS A WITNESS IN
CRIMINAL CASES BUT THERE WAS
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THE
PHYSICIAN COMMITTED MULTIPLE
CRIMES OF MORAL TURPITUDE
SPECIFICALLY SEXUAL ASSAULTS.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SAME
YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
COUNTY FIRED HIM FROM HIS CHIEF
PEDIATRICIAN OPPOSITION AND
THEN IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES BAR THE
PHYSICIAN FROM WORKING WITH ANY
CHILDREN OR ADULTS. IN STATE
LICENSED FACILITIES. THE
NEWSPAPER REPORTED THAT IT WAS
NOT UNTIL FEBRUARY. NINETEEN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. TEN
YEARS LATER. THAT A MEDICAL
BOARD ACCUSATION WAS FILED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. SEEKING
TO REVOKE THE PHYSICIAN'S
LICENSE. OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE
NEWS REPORTS OBVIOUSLY PROBABLY
MANY IF NOT MOST OF OU WERE
AROUND IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE
IS A LOT OF GOVERNMENT ACTION
INVOLVED HERE WITH THE NUMBER
OF MANDATED REPORTERS OVER THAT
TEN YEAR PERIOD SO MY QUESTION
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD. IF YOU
CAN ANSWER. IS WHY IT TOOK SO
LONG. WELL SENATOR THE SIMPLE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS THAT
THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN ONLY
REACT TO THE EVIDENCE INTO THE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE MADE TO US.
AND HERE ACCORDING TO WHAT THE
UP FOR INFORMATION THAT I HAD
IT WAS ONLY. UNTIL THE
COMPLAINT WAS MADE TO US AT A
MUCH SUBSEQUENT TIME THAT HE WE
HAD ANY BASIS TO ACT AT ALL
THAT PREVIOUS TO THAT POINT THE
PRIMARY JURISDICTION WAS WITH
THE- CRIPPLED THE VISION OF THE
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE WHERE IT
SHOULD RIGHTLY BE. AND THAT
MEXICO ARE MADE TO US WE CAN
INVESTIGATE I HATE TO INTERRUPT
BUT THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE TO ME. THE MEDICAL BOARD
ITSELF CAN INITIATE A COMPLAINT
CAN YOU NOT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT FOR A CONSUMER. WARRICK
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
FILE A COMPLAINT. UNDER YOUR
SKIN CAN THE BOARD ITSELF NOT
INITIATE A COMPLAINT AGAINST A
POSITION. WE CAN INITIATE A
COMPLAINT WE CONDITION AGAINST
TO A PHYSICIAN OR WE CAN
INITIATE AN INVESTIGATION
PROVIDEDWE HAVE THE EVIDENCE
TO DO SO BUT WE ARE NOT A
PRIMARY INVESTIGATIVE BODY. WE
DON'T GO OUT SEARCHING FOR
COMPLAINTS IF THINGS COME TO
OUR ATTENTION THROUGH WHATEVER
MEANS OF COURSE WE CAN FOLLOW
UP ON THEM. BUT LARGELY WE ARE
REACTIVE BODY WE HAVE TO WAIT
FOR A COMPLAINT IT WASN'T UNTIL
MUCH LATER IN THE PROCESS THAT
THE INFORMATION CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION WHICH ALLOWED US TO
ACT UPON IT. WELL I. I'LL BE
INTERESTED TO SEE THE REACTION
OF SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES TO THE
STATEMENT THAT YOU ARE REACT
YOU ARE A REACTIVE BODY. SEEMS
TO ME THAT IS A STATE LICENSING
AND REGULATING ENTITY. YOU HAVE
A DUTY. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THAT CERTAINLY IN YOUR MISSION
AS YOUR PRIMARY MISSION YOU
HAVE THE- AUTHORITY TO INITIATE
COMPLAINTS. YOU HAVE AS PER
YOUR POWER POINT A- IS TO BE A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATORS IN VARIOUS UNITS
TO CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND-
I WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU THAT AS
PART OF YOUR- YOUR OWN INTERNAL
REVIEW PROCESS THAT YOU MAY
WANT TO TAKE A LOOK. AT THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE TO HAVE DID IT
AND IF NOTHING ELSE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MANDATED REPORTING
RULES WHEN IT COMES TO
PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL PRACTICE
BECAUSE- SOMEWHERE ALONG THIS
TEN YEAR PASSED. THE PROCESS
BROKE DOWN WHETHER IT WAS AND I
REALIZE YOU WILL PROBABLY
WEREN'T THERE. BUT I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE INSTITUTION ITSELF-
THERE NEEDS TO BE A WAY TO-
RECOVER INFORMATION AND TO
EVALUATE INFORMATION- AND TO
PROCEED WITH THAT INFORMATION
WHERE- WHERE THE FACTS. DICTATE
THAT ACTION IS APPROPRIATE. I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES NOW AND- LET THEM
CONTINUE TO ASK QUESTIONS AS
APPROPRIATE CENTER PAM. THANK
YOU I CHAIR OFTEN SHARE LOW
ACTUALLY- I DO HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS BUT MAYBE FIRST
QUESTION I JUST FOLLOW UP WITH.
THE. WHAT'S CENTER ROCK PASSED-
SO JUST TO CLARIFY- MEDICAL
WARD ICE I DO UNDERSTAND IS
SOMETIMES CHALLENGED. IN TERMS
OF- IDENTIFYING- THE ISSUES IT
MAY BE GOING ON- YOU MENTIONED
CERTAINLY- WHEN THINGS THAT
FIGURES INVESTIGATION ARE OUR
COMPLAINTS AND UC'S MANY IS YOU
FELT DOCUMENTED HERE. BUT SHE
JUST ALSO MAYBE PERHAPS DISCUSS
A LITTLE BIT FOR EXAMPLE- HE
WHAT OTHER SOURCES OF
INFORMATION MEDICAL BOARD GETS
THAT MIGHT TRIGGER COMPLAINTS
SO- I THINK- LEGAL ACTIONS
AGAINST PHYSICIANS- WHETHER
CIVIL OR CRIMINAL TO THOSE-
COME IF IT INVOLVES A- PERSON
LICENSED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA DOES. COME TO THE
BOARD- OR ARE SOMEONE SCANNING
FOR THAT OF COURSE THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS THAT SHOW UP IN
OTHER TYPES OF DATABASES I
THINK- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MAINTAIN CERTAIN DATABASES. AS
WELL- IT. A RELATION TO CERTAIN
TYPES OF- BEHAVIOR BY
PHYSICIANS OR OTHER PROVIDERS.
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE ROLE OF
THOSE TYPES OF SOURCES OF
INFORMATION AND POTENTIALLY
TRIGGERING INVESTIGATIONS OR
COMPLAINTS- SEPARATE FROM SO
YOU'LL OF ARTICLES EIGHTY CURES
DATABASE RIGHT YOU SEE
SOMEONE'S PRESCRIBING A LARGE
AMOUNT NOW THAT'S NOT A
COMPLAINT. OF IT SOMEONE'S
OUTSIDE OF THE RANGE OF THAN
YOU KNOW- IT IS IT- SO CAN YOU
JUST SPEAK TO YOUR PROCESSES
AND IN LOOKING AT THOSE SORT
DATASETS- AND I GUESS AND- ROTS
CASE WOULD BE- POTENTIALLY. I
ASSUME THERE WERE SOME CRIMINAL
OR CIVIL ACTION THAT TOOK BY
TAKING PLACE BY PROSECUTOR
MAYBE IT DIDN'T. NEED TO SPEAK
TO HOW THAT MIGHT TRIGGER
INVESTIGATIONS. YES WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
LOOK THERE ARE A WHOLE SERIES
OF DATABASES AND REPORTING
MANDATES THAT WE CAN USE TO
TRGGER- COMPLAINTS AND
INVESTIGATIONS. THERE'S A
DATABASE FOR EXAMPLE OF ALL
THIS WITH ACTIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE ACROSS THE STATE. MEDICAL
BOARDS IN ALL FIFTY STATES
THOSE COME TO US AND THEY GIVE
US NOTICE ABOUT A LICENSEE WHO
HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO AN ACTION
IN ANOTHER STATE. THERE A WHOLE
SERIES OF REPORTING MANDATES
DEALING WITH CIVIL ACTIONS IN
TERMS OF MLPRACTICE SUITS DALY
WITH THE RESTRICTION OF
PRIVILEGESTO PRACTICE AT A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS. THEY ALL COME TO
US THEY ARE ALL VERY USEFUL BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY IN ALL OF
THOSE WERE DEPENDED UPON THE
REPORTS. THAT COME IN TO US
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OUR
DIRECTOR ENFORCEMENT MS JONES.
IF YOU CAN OF SUPPLEMENT THAT
ANSWER AND ACTUALLY- BEFORE SHE
BEGINS- IN IN HER ANSWER COULD
SHE ALSO PERHAPS ADDRESS- BY
THE QUESTION OF HOW MANY
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN FIGURED BY THOSE DATABASES
ARE. NOW THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION- SEPARATE FROM AN
ACTUAL SOMEONE FILING A
COMPLAINT YOU KNOW DIRECTLY
WITH THE BOARD SIZE EVER
TRIGGERED AN INVESTIGATION ON
ITS OWN AND IF YES HOW MANY HOW
OFTEN DOES THAT HAPPEN. YEAH. I
THINK WE HAVE THAT RECORDED. IT
IS FIND THAT. CHART WE RECEIVED
A COMPLAINT FROM A NON OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES- MALPRACTICE
SETTLEMENTS. THAT ARE OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WE WERE
REPORTS OF THOSE- WE ENDED A
BEST BUT ON THE AND IT IS A
CLEAR IT DIDN'T SO USE A CIVIL
OF SIZE DO YOU WAY FOR SOMEONE
TO ACTUALLY YOU OR YOU USE IT
YOU GO OVER START AND- R. OR
NOT ARE YOU. LOOK AT IT MORE
DETAIL SO AT THAT ELECTION I
WANT TO TRY TO. DISCERN BETWEEN
SOMEONE ACTIVELY HAVING TO
SUBMIT SOMETHING TO SAY PLEASE
PLEASE PLEASE INVESTIGATE THIS
VERSES YOU'RE SCANNING THESE
DATASETS STUDIES SAID THE
STEEL- HOSPITAL STAFF YOU KNOW
CIVIL CASES IT CENTER AND
SAYING- WE SEE A PATH TO
SOMETHING HERE THAT WE THINK.
WE NEED TO START. BECAUSE A
JUDGE MADE A CERTAIN RULING
ARE- MEDICAL STAFF MADE A
CERTAIN RULING ABOUT. BEHAVIOR
OF A OF A LICENSEE- WELL IN THE
CASE OF MEDICAL MALPRACTICE
CASES- WE ARE NOT. SCANNING THE
COURT RECORDS IF SOMEONE IN-
IDENTIFY SOMETHING. FIRE TO THE
SETTLEMENT IS BEING REACHED WE
WILL LOOK INTO IT BUT- THERE IS
A MANDATORY REPORTING UNDER THE
EIGHT OH ONE POINT OH ONE
SECTION WHERE THEY HAVE TO
REPORT THE MALPRACTICE
SETTLEMENT AMOUNTS TO US- WE
ALSO HAVE- THE CORNERS
REPORTING CRIMINAL CHARGES ARE
REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED- THE
NUMBERS OF MALPRACTICE REPORTS
IN NIGHT IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY OR FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO. BUT I WILL BE
HONEST WE DO NOT- REGULARLY RUN
CHECKS ON THE CIVIL COURT
SYSTEM OF FORT CHECK FOR
MALPRACTICE CASES THAT MAY BE
PENDINGOKAY WELL ANY CITY BUT
YOU BUT YOU SAID YOU DO RECEIVE
REPORTS OF ANY ONE AND BY THE
WAY I SHOULD POINT OUT THE
RESEARCH SHOWS IT'S VERY LOW
CORRELATION BETWEEN MALPRACTICE
SUITS AND ACTUAL QUALITY BUT I
WANTED TO ACTED ON SITE. BUT
YOU ARE RECEIVING HE TOLD YOU
JUST TOLD ME THAT YOU ARE%
RECEIVING THESE REPORTS RIGHT
SO IF YOU HAVE A CIVIL CASE
THAT RESULTS IN A- I GUESS A-
ANALYTICS. AWARD OR FINDING OF
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU'LL RECEIVE A REPORT THAT
HAPPENED. THAT THAT EVER IN
ITSELF- BECAUSE SOME FURTHER
INVEST A EXAMINATION OF WHETHER
THAT'S A CIRCUMSTANCE THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF DO YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO WAIT FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY. PLEASE
INVESTIGATE THIS SO YOU'RE
GOING TO GET INFORMATION FROM
HOSPITAL STAFF HAVE TAKEN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST
PHYSICIANS. WE HAVE YEAH
POTENTIALLY CRIMINAL CASES HAVE
HAPPENED INVOLVED LICENSEES. SO
I'M TRYING TO DISCERN BETWEEN
DO AND YOU DO SEE IT HE SAID MY
TAKES YOU DO RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT YOU JUST TOLD ME.
THE NEW THOSE IN ITSELF AND
LEAD TO FURTHER EXAMINATION BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT MAY THEN
TRIGGER A FULLER INVESTIGATION
AND POTENTIALLY ACTION BUT
MEDICAL BOARD. YES SIR. OKAY
AND HOW OFTEN DOES THAT HAPPEN
PURSES AND SOMEONE ACTUALLY
FILING AN ACTIVE COMPLAINT.
EVERY CASE THAT WE RECEIVE A
NOTICE ON. FORT WEATHERBY
MALPRACTICE- A CRIMINAL CHARGER
RASPY. WERE OPENING ALL OF
THOSE COMPLAINTS. AND REVIEWING
THEM. OKAY SO WHEN I THINK THAT
MIGHT BE IN THE AND- BABY YOU
MAY HAVE THE DETAILS HERE SO WE
CAN FOLLOW UP THERE SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE EXAMPLE SERA JUST
GAVE- YOU SAID ELLIS TESTIFIED
THAT DECISION RECEIVED
INFORMATION TOLD VERY LATE INTO
THE PROCESS I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHAT CAUSED THAT
DELAY WAS IT BECAUSE- AND YOU
KNOW MAYBE THERE WASN'T A
YELLOW LEGAL ACTION THAT AND-
SEND A REPORT OR SOMETHING BUT-
I THINK THAT'S- CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT'S THAT HIGH
PROFILE MURDER IT WAS A LOT OF.
IS IT'S INTERRUPTED LIVE
GOVERNMENT ACTIVITY. SOMEWHERE
SOMETHING YOU'D THINK WOULD
HAVE MADE ITS WAY TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD EARLIER- NOW THAT
IS SELL MIGHT BE. USEFUL TO
LOOK AT SOME OF THESE TYPES OF
CASES AND GO WELL WHAT HAPPENED
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WERE
AND WHY ARE WE NOT GETTING THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO SAY
THAT- THAT MAY BE SOMETHING WE
NEED TO LOOK INTO AS WELL
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT INVOLVES A
LICENSEE AND ITS INVOLVES
SOMETHING THAT'S- FAIRLY.
SERIOUS IN RELATION TO THEIR
PRACTICE OUR BEHAVIOR IN
PRACTICE- WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
RESEARCH THAT. AND I WILL
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OKAY SO
THAT ALL RIGHT SO I JUST WANTED
TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND ALSO
CLARIFIED TERMS OF FOUR.
DIFFERENT WHAT. WHAT SORT OF
ISSUES I KNOW THE MEDICAL BOARD
DOES LOOK A LOT. AT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS- LET'S SEE
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES OF INFORMATION. THE
OTHER CELEBS LET'S MOVE ON- MAY
I SPEAK TO THE- SEARCH AREA
OKAY BEFORE I MOVE ON YES. THIS
IS OUR KRAUSER. UP ONE OF MY
FRUSTRATIONS AND SERVICE ON THE
BOARD. IS THAT GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND EVEN DIFFERENT
BOARDS- WITHIN THE DCA AND
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS. DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH COLLABORATION- SO
THERE'S ALSO A SEMANTIC ISSUE
HERE- WHEN WE SPEAK OF
COMPLAINT. WE'RE NOT MEANING TO
SAY THAT MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
NEEDS TO FILL OUT A REPORT AND
MAKE A COMPLAINT. A COMPLAINT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE BECOME
AWARE OF WHAT WE ALSO READ THE
NEWSPAPER AND BECOME AWARE OF
THINGS THAT THE NEWSPAPER. OVER
THE YEARS- APART READING AN
ARTICLE IN THE NEWSPAPER I
SOMETIMES WILL CALL CALL THE-
THE BOARD DIRECTOR AND SAY WHAT
ABOUT THIS AND GENERALLY BY THE
TIME I BECOME AWARE OF
SOMETHING IN THE NEWSPAPER THE
BOARDS ALREADY INVESTIGATING IT.
HI SIMILARLY- THERE WAS A
RECENT CASE WHERE. THE MEDICAL
BOARD WAS INVESTIGATING A
COMPLAINT- AND THE L. A. TIMES
WROTE AN ARTICLE THAT THEY
CALLED THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. BECAUSE THERE SEEM THAT
THEIR CALLS ALSO COULD HAVE
BEEN A FAILURE TO REPORT- ON
THE PART OF THE UNIVERSITY
HOSPITAL SYSTEM. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SAID WELL WE HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE
OF THIS. JONES SO SINCE THAT
TIME I KNOW THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS REACHED OUT TO ALL
ASSOCIATED ORGANIZATIONS. I AND
THIS BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS
SUCH THAT WE CAN. LET ONE
ANOTHER KNOW WHEN WE BECOME
AWARE OF AN ISSUE. THAT MAY
REACH ACROSS MULTIPLE BOARDS OR
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS. REGARDING
THIS SPECIFIC CASE- A PEDOPHILE
YEAH IN SAN FRANCISCO. I WOULD
ASSUME THAT THE BOARD BEGAN
INVESTIGATING AND WHEN THE
BOARD BECAME AWARE OF IT. SO IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO VIEW THIS
AS A SENTINEL CASE. AND TO LOOK
OVER ALL OF THE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT INVESTIGATED THAT
CASE AND VIEWED THE CASE AND
FIND OUT. WHY THAT HAD NOT BEEN
REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
SOONER. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD HOPE WOULD COME
OUT OF ISSUES SUCH AS THIS.
WOULD BE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
HELP US IN ASSURING THAT WE
HAVE A GREATER COLLABORATION-
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENTS
AND GREATER SHARING OF
INFORMATION. SO THAT THINGS
DON'T FALL BY THE BY THE
WAYSIDE. BUT AGAIN
SEMANTICALLY. A COMPLAINT BY
DEFINITION IS ANY. CHARGE OR
CONCERN IT COMES TO THE BOARD'S
ATTENTION WHETHER IT BE BY
REPORTING FROM- CRIMINAL
SYSTEMS OR SETTLE SYSTEMS. OR
HOSPITAL REPORTING OF-
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CALL A
COMPLAINT. I WOULDN'T WANT- THE
COMMITTEE TO THINK THAT. BY
COMPLAIN FOR MEANING THAT SOME
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO.
MAKE AN ADDITIONAL COMPLAINT N
ADDITIONAL TWO ARE BECOMING
AWARE OF IT OKAY BUT ONCE WE
ARE AWARE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
BENNETT IS INVESTIGATING OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT EXPLANATION PRECIADO
CLARIFICATION WHAT THE TERM
COMPLAINT MEANS AND- I DO THINK
THAT. WE SHOULD LOOK A SOME OF
THESE CASES WHERE IT SEEMS LIKE
MEDICAL BOARD- WAS DELAYED IN
TAKING SOME SORT OF YOU KNOW-
ACTION IN TERMS OF AT LEAST AND
THESE INVESTIGATING. AND
WHETHER- DOOR OTHER STEPS THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN DOWN BUT
MADE A MAJOR MEDICAL BOARD
AWARE EARLIER- AND- CERTAINLY
WOULD APPRECIATE THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S HELP AS WELL SO YOU
KNOW WE WANTED TO DO THINGS
THAT AREN'T AFFECTED. OKAY IN
THE MOVE ON TO- NEXT QUESTION I
HAVE ACTUALLY- SO I KNOW ONE OF
THE ISSUES OF COURSE IS THAT-
YOU KNOW WITH YOUR YOUR
REVENUES ARE. USED EXPENDITURES
ARE LIKING YOUR REVENUES AND
THEN- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO MAKE THINGS MORE
EFFICIENT. BUT I'LL JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT IN YOUR REPORT- THE
MEDICAL WORK CALIFORNIA NOTES
AND- THE 88% OF APPLICATIONS IT
RECEIVES IN REVIEWS DEFICIENT
AT THE TIME TO REVIEW. NOW WHY
I BRING. THIS UP. SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO THE MEDIC BOARD TELLS
FOR LES OR THESE ARE. WHO
APPARENTLY SUCCESS BY FOR CAR.
AND GOT THROUGH THE COLLEGE
PROCESS AND TRAIN YOU HOW TO
FILL AN APPLICATION TO THEN
APPLY TO MEDICAL SCHOOL AND WAS
ABLE TO COMPLETE AND HAVE
MEDICAL SCHOOL APPLICATION
FULLY- WITHOUT- TOO MUCH
TROUBLE AND THEN APPLIED FOR
RESIDENCY SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE AREN'T USED TO
APPLYING FOR THINGS. AND YET
848% THE APPLICATIONS WERE
DEFICIENT THE TIME REVIEW.
SEEMS TO ME THERE'S A SYSTEMS
PROBLEM THERE- WHAT. IF YOU
TAKE A GROUP OF VERY SMART
TALENT PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO APPLY
TO THINGS EVEN COMPLEX
APPLICATIONS IT YOU KNOW I'VE
THAT. RESIDENCY DIRECTORS I
KNOW WHAT MEDICAL SCHOOL
APPLICATION LOOKS LIKE AND YET
SEEM LIKE WE CANNOT FOLLOW
INSTRUCTIONS OR SOMETHING.
GOING ON WITH THESE
APPLICATIONS. AND I WILL POINT
OUT THOUGH IN MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE- YOU KNOW FULL
DISCLOSURE ON THE LICENSEE OF
THIS FOR NOW THIS IS A WHILE
AGO. FOR EXAMPLE ONE TO HANG UP
TO HAPPEN IN MY LICENSE
APPLICATION WAS IS THAT THEY
WANTED A LETTER OR PROOF OF
RESIDENCY FROM MY RESIDENCY
DIRECTOR. I PROVIDED FROM THE
EXISTING RESIDENCY DIRECTOR
BECAUSE THE PERSON'S RESIDENCY
DIRECTOR. TIME I DID MY
RESIDENCY HAD PASSED AWAY. AND
YET THE MEDICAL SAID. WAS NOT
ACCEPTABLE I NEED TO GET A FROM
MY ACTUAL RESIDENCY DIRECTOR
WHO INFLICTED WAS IN THE GRAVE
AND WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE A
LETTER ALTHOUGH I'M SURE WE'VE
BEEN HAPPY TO DO SO IF HE WAS
ABLE TO. AND SO THAT WENT ROUND
AND ROUND AND ROUND AND
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
STAFF TIME THAT TOOK FOR THEM
FOR ME IS. QUITE EXPLAINED
THAT. PROJECT WHO DO YOU WANT A
LETTER FROM BECAUSE I AM FORTY
CAN GET IT FROM ITS CENTER SO-
FROM UP FOR. AND THEN THE OTHER
ACTUALLY INTERESTING PROBLEM
THAT HUNG UP AND AGAIN IT'S NOT
ABOUT MY APPLICATION BUT IT.
I'M JUST SAYING LIKE HOW MUCH
TIME DOES IT TAKE TO DO THIS-
THAT- YEAH RIGHT NOW I SEE THE
BOARD'S MOVING TOWARD
INSTITUTIONALIZING CURE FOR
RESIDENCY APPARENTLY.
MASSACHUSETTS DID HAVE THAT AT
THE TIME THAT WASN'T GOOD
ENOUGH FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA TIME SO WE WENT
ROUND AND ROUND OR- ABOUT. MY
LICENSURE AS WELL AND FINALLY
GOT THAT STRAIGHTENED OUT. SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION REALLY THE
BOILS DOWN TO. WHAT HOW MUCH
TIME AND MONEY WE SPENDING ON
REVIEWING THESE APPLICATIONS.
IF 88% THE APPLICATIONS ARE
DEFICIENT THE TIME REVIEW ARE
WE BEING TO. NOT BEING
TRANSPARENT ENOUGH WITH PEOPLE
APPLYING WHERE WE MAKING IT SO
HARD. FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
EXPERIENCED IN FOLLOWING VERY
COMPLEX INSTRUCTIONS AND
PROVIDING VERY COMPLEX
DOCUMENTATION AND IF. APPROVED
IT THROUGH AT LEAST THREE
DIFFERENT. CYCLES OF APPS. IN
ORDER EVEN TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY COULD APPLY FOR A MEDICAL
BOARDOF CALIFORNIA LICENSE. IS
THERE ANY CAN CAN WE TALK ABOUT
EFFICIENCY. HERE- IT'S ONE
THING IT'S LIKE 10% I CAN
IMAGINE THISGROUP OF PEOPLE
80% OF THEM CAN'T FIGURE OT
HOW TO FILL OUT AN APPLICATION
THERE IS INSUFFICIENT AND THE
INSTRUCTIONS ARE VERY POOR. DO
YES OKAY I WILL ASK OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL- MISS WEB TO DEAL WITH
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN FOR THAT QUESTION AND I
THINK. YOU HIT IT- IN PART THAT.
PART OF THE REASON WHY THERE'S
DEFICIENCIES UPON FIRST REVIEW
IS THAT THE BOARD DOES REQUIRE
PRIMARY SOURCE DOCUMENTATION
FOR MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND PASSED
SEEN AS SAID THE REQUIRED
EXAMS. THIS IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BOARD- OKAY ARE SAID
THE TICKET AND I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY.
I HAD TO PROVIDEPRIMARY SOURCE
INFORMATION FOR APPLYING TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL FROM COLLEGE AND
THEN WHEN PEOPLE FIGHT TO
RESIDENTS AND BY LAW AS A
RESIDENCY DIRECTOR WE NEEDED
CERTAIN PRIMARY SOURCE
INFORMATION AND YET I DIDN'T
HAVE THIS RATED EFFICIENCY AND
APPLICATIONS FROM PEOPLE OF
FLIGHT FROM MEDICAL SCHOOL TO
MY RESIDENCY PROGRAM. SO I
THINK IT WAS CLEARER AND LESS
THE REQUIREMENTS AS A AND I
GUESS I POINT OUT MY OWN
EXAMPLE BUT THAT'S NO IT'S ONLY
SAMPLES NOT PAID- IT'S- DATA.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE REQUIREMENTS
ARE AND THAT YOU CAN'T MEET ALL
RIGHT BY ASKING FOR A LETTER
FROM THE VERY PERSON WHO
HAPPENED TO PASS AWAY BUT- YEAH
ARE WE ARE WE MAKING IT TO
ADDRESS I MEAN WE I COULD I
COULD PROVIDE AND LETTER FROM
THE EXIT PROGRAM DIRECTOR WHO
ACTUALLY WAS PRACTICING WHO HAD
ACCESS TO THOSE RECORDS I COULD
HAVE. LETTERS FROM THE
INSTITUTION BUT IT WAS NOT MADE
CLEAR IN THE BEGINNING THAT YOU
KNOW IF YOU'RE PROGRAM AFTER
ACTUALLY ISN'T THERE PASSED
AWAY OR SOMETHING ELSE
HAPPENED- THAT THESE WERE THE
ALTERNATIVES THAT WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT FOR THE BOARD WHICH
REALLY ARE STILL PRIMARY SOURCE
I MEAN IT'S THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR WOULD STILL BE POINT
THE SAME. RECORDS AND GOING OH
YEAH I KNOW HE COMPLETED AS IT
SEE ALL THE HIS FACULTY SAID HE
WAS FINE AT CETERA AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LETTER IN THE FILES
RESIDENTS HERE ACTOR THAT I
WRITE THE END OF EVERY YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE GRADUATING
RESIDENTS THAT WE FIND THE FILE
SAYING YES THEY HAVE COMPLETED-
AFFECT AT THE CERTIFY IT TO THE
ACT OF TWO OTHER. OTHER
PEOPLE'S. WELL BUT YET. SO
AGAIN. PRIMARY SOURCE AND DC
KNOW HOW TO AS YOU I NEEDED YOU
KNOW I KNOW THIS FOR THIS FROM
THIS THIS FROM THIS THEY CAN DO
IT SO WHY IS IT STILL 88% OF
PEOPLE STILL CANNOT CANNOT GET
CANNOT FOLLOW THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS EITHER SOMETHING
IS WRONG WITH THE INSTRUCTIONS.
BORROWED BEING UNREASONABLE AND
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT'S ALSO
INVOLVES NOT ONLY THE APPLICANT
SENT TO STAFF TIME TO GO AND
SEND THE LETTER REJECTIONS
SAYING YOU NEEDED THAT AT
CETERA BUT- YET THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH CLARITY. THAT PEOPLE
CAN'T DO IT THAT 80% OF THE
PEOPLE STILL HAVE A DEFICIENT
APPLICATION THE TIME TO REVIEW.
AT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THAT
QUESTION- SHE POINTS TO MAKE
FIRST. TIME I'M GLAD THAT THE
BOARD WAS ABLE TO. RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE WITH YOUR APPLICATION- IF
I DON'T KNOW YOU WANT AND DON'T
KNOW HOW LONG THAT TOOK RIGHT
AWAY BY THE WAY YEAH SO- MONTHS.
ONCE WHICH YEAH WHICH THE LATE
OF COURSE MY- YEAH SO ANYWAY
FORTUNATE SLIDE EARLY SO
DIDN'T- BUT ANYWAY DEBATE LATE
APPLICATION BY MONTHS AND
MONTHS AND MONTHS BECAUSE WE
WENT IN CIRCLES AND CIRCLES AND
CIRCLES I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THE STAFF TO THE GO AND TELL ME
THEY WERE EVERY ALTERNATIVE AT
CENTRE AND DIDN'T TELL ME WHAT
TO DO SO I HAVE TO KEEP TRYING
DIFFERENT ANGLES AND SO FORTH
MAKE UP INSISTING ON I KEPT
SAYING YOU WANT THE DEATH
CERTIFICATE FROM THE PERSON WHO
PASSED AWAY IS THAT WHAT YOU
NEED. TO GO TALK TO HIS FAMILY
AND SEE WHAT IF YOU GIVE ME A
COPY. I THE SECOND. POINT I
WANT TO MAKE IS. THAT IT'S NOT.
A LACK OF FOLLOWING
INSTRUCTIONS IN. MOST CASES
IT'S THAT. THE APPLICANT HAS
APPLIED. THEY'VE ALREADY SENT
THE REQUEST OUT TO. THE VARIOUS
ENTITIES FOR THE BOARD NEEDS
PRIMARY SOURCE AND THE BOARD IS
WAITING. FOR THAT INFORMATION
TO COME IN. SO THAT IT'S
SUFFICIENT BECAUSE THE BOARD IS
WAITING FOR THAT INFORMATION
COMMAND NOT BECAUSE- THE
APPLICANTS- DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
THE INSTRUCTIONS. OKAY THE-
WHEN I WANT TO MAKE IT THAT THE-
IS MAY ME FUTURE IMPROVEMENTS
AND US WITH IT'S- NEW DOCKS
PORTAL AND SO. IT BISS HAS
CREATED HUGE EFFICIENCIES AND
HAS MADE IT EASIER FOR PROGRAMS
AND SCHOOLS TO UPLOAD
DOCUMENTS. THAT HAS STREAMLINED
THIS PROCESS AND WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE. LEVINE IN THE
STORE. THANKS THAT THE BOARD
HAS LEARNED FROM KOBE HAS-
EXPERT THIS CHANGE AND THE
BOARD WILL BE ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM THE LEGISLATURE
TO IMPROVE EFFICIENCY EVEN MARK
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT I JUST
THINK THIS IS VERY SYMBOLIC
POTENTIALLY AND I APPRECIATE SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO INFORM US AS TO THE
IMPROVEMENTS. THAT YOU ARE
MAKING BUT I JUST THAT YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD FROM MANY PEOPLE WHO
OF COURSE DEAL FORTUNATELY YOU
MAY ONLY APPLY ONCE AND THEN
YOU KNOW YOU GET LICENSE AND IT
REELS ALAS CENTER SIMPLER BUT-
IT REALLY ANY I'VE HEARD SO
MANY HORROR STORIES ABOUT
PEOPLE RYING TO FLY FOR A
LICENSE HERE WHO IT'S NOT
ISSUES THEY'RE BEING GOOD
STANDING IT'S AN ISSUE OF
REALLY THIS ROUTE- NEED A LOT
OF. WELL ANYWAY I DO THE SAME
AND I ALSO WANTED TO GET WHAT
THE COST OF THAT IS TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THAT'S. STAFF TRYING TO
KEEP. WHEN YOU HAVE THAT. LEVEL
OF ERRORS. OKAY WELL MOVE ON
HERE I WANT TO THE LABOR THAT'S
WHY- AND JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW GOING TO HAVE A SECOND
SESSION. RECOVERY FEE STRUCTURE
FINANCIAL. SOLVENCY STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS AND ALL THE REST OF.
HIS JUST IN CASE THAT. BEARS ON
YOUR QUESTION OKAY YES SORRY NO
THANK YOU AND- I WILL THERE ARE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS I WILL TRY TO
LEAD TO THE- THE SUBSEQUENT
HEARING RELATED TO THOSE
ISSUES- IN TERMS OF- THE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE- IN TERMS OF BOARD
COMPOSITION. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
BOARD DOES AND- WE HAVE YEAH-
MANY EXCELLENT MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD- BUT AFTER MIDDAY- IN
THIS. PERHAPS THOSE BACKGROUND
EVENTUALLY- IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT- WHAT
KIND OF GUIDANCE DOES THE STAFF
PROVIDE TO MEMBERS OF MORE
PARTICULARLY THE PUBLIC MEMBERS
ABOUT STANDARD OF CARE- EVAN
FORTY HEARD SOME DISCUSSIONS AT
THE BOARD THAT- MAYBE A LITTLE
DISTURBED THAT THERE WAS NOT A
GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF STANDARD
OF CARE AND EVIDENCE. AND AND
WE'RE- SOME OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS MADE STATEMENTS THAT
WERE SOMEWHAT CONCERNING IN
REGARDS TO- WE CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE I HAD GREAT INTEREST AND-
CAN YOU CAN WE CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK TO THAT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THAT WILL HAVE SOME BEARING IF
THEY'RE PLAYING ROLES AND
INVESTIGATIONS. YES I WOULD BE
VERY PLEASED TO. ADDRESS THAT
SUBJECT. I CAN ASSURE OF THE
SENATOR THAT STANDARD OF CARE
IS AT THE VERY HEART OF WHAT WE
DO. INSEAD THE VERY HEART OF
THE ROLE OF THE BOARD MEMBER.
DURING THE SHORT TIME THAT I
HAVE BEEN THERE WE'VE HAD.
WE'VE HAD PRESENTATIONS AT
BOARD LEVEL IN TRAINING. ON THE
ISSUE OF STANDARD OF CARE IT
IT'S SOMETHING WHICH IS
REGULARLY- WHICH IS REGULARLY-
REVIEWED AND CONSULTED ON.
OBVIOUSLY ANYTIME THAT THERE IS
DISCUSSION OF IN THE INDIVIDUAL
CASE IN THE PARTICULAR.
SANCTIONS ARE THE STANDARD OF
CARE IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
THAT POINT SO THE REVIEW OF
EVERY CASE WE WOULD HOPE
REINFORCES. THE CENTRALITY OF
STANDARD OF CARE. OKAY WELL I
AM VERY APPRECIATE THAT I SAID
IF I HAVE A AS ABSORBED SOME
BOARD- HEARINGS- WHICH- THAT
THAT. HAS LED TO SOME CONCERN
ON MY PART- THAT- THAT
SOMETIMES SOME OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS MAY NOT BE AS AWARE OF-
PUBLIC HEALTH EVIDENCE AND
STANDARD OF CARE- BUT-
APPRECIATE- THAT EXPLANATION-
JUST GO FLIP THROUGH HERE ALL
RIGHT WELL I WILL- I THINK MOST
OF MY OTHER QUESTIONS INVOLVED
LICENSURE WHICH I UNDERSTAND BE
TAKEN UP AT A SUBSEQUENT
HEARING SO I'LL LEAVE IT FOR
VAN- THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. CHAIR OFF THANK
YOU CENTER PAN I HAVE- LOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG CENTER HER
TADO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IN
THE Q. AND AS I'M STIRRING THIS
BACK TOWARD ENFORCEMENT I JUST
WANT TO PUT A COUPLE QUESTIONS
ON THE RECORD THAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE HAVING RESPONSES
DELIVERED TO THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEES- ONE HAS TO DO WITH
BOARD SELF INITIATION OF
INCREASE AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW
HOW MANY. BOARD DIRECTED
INCREASE ON DOCTOR MISCONDUCT
WITHOUT PRIOR. COMPLAINTS WERE
INITIATED IN THE LAST FISCAL
YEAR AND CERTAINLY THE FISCAL
YEAR BEFORE THAT AND I'M NOT
TALKING MEDICAL MALPRACTICE
NECESSARILY DR PHYSICIAN
MISCONDUCT. THAT'S ONE GIVEN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A STATE
AGENCY IN THIS STATE WHO TOOK
ACTION IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
ON THAT. ATTRITION THAT I
REFERENCED EARLIER. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHEN THE MEDICAL BOARD
BEGAN TO TAKE ACTION WITH
RESPECT TO THE DOCTOR'S
BEHAVIOR AND BASICALLY BUT
SINCE IT'S BEEN PUBLISHED IN
THE NEWSPAPER I'D LIKE TO SEE A
TIME LINE ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S ACTIVITY WITH RESPECT
TO THAT SPECIFIC CASE- THAT I
CITED. THERE ANY QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE INFORMATION
REQUESTED- YOU CAN. LET ME KNOW
NOW OR BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THE
HEARING OR ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY
TO- THE CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
BOTH COMMITTEES. HELLO SAYS
JUST BY POINT OF CLARIFICATION
THERE BY TERMS OF THE FIRST
QUESTION YOU SAID- COMPLAINT
SORRY WHICH AWARE WE'VE
INITIATED A- AN INVESTIGATION
WITHOUT A PRIOR COMPLAINT ARE
YOU INCLUDING THEIR THE
MANDATORY REPORTS THAT WE
RECEIVE YES. OKAY SO HE'S WITH
BECAUSE FRANKLY SIR I'M
BOTHERED BY THE- AND YOUR
INITIAL COMMENTS INDICATING
THAT. YOU'RE SORT OF A REACTIVE
REGULATORY AGENCY AS OPPOSED TO
A PROACTIVE REGULATORY AGENCY
AND I WANT TO GET A FEEL FOR
AND A HANDLE ON. WHAT EXACTLY
YOU DO IN THE ABSENCE OF
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS AND I'M
PARTICULARLY BOTHERED BY THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
FOR HIS STATE DEPARTMENT. OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I BELIEVE IT
TOOK TOOK ACTION TO BAR THIS
POSITION IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND IT WAS NOT UNTIL
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE BUT AN
ACCUSATION WAS FILED SO I THINK
THE TIMELINE ON THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WOULD BE INSTRUCTED. AND
YOU KNOW I WASN'T ASKING A
QUESTION ABOUT THE TIME LINE IN
TERMS OF THE PARTICULAR
PHYSICIAN. BUT YOU THAT THE
FIRST THING YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT WAS. WHERE WE HAD
INITIATED. INVESTIGATIONS
WITHOUT A PRIOR COMPLAINT RIGHT
AND NOW FIGHT WITHOUT A PRIOR
COMPLAINT ARE YOU INCLUDING
THEIR THE MANDATORY REPORTS WE
GET IN TERMS OF MALPRACTICE
RESTRICTION A PRACTICE. DO YOU
INCLUDE THAT AS A COMPLAINT OR
NOT. NO I DON'T INCLUDE THAT AS
A COMPLAIN I CONCLUDE THAT IS
RECEIVING INFORMATION THAT
COULD CAUSE YOU TO AND BY THE
WAY YOU'RE YOU FOCUSED ON
MALPRACTICE I'M TALKING.
PRIMARILY ABOUT PHYSICIAN
MISCONDUCT CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
ACTIVITY SUCH AS THAT AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE A
HANDLE ON. HOW REACTIVE THE
BOARD IS OR IS OT. WHEN THE
BOARD KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
BASED ON THE INFORMATION-
EXISTING OUT THERE OF
PHYSICIANS CONDUCT THAT
WHETHER. IT OCCURRED OR NOT
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED. OKAY
THAT'S UNDERSTOOD PERFECT.
CARILLO QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JIM ROTH I WANNA AT.
JOIN IN THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO BACK TO TCHERASSI COMMENTARY
DIRECTED TO- MR PACIFICA OF
REGARDING THE- ARTICLE
SPECIFICALLY THAT HAPPENED FROM
THE COUNTY THAT I REPRESENT IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY- IS
PROFESSOR ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH
THE ARTICLE AT HAND FROM THE
BAY AREA NEWS GROUP. THAT WHAT
YOU HAD WAS FOUND TO HAVE
TWENTY THIRD. YOU HAVE TO GIVE
ME SOME MORE MEANS TO IDENTIFY.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
ARTICLE PUBLISHED ON FEB TWENTY
THIRD TWO A TITLE AFTER DECADES
OF SEX ABUSE CLAIMS. STATE
MOVES TO STOP FORMER SANTA
CLARA CHIEF PEDIATRICIAN FROM
PRACTICING MEDICINE I'VE- ARE
YOU ABLE TO SELL I'M FAMILIAR
CERTAINLY ABOUT THE CASE YES
YES OKAY. YOU STATED EARLIER-
IT WAS BROUGHT ALSO TO BUY A TO
YOUR ATTENTION JUST JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AGO BY SENATOR ROTH.
ABOUT THE CASE AT HAND AND I
WAS PARTICULARLY STRUCK AND
DISTURBED BY YOUR RESPONSE.
STATING THAT YOU HAVE TO WAIT
FOR A COMPLAINT TO BE MADE
FIRST. IT CAN YOU HELP ME
SUMMARIZE IT HELP ME UNDERSTAND
THAT AS TO WHY YOU BELIEVE IN
WHAT YOU STATE OR MAYBE CAN
CLARIFY YOUR COMMENT THAT YOU
STATED THAT YOU HAVE TO.
BELIEVE THAT YOU MUST WAIT FOR
A KEY A COMPLAINT FIRST. YEAH
WELL I THOUGHT DOCTOR EXPLAINED
IT QUITE CLEARLY WE HAVE TO.
HAVE INFORMATION. THAT GIVES US
A BASIS FOR GOING FORWARD. THE
INFORMATION COMES FROM A
VARIETY OF SOURCES. THE OBVIOUS
ONE IS THROUGH THE COMPLAINTS
PROCESS BUT THERE IS PUBLIC
INFORMATION. THERE ARE
MANDATORY REPORTS THAT COME
THROUGH US. WE GET ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINTS WHICH AGAIN ARE
CERTAIN CREATE CERTAIN PROBLEMS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE TO
FOLLOW UP. SO THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF BASIS UPON WHICH WE-
CAN ARE. TAKE ACTION THE
DIFFICULTY THAT I HAVE IS THAT
FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW. ON THE
BASIS OF NO INFORMATION. WE ARE
NOT SEEKING TO SEE IF THERE IS
SOMEONE WHO IS PROBLEMATIC IN
SOME PLACE WE HAVE NEVER HEARD
OF OUR DON'T KNOW EXIST WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOMETHING. TO GO NO WE
CAN BE A VARIETY OF THINGS WE
FOLLOW UP ON NEWSPAPER ACCOUNTS
OR OTHER MEDIA REPORTS BUT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A NAME AND WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME BASIS. UPON WHICH
WE CAN COLLECT INFORMATION. SO
YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE OF
THE ROLE OF THE BOARD IS TO BE
PROACTIVE. WELL YOU KNOW IT IS
IN THE SENSE THAT I'VE JUST SET.
BUT WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO HAVE
SOME INFORMATION. THAT GIVES US
THE BASIS. TO GO FORWARD.
SEEKING FURTHER INFORMATION.
MAY I SPEAK TO THE QUESTION.
SURE HI THIS IS SAID DR CROSS
AGAIN- IF I MADE- HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF INTERPRETING AGAIN
SEMANTICALLY WHAT WE MEAN BY
REACTOR VERSUS A PROACTIVE- WE
HAVE TO HAVE INFORMATION TO
REACT TO. BUT AGAIN WE DON'T
REQUIRE SOMEONE TO SEND IN A
REPORT SPECIFICALLY TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD SAYING- SO AND SO
WHAT I DID THIS AND- YOU KNOW
DID YOU READ THE NEWSPAPER- SO
A NEWSPAPER ARTICLE DOES COME
TO THE BOARD'S ATTENTION. BUT
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE STAFF
THAT THE RESET EVERY NEWSPAPER
SO THERE COULD BE SOME
ARTICLES- THAT THEY DON'T COME
TO OUR ATTENTION. I AS I SAID
EARLIER GENERALLY BY THE TIME I
READ SOMETHING IN THE PAPER THE
BOARDS ALREADY. WORKING ON IT-
WHAT IS MEANT WHEN WE SAY WE'RE
NOT PROACTIVE. IF WE DON'T HAVE
A STAFF OF A DOZEN PEOPLE WHO
WERE HANGING OUT HOSPITAL LOW
LOUNGES AND STREET CORNERS
OVERHEARING CONVERSATIONS TO
PICK UP ON CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
IN SOMEBODY MAY BE MISBEHAVING.
WHAT WE NEVER DID MORE
INFORMATION- WE NEVER IGNORE
CONCERNS VIDAK READ OF SOMEONE
WHO MAY BE MISBEHAVING IN A
NEWSPAPER ARTICLE. LET'S NOT DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT UNTIL
SOMEONE SENDS IN A COMPLAINT TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD SO I DON'T
WANT THAT TO BE MISUNDERSTOOD
WE'RE PROACTIVE. ONCE WE HAVE
INFORMATION. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
A CADRE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
IN THE WOODS- AND IN THE
STREETS SO TO SPEAK-
OVERHEARING CONVERSATIONS TO
COLLECT INFORMATION. SO I FEAR
THAT WE'RE GETTING HUNG UP ON
SEMANTICS. AND THE SUGGESTION
THAT WAS MADE EARLIER BY
SENATOR ROTH. YOU LOOK AT THIS
BAY AREA CASES A SENTINEL CASE.
AND TO SEE WHERE IN THE- CHAIN
OF EVENTS. THERE WAS A FAILURE
TO NOTIFY THE MEDICAL BOARD BY
ONE AGENCY OR ANOTHER AGENCY.
WILL BE VERY INSTRUCTIVE. YOU
KNOW THERE ARE SOME CASES WHERE
THERE IS MANDATORY REPORTING-
AND IF INDEED THE LEGISLATURE
CAN HELP US TO INCREASE
MANDATORY REPORTING. SEVEN MORE
THINGS BECOME EVIDENT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD. THAT WILL BE
VERY HELPFUL IN PROTECTING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. SO HELP
US OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION. AND
WE WILL BE VERY PROACTIVE AS
WELL AS REACTIVE I IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATING AND ARE DOING OUR
JOB TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC OKAY.
THANK YOU MR KRAUSS YOU KEEP
BRINGING UP THE WPA THE WORD
SEMANTICS THIS IS NOT SO BASIS
THE SEMANTICS OF INTERPRET.
YOUR COMMENTS TO BE SOMEWHAT
CONDESCENDING THIS ABOUT VERY
BIG BABY BEING VERY DIRECT
ISN'T ABOUT GOING INTO THE
WOODS IT'S A SIMPLISTIC AS
HAVING A GOOGLE ALERT FOR
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD WHAT
THE FAILURES TO ACT.
SPECIFICALLY NOT HAD A PASSING
THE BUCK I'M TRYING TO SAY THAT
WE'RE NOT BEING PROACTIVE WE
EXPECT MORE THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT HEARING
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD I THINK
IT'S A FAILURE FOR THE BOARD
SPECIFICALLY ON THE OWNERSHIP
OF THE- HEADLINE OF THAT REPORT
SO. BACK TO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR HOW DO YOU INTERPRET
THE PUBLICATION ITSELF. DO YOU
INTERPRET THAT AS A FAILURE OF
THE BOARD. WHAT. WHAT IS THE
DATE OF THE PUBLICATION OF THE
DAY THE DATE OF THE PUBLICATION
IS FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE YES BUT A
MONTH AGO NOT TOO LONG AGO AND
THIS TITLE RETREATS AFTER
DECADES OF SEX ABUSE CLAIMS
STATE MOVES TO STOP FORMER
SENATE CLEAR CHIEF PEDIATRICIAN
FROM PRACTICING MEDICINE. YEAH
THAT'S BECAUSE NOTE PRIOR TO
THAT WAS WHEN WE HAD FILED THE
ACCUSATION WHICH IS A PUBLIC
RECORD THE ACCUSATION WAS
PUBLISHED AS A RESULT OF AN
INVESTIGATION WHICH WAS
INITIATED PREVIOUSLY AT THE
SOONEST POSSIBLE DATE THAT IT
COULD BASED ON THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE IT THEN WENT
THROUGH A PROCESS IT WENT
THROUGH AN INVESTIGATION IT
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WHO PROVIDED
THE- AT THE INFORMATION AND THE
EXPERTISE TO BRING IT TO THE
ACCUSATION LEVEL. SO THE SO THE
ACTION THAT WE TOOK. WAS DONE
AT THE EARLIEST STAGE THAT WE
HAD THE INFORMATION TO ACT UPON.
IS IT IS THIS A FAILURE OF THE
BOARD. WELL OKAY WELL I WOULD
WELCOME HAD OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
BACK IN TIME AS TO WHAT WAS
HAPPENING TEN YEARS AGO AND TO
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION THAT
THE BOARD HAD AVAILABLE TO
ITSELF. BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SEVERITY OF THE ACCUSATIONS
THERE IT IS QUITE OBVIOUS THAT
THIS IS A CRIMINAL LAW MATTER
PRIMARILY AND THAT'S I THINK
WHERE WE SHOULD LOOK AT IN
TERMS OF INVESTIGATION
INITIATIONS CONTACT WITH THE
SOCIAL SERVICES FAILURE TO
REPORT THEIR- OKAY AND I WOULD
BE VERY HAPPY TO LOOK AT. WHAT
INFORMATION. THE MEDICAL BOARD
HAD TEN YEARS AGO AND TO SEE IF
WE HAD A BASIS TO TAKE ACTION
BACK THEN WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOES YOUR BOARD VICE
PRESIDENT I DON'T WANNA GET
INTO SEMANTICS TELLS A LOT OF
WORDS I JUST ASKED A SIMPLE
QUESTION IS THIS A FAILURE OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD YES OR NO.
WELL THE SIMPLE ANSWER. YOU A
FILLING NO NO NO NO NO NO THANK
YOU I'M ASKING THE EXACT. IS
THIS FAILURE OF THE MATTER
BOARD YES OR NO. WELL I'M NOT
PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THAT WAY NOW WITHOUT
KNOWING THE FACTS. YOU DON'T
KNOW THE FACTS ARE WHERE DOES
THE BUCK STOPS. THE BUCK STOP
WITH YOU. WHO'S INVOLVED IN THE
RESPONSE PROBLEM WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD TODAY THE BUCK
STOPS WITH ME. FULL STOP NO
EXCUSES WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING
TO DO BETTER THE CURRENT
EXECUTIVE TEAM DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE STATUS QUO IS GOOD
ENOUGH. AND WE ARE STRIVING TO
IMPROVE THINGS BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO THROW MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES UNDER THE BUS
WITHOUT KNOWING THE FACTS. MAY
I SPEAK. NO NO NO NO I JUST I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THE THAT
ALTMAN AUTHORITY. I JUST ABOUT
IT I DON'T WANNA GET INTO
SEMANTICS THIS IS JUST ABOUT
VERY STRAIGHT FORWARD. HOW IS
IT THAT YOU DO NOT KNOW THE
DETAILS OF THIS CASE. BEING
THAT IT WAS MADE PUBLIC BUT A
MONTH AGO. AND YOU KNOW WITH
JIM KNEW THAT WE WERE HAVING
AND- OVERSIGHT HEARING. HOW IS
THAT POSSIBLE OKAY WHAT I KNOW
ARE THE DETAILS OF WHAT THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS DONE. AND
THAT'S IN THE PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
THERE. NOW WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
ME TO DO IS TO TELL YOU WHAT
HAPPENED TEN YEARS AGO WHAT
INFORMATION WAS AVAILABLE IN
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN. AND SHOULD
THAT OR SHOULD THAT NOT HAVE
BEEN THE BASIS FOR AN ACTION BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD. I DON'T KNOW
THAT. OKAY SPEAK THE AND THEN
AND THE NEW WHO IF YOU WILL NOT
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THIS AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD. WITH A SIMPLE
QUESTION IS THE FAILURE OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD THEN WHOSE
FAILURE IS IT. I TRIED ANSWERED
YOUR CARRILLO MAY I THINK THIS
IS CHRISTINA OFTEN. BUT MY
QUESTION IS DIRECTED TO THE
BUCK STOPS WITH THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND I LIKE TO ASK
DIRECTLY TO THE PERSON WHO IS
ACCEPTED OWNERSHIP. I HAVE
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION SENATOR.
I WILL NOT BE BULLIED INTO
MAKING ANY KIND OF STATEMENTS
THAT HAVE NO BASIS IN FACT. AND
I SPEAK NO NO NO NO IT THE DATE
THANK YOU ALL OF FINALLY SAY
THAT IF YOUR INTERPRETATION IS
THAT OF ASKING A QUESTION ABOUT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESTATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE
ARE DOING OUR JOB. THE
NECESSARY CONSTITUTIONAL JOB OF
OVERSIGHT THAN IT IS TO BE
INTERPRETED SUCH THAT WE ARE
ASKING THE TOUGH QUESTIONS ON
THE FAILURES OF THE WORK THAT
AND WITH THE BUCK STOPS WITH
YOU. AND THAT IS OUR OBLIGATION
TO BE ABLE TO DO IF YOU'RE ILL
EQUIPPED TO BE PREPARED YOU'LL
SEE SUBSEQUENT OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS FOR US TO HOLD YOU
ACCOUNTABLE SINCE YOU'VE TAKEN
OWNERSHIP AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU. MAY I
SPEAK. THE VILLAGE VENTURA. MAY
I SPEAK ABSOLUTELY PUT YOU HAS
IS NOT OF YOUR AN OPPORTUNITY
RESPOND. MANY OF THE IN YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE
TO APOLOGISE- I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THE BRONX AND
SOMETIMES- I'M CYNICAL AND
SARCASTIC AND- SOMETIMES I
APPEAR TO BE CONDESCENDING BUT-
NO COMMENT THAT I MADE TODAY.
WAS INTENDED TO BE
CONDESCENDING AND IF I COME OFF
THAT WAY I HUMBLY APOLOGIZE I
HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT.
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
PROCESS THAT E'RE GOING
THROUGH TODAY SO NEVER HESITATE
TO CALL ME ON NOT HAN HOW I
BEHAVE. SECOND OF ALL AS I
WITNESSED THE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN SAN ANGELO AND MR
PACIFICA. I ALSO- RESTRAINING
WE WITNESS A MISUNDERSTANDING-
MISTER PERCEIVE BECAUSE SEEMS
TO FEEL THAT CENTER LOS
QUESTION WAS DIRECTED TOWARD
WHAT ACTIONS AT THE BORDER TAKE
OR NOT TAKE TEN YEARS AGO.
WHERE IS I HEARD SENATOR LOS
QUESTION TO BE WHAT ACTION THAT
THE BOARD TAKE OR NOT TAKE
SUBSEQUENT TO THE ARTICLE
PUBLISHED IN THE BAY AREA NEWS.
IN FEBRUARY. AS SENATOR ROTH
SAID EARLIER- WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE TIMELINE. WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS CASE WE NEED TO
TAKE IT AS A SENTINEL CASE AND
WE NEED TO SEE STEP BY STEP.
WHEN WAS THEIR PUBLIC
INFORMATION WHEN WE'RE THERE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES INVOLVED
WHEN DID THE MEDICAL BOARD
BECOME AWARE OF THIS WHETHER IT
BE THROUGH THE PRINT MEDIA TV
NEWS OR ANY OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE
AND THEN WE WILL KNOW. WHETHER
OR NOT BORDER FAILED- I WOULD
NOT. SIT HERE AND BE HONEST AND
SAY THAT THE BOARD HAS NEVER
FAILED. BUT I DON'T THINK ANY
ONE OF US NO IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE AT THIS TIME. WHETHER OR
NOT THE BOARD FAILED- AND I
WOULDN'T RUSH TO JUDGMENT. SO
PLEASE GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INVESTIGATE THE TIMELINE OF
THIS CASE. AND THEN ANSWER THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU. TWENTY SIR
ROBERT I MAY. JUST OFFER A
COUPLE ADDITIONAL. THOUGHTS ON
THAT POINT ABSOLUTELY. THANK
YOU- I'M ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS. THAT ARE GOING ON HERE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHETHER
THERE'S A FAILURE OR NOT THERE
CAN BE A FAILURE IN OUR PROCESS
AND THE DOCTOR KRAUSS
ARTICULATED WE ARE HAPPY TO
INVESTIGATE THAT AND
UNDERSTAND- PRECISELY BUT YES
AND WHEN AND WHERE THERE WAS A
FAILURE IN ONE OF OUR OUTBOARD
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS THESE- BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE. GOING
ON HERE- WHICH IS ONE OF PUBLIC
TRUST AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE BOARD
AND SO IT'S EASY TO TAKE THE
CASE THAT- WHERE WHERE THE
PUBLIC HAS INVESTED A DEEP
TRUST IN THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
PROTECT THEM AND MAKE SURE WE
ARE LOOKING OUT ON THEIR
BEHALF. AND THEIR MAIN IT
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A FAILURE
HERE TO DO THAT TO COMMUNICATE
WHAT OUR PROCESS THESE ARE
PERHAPS WE WEREN'T DOING A GOOD
JOB ALONG THE WAY AND SO I TAKE.
THAT ROLE AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
PLEASE ALTHOUGH PUBLIC. ROLE OF
COURSE OPERATE OUTSIDE OF OUR-
STATUTORY AT THE WERE THE
MEDICAL PRACTICE. SOME OF THE
OTHER DIRECTION SO. IT IS
INCUMBENT- AND I AND ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD I KNOW. ALL THE
BOARD MEMBERS WOULD AGREE THAT
NEEDS SOMETHING WE'RE CERTAINLY
FOCUSED ON WORKING ON AN
IMPROVING. AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE TRUST AND
CREDIBILITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN ENTRUSTED TO
PROTECT. THANKS THANK YOU FOR
THOSE REMARKS. OF MEMBER FARM.
I THANK YOU CHAIR- A ROTH
ENSURE LOW- I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT- THE SETTLEMENT ISSUES-
AND THE ROLE OF THE BOARD- IF
YOU LOOK ONPAGE SIXTY ONE OF
THE ANALYSIS AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S AVAILABLE TO YOU- IT
HIGHLIGHTS A SITUATION THAT
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT- IN
KERN COUNTY- IN THE PARAGRAPH
I'LL JUST READ IT FOR THOSE TO
GET YOU DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF
USES THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
PATIENTS STEMMING FROM
SETTLEMENTS CAN BE SIGNIFICANT.
AB ONE TWO THOUSAND POSITION
ENTERED INTO A STIPULATED
SETTLEMENT- FOR VIOLATIONS THAT
OCCURRED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND NINETY SEVEN. THE POSITION
WAS PLACED ON PROBATION FOR
THREE YEARS. THE POSITION WAS
RESTORED TO FULL LICENSE STATUS
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE BUT AGAIN
PLACED ON PROBATION FOR FIVE
YEARS BASED ON A SETTLEMENT-
THE BOARD'S MOST RECENT
ACCUSATION FILED AGAINST
POSITION SIDES PRESS
NEGLIGENCE. NEGLIGENCE AND
FAILURE TO KEEP ADEQUATE AND
ACCURATE RECORDS RELATED TO THE
WRONGFUL DEATH OF THE PATIENT
AND HER UNBORN SET LAST YEAR-
SO I GUESS. COULD YOU PROVIDE
SOME. CLARITY IN TERMS OF I
KNOW YOU TO TALK ABOUT THIS IN
YOUR PRESENTATION ABOUT HOW
THAT. THE GUY DIDN'T THAT THE
DESPITE GUIDELINES OURS OUR
GUIDANCE IS BUT NOT- MANDATES-
BUT COULD YOU AND I GUESS
HIGHLIGHT. OR OR TO SHED SOME
LIGHT IN TERMS OF. HOW YOU COME
A CONCLUSION MAY NOT. BE AT THE
LEVEL OF THAT THE GOT THE
GUIDELINES AND THEN TALK ABOUT
HOW THE BOARD MONITORS
PHYSICIANS ON PROBATION- FOR
SOMETHING LIKE A GROSS
NEGLIGENCE OR WRONGFUL DEATH
ACCUSATIONS. YES WELL CERTAINLY
AS WE HAVE SAID THAT THE
GUIDANCE IS THERE TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE SETTLEMENTS ARE DONE
IN THE CONTEXT OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL CASE LOOKING AT ALL
OF THE RELEVANT FACTS WE LOOK
AT. THAT WE BEGIN WITH THE
ACCUSATION WE LOOK AT THE
EXPERT REPORTS THERE MAY BE
CONTRARY EXPERT REPORTS WE LOOK
AT THE QUALITY OF THE EVIDENCE
WE ALWAYS HAVE A VIEW AS TO
WHAT IS THE POSSIBLE OUTCOME
GOING TO BE IF THERE IS NO
SETTLEMENT AND IF THE CASE GOES
TO HEARING. WE OBVIOUSLY LOOK
AT THE OUTCOME WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS CASE WAS A
VERY SERIOUS. INVOLVING THE
DEATH OF THE PATIENT BUT THE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO FACE UP
TO IS RELATED TO THE STANDARD
OF CARE WHICH CANNOT BE DRIVEN
EXCLUSIVELY BY THE OUTCOME. YOU
CAN HAVE A VERY A POOR OUTCOME
AND THERE IS NO VIOLATION OF
THE STANDARD OF CARE YOU COULD
HAVE A SATISFACTORY OUTCOME. IN
THERE IS AN EXTREME DEPARTURE
FROM THE STANDARD OF CARE IT'S
THE STANDARD OF CARE AND THE
QUALITY OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
RELATES TO DECISIONS THAT ARE
MADE. ON THE BASIS OF
SETTLEMENTS AND SETTLEMENTS ARE
DRIVEN BY WHAT WE CONSIDER TO
BE IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
THE CONTEXT OF EACH CASE. THERE
MAY BE A VIEW TAKEN THAT THE
SETTLEMENT ACHIEVED IS BETTER
THAN IS LIKELY TO BE ACHIEVED.
IF THE CASE WERE TO GO TO
HEARING. BOB ASKED THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE MONITORING OF
CONDITIONS ON THE BASIS OF
PROBATION. AND MAYBE IF I COULD
TURN THAT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
MS JONES. ON THE ENFORCEMENT
SIDE. I'M SORRY YOUR ON THE.
THE TERMS OF PROBATION AM I NOW
YES AS I THOUGHT YEAH- WE HAVE
PROBATION MONITORS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT OVERSEE THE
PROBATION TERMS OF EACH
LICENSEE THAT IS ON PROBATION-
THEIR ROLE IS TO INITIALLY MEET
WITH THE PERSON THAT'S BEING
PLACED ON PROBATION GO OVER ALL
OF THE TERMS OF THE ORDER TO
ASSURE THAT THERE. CLEARLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE TERMS
ARE AND WHAT WILL BE EXPECTED
OF THEM- AND THEN THEY HAVE
QUARTERLY IN PERSON MEETINGS
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS AND FOLLOW
UP WITH THE IF THEY HAVE A
MONITOR THERE FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE MONITOR THEY'RE REVIEWING.
RECORDS REVIEWING- CHARTS- IT
JUST DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING TERMS OF THE ORDER
REQUIRE. AND THEN AND ARE THESE
MONITORS ARE THEY BASED IN EACH
COUNTY OR HOW DOES OUR EXIT BY
REGION OR HOW'S THAT STRUCTURE-
THEY'RE BASED OUT OF THE- IN AN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE AND
THEY'RE IN THE- I AM NOT SURE
IF IT WOULD BE REGION OR
COUNTY- BUT THERE ARE THEY
KOSHER OFFICES WITH THE H. Q.
ARE YOU OFFICES- SO THERE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OKAY AND
THEN- I MEAN CERTAINLY THIS IS
A VERY- TRAGIC AND CONCERNING
SITUATION- NOW THAT THIS IS A
REPEAT IT- SITUATION SO IN
TERMS OF. AND I AND I AND I
GUESS GOING BACK TO THE
SETTLEMENT ISSUE- IS THAT TAKE
A CLEARLY THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT- IN TERMS OF THE
GUIDELINES AND DISCIPLINE. YES
SIR- AND THEN- SO HOW HOW DOES
THE BOARD DETERMINED WHETHER A
LICENSEE IS REHABILITATED OR
FIT OR COMPETENT TO PRACTICE IT
I GUESS IN THIS IN THIS EXAMPLE
CITED AND DENOUNCES AND OF
COURSE IN MY DISTRICT I MADE
SAID THAT THE LICENSE WAS WAS
REINSTATED- WHAT WHAT GOES INTO
THAT PROCESS HELLO GUYS IN THAT
DECISION. WELL AS WAS INDICATED
THIS IS HANDLED BY THE
PROBATION OFFICE THEY MONITOR
ALL THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF
THE PROBATION. N. AT THE END OF
THE TERM OF PROBATION OR IN
SOME CIRCUMSTANCES AT AN
EARLIER STAGE IT HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED THAT ALL OF THE
CONDITIONS HAVE BEEN MET. THEN
THAT'S THE BAND THERE THEN THE
ARM. ARE THE LICENSEE IS
ELIGIBLE TO COME OFF PROBATION
AND SO IT'S ALL DONE IN THAT
CONTEXT. SO THEN. I MEAN I
CERTAINLY- WANT TO KIND OF
DELVE A LITTLE DEEPER INTO THAT
I MEAN WHO WHO'S INVOLVED IN
THE AND- THE ASSESSMENT. OF
WHETHER- WHETHER A SETTLEMENT
SHOULD BE- DIFFERENT FROM THE
GUIDELINES- IF THE GUIDELINES
ARE THERE TO BE GUIDANCE IS AND
THE DECISION IS TO BE MADE TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS. NOT TO
THE SAME LEVEL AS WHAT'S
RECOMMENDED. I'M I'M I'M
STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT HOW THAT'S POSSIBLE WHAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THE OF THE
GUIDELINES IF YOU'RE GOING TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT TO THAT LEVEL. OKAY IT'S
VERY SIMPLE THE GUIDELINES ARE
BASED ON THE ASSUMPTION. THAT
ALL ELEMENTS OF THE CASE HAVE
BEEN PROVEN TO A CLEAR AND
CONVINCING STANDARD. THERE
BASED ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL FACTORS
OF MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. A SO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS HAVE TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. THE PROCESS BY WHICH A
SETTLEMENT IS ENTERED INTO. IS
THAT THE INITIAL AGREEMENT TO
PROPOSE A SETTLEMENT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND THE EXECUTIVE WHICH IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND THE HEAD OF
ENFORCEMENT AT THAT POINT THEN.
IF WE AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION ARE WE FASHION A
NEW RECOMMENDATION. IT IS GOES
INTO SETTLEMENT THERE MAY OR
MAY NOT BE IN AGREEMENT IF
THERE IS AN AGREEMENT. THAT
ULTIMATELY THAT GOES FOR REVIEW
BEFORE ONE OF THE PANELS AND
THE PANEL HAS AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO OBJECT TO THE SETTLEMENT ARE
TO QUESTION AT. OUR END WHICH
WILL GO TO A HEARING. AT WHICH
THE PARTIES WILL BE THERE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL BE THERE
TO EXPLAIN VARIOUS FACTORS THAT
WERE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. AND
THEN THE PANEL HAS THE ABILITY.
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
BELLETTI TO REJECT THE
SETTLEMENT SO THAT'S IF YOU
WILL TO PROCEDURAL SAFEGUARDS
THAT IS THAT IS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. SO IN IN IN IN THAT
PROCESS AND CAN I ASK. WHO
MAKES THE INITIAL
RECOMMENDATION YOU AND YOU SAID
THAT THERE WAS A KIND OF A- A
NUMBER OF. AGENCIES ENTITIES
THAT ARE INVOLVED IS IT. AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE MAKE
A RECOMMENDATION OR IS IT A
COLLECTIVE DECISION FIRST
AMONGST. ON THE BOARD AND THE
AG AND THEN JOKES THAT THE
PANEL THE PEOPLE AT THE AT THE
WAY THE GENERAL PROCESS WORKS
AS AN ADDITIONAL. AN INITIAL
RECOMMENDATION IS MADE TO THE
EXECUTIVE BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND THEN THAT IS-
THAT'S A MATTER OF DISCUSSION.
SOMETIMES WE ACCEPTED SOMETIMES
WE ACCEPTED WITH CONDITIONS-
EITHER UP OR DOWN IN TERMS OF
LEVEL OF SOME OF- A SEVERITY.
THAT'S THE INITIAL POINT BET
NOW THERE IS NO SETTLEMENT
UNTIL YOU HAVE TWO PARTIES TO
AGREE TO IT. THEN IT GOES TO
THE OTHER PARTY THERE MAY BE
SOME NEGOTIATIONS IF THERE IS
NOTHING IS DONE WITHOUT THE
APPROVAL OFTHE EXECUTIVE THEN
YOU REACH A SETTLEMENT. AND
THEN IT'S. ELIGIBLE TO GO TO
THE PANEL FOR REVIEW. OKAY BUT
YOU STATE EARLY AND AN AND ME
IF I I. FIVE ARE FROM EIGHTY
FOUR PER. OF THE CASE FILE.
BEFORE THE BOARD RESULT IN
SETTLEMENTS. IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO DO YOU DO YOU
LAUGHTER. THAT WAS LAST NIGHT
I'M SORRY LAST YEAR JUST TO
CLARIFY THE APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION. DO YOU HAVE.
ENGINE IN GENERAL AND MAYBE AND
I KNOW I NEED OF ME MAYBE IF
YOU CAN PROVIDE ME OF A
SPECIFIC DATA AT SOME AT SOME
POINT. MAYBE NOT HERE BUT- M.
HOW HOW MANY TIMES IS IT
NORMALLY ACCEPTED THE
RECOMMENDATION TO ACCEPT
ADVERSITY IS IT BEING. CHANGED
REJECTED OR OR IS THAT JUST AN
ONGOING THING. WELL FIRST OF
ALL YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
THAT WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND HAVE A VERY LENGTHY
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM WE'VE
BEEN DOING BUSINESS WITH THEM
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME. SO
THEY KNOW WHAT ARE YOU THOUGHTS
IS WHAT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
AND THEY REALLY HAVE
INTERNALIZED A LOT OF THAT. IN
TERMS OF THEIR OWN WORK. SO BY
AND LARGE WE GET
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THEM FIRST
OF ALL WE ALWAYS FIND THAT THEY
ARE VERY WELL PUT TOGETHER.
THAT THEY ARE DESERVING OF. OUR
CAREFUL ANALYSIS- WE WOULDN'T
REJECT THEM LIGHTLY BUT THE
MEDICAL BOARD IN THE EXECUTIVES
WE HAVE DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW WE HAVE A DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE. WE HAVE DIFFERENT
VIEWS OF INDIVIDUAL TYPES OF
CASES AND THERE'S A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE. GIVE AND TAKE
BETWEEN US AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE DECISION IS WITH THE
BOARD THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS.
OUR ADVISER WE ARE THE CLIENT
BUT WE FIND THAT THEY WERE
ADVISED IT'S VERY GOOD IT'S
ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. AND THE ONE THING
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE HAS IS VERY FLUID
INTELLIGENCE AND EXPERIENCE.
DEALING WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES SO THEY HAVE A VERY
GOOD INTELLIGENCE ABOUT WHAT'S
THE LIKELY. OUTCOME GOING TO BE
A HEARING WHICH IS VERY POOR.
OKAY BUT INTERESTED I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE IS. THAT IT IT
STATED IN THE CO LIKE A PART.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH BE THE HIGH
PRIORITY SO YEAH UP IN THE-
DECISION. THAT IS THAT. IS THAT
IS THE GOAL- I ABSOLUTELY WE
DON'T AGREE ANY SETTLEMENT THAT
WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT'S IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. FULL STOP. BOB
NOW IS A VERY RECENT CASE I
DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
DETAILS OF IT. BUT THERE WAS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT IT SHOULD
GO TO SETTLEMENT. AT THE VIEW
WAS ARE THAT THE THAT THERE WAS
A SETTLEMENT PROPOSAL AND WE
SAID NO SIMPLY BECAUSE- WITHOUT
IT YOU GO TO A HEARING THERE
WAS A CONFLICT THE FACT. NOW IT
IS NOT CLEAR. HOW THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED. ALL THESE CASES ARE
BLACK AND WHITE. BUT I
CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT CON. CONFLICT THE
FACT BETWEEN THE PARTIES THAT'S
WHAT YOU WANT TO HAVE A HEARING.
BECAUSE LET THE FACT FINDER
MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE EVIDENCE
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN'T DO JUST ON THE BASIS OF A
PAPER SETTLEMENT. SO WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINIONS BUT
THAT'S A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE
THANK. WE GET GOOD ADVICE WE
RESPECT THE ADVICE BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE MEDICAL
BOARD MAKES THE DECISION. AND
AGAIN WE DON'T RECOMMEND ANY
SETTLEMENT UNLESS IT'S IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. DO YOU AND I
KNOW THAT I NOTED I KNOW TO
NOTICE THAT YOU HAD A NUMBER OF
REFORMS- IN YOUR POWERPOINT
PRESENTATION. AND ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL REFORMS TO THE
SETTLEMENT PROCESS THAT THAT
WOULD IMPROVE. PATIENT
PROTECTION DO YOU SEE- AND ANY
ADDITIONAL CHANGES THAT NEED TO
BE DNE- AS THE PROCESS
CONTINUES THIS IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT- I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM KERN COUNTY INTO THE
SENATOR FOLLOWING YOU WILL
PROBABLY BE. ASKING VERY
SIMILAR QUESTIONS ABOUT
REPEATED SITUATIONS AND
NEGLIGENCE. THESE ARE AN UP AND
OF COURSE THE RESULT OF
WRONGFUL DEATH IS TRAGIC AND-
OTHER REFORMS THAT CAN BE DONE
TO IMPROVE. THIS PROCESS OKAY
WELL FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE NOT
INCLUDED ANY SUCH REFORMS IN
THE CURRENT SUNSET PROPOSAL.
BUT I CAN CERTAINLY ASSURE YOU.
THAT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
AREA. AND THAT WE ARE. WILLING
TO LISTEN TO ANY CONSTRUCTIVE.
ADVICE OR DECISIONS TO IMPROVE
THE PROCESS. OUT WE THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. AGAIN THE
SETTLEMENTS HAVE THE ADVANTAGE
FOR US OF CERTAINTY. AND THAT
WE KNOW WE ARE GOING TO GET. A
SOLUTION WHICH PROTECTS THE
PUBLIC INTEREST AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
THE ABSENCE OF SETTLEMENTS AND
MANY OF THE CASES. BUT WE ARE
CERTAINLY OPEN. TO CONSIDERING
IMPROVEMENTS OF THE PROCESS BUT
NONE OF THOSE ARE PART. OF OUR
CURRENT SUNSET PROPOSED. AND I
POLICIES ARE JUMPING OVER BY
YOU WANT ASK THIS QUESTION WHEN
IT TO PROVIDE- IS THAT NORMALLY
DOES THAT NORMALLY LIMIT A
POSITION THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
IS THAT OR IS THAT PART OF. THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AS WELL.
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE. OF MANY
TIMES THERE ARE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE PUT WHETHER IT'S TRAINING
THERE COULD BE A- MANDATORY
TESTING IN THE APPROPRIATE
CASES. SOMETIMES THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS ON PRACTICE
SOMETIMES THERE ARE LIMITATIONS
ON SOLO PRACTICE- THERE'S
REQUIRING A PRACTICE MONITOR
BUT THOSE ARE NOT ALWAYS THE
CASE THE CONDITIONS ARE TAILOR
MADE. BASED ON THE CASE. THAT
THE OUR- CONDITIONS AROSE OUT
OF. I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CANDOR I WOULD SAY THAT
PROBABLY MAYBE THE AREA THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON IS THE
MONITORING PART AND MAYBE DO
THAT BETTER- HE SAID IT WAS A
QUARTERLY MEETINGS AND- CHECK
INS AND- THAT MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH. THAT MAY BE SOMETHING
THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO MAKE ONE
MORE OF US BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
INFORMATION THANK YOU SHARE
ROSS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK
MEMBER FONG CENTER TYLER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
APOLOGIZE IF- I'M A BIT
SCATTERED HERE AS YOU CAN SEE I
HAVE A LOT OF- PAPERWORK AND
THEREFORE. A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
OF I KNOW THE PERHAPS THE SOME
OF THE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH ME I SENT IN A
LETTER AT. WHAT IF SEVERAL
QUESTIONS. OF IN AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR. ARE NOT FULLY HAPPY WITH
THE ANSWERS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO ME SO I'LL GO AHEAD AND ASK
SOME OF THOSE AGAIN. I DO WANT
TO JUST BRIEFLY GO OVER SOME OF
THE INFORMATION THAT I PULLED
OUT OF THE WEBSITE THE DC
WEBSITE. OF THE COMPLAINTS FOR
THE FISCAL YEAR 292-019-2020 A
THE BOARD RECEIVED TEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT
COMPLAINTS. AND THEY CLOSED-
TWELVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
THREE BUY THE COMPLETE UNIT- MY
FIRST QUESTION IS CAN YOU
PLEASE- EXPLAIN. GIVE US AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
COMPLAINT UNIT DOES THE ROLE
HOW DO THEY MAKE THE
DETERMINATION OF. OF CLOSING
EIGHT COMPLAINT THAT WAS SENT
TEN BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SAID IT
WAS ABOUT 8085% OF. THAT YOU
KNOW THAT ARE CLOSED DURING YOU
KNOW IT WITHIN THIS UNIT. BUT I
MEAN ARE THE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT LIKE THE LIST CLAIMS THEN
AT THIS POINT I MEAN WHAT WHAT
GOES INTO DETERMINING- CLOSING
THE CASE WITHIN THE UNIT- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- THIS IS
JENNA JONES AGAIN SO. THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT GO
INTO THE INITIAL REVIEW OF A
COMPLAINT OR MATTER- WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT TO THE TEN THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS THAT WERE RECEIVED
DURING THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY- THERE MAY BE CASES
PENDING FROM THE PRIOR FISCAL
YEAR- SO THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THE NUMBER.
INCREASED TO THE TWELVE
THOUSAND FIGURE YOU PRESENTED
BECAUSE WE HAVE CASES THAT ARE
STILL PENDING REVIEW AND
FINALIZATION OR DETERMINATION
SO THAT'S WHERE THE NUMBER CAN
BE INCREASED NOW THE TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS THAT MAY BE CLOSED
AT THE INITIAL REVIEW. MAY
INCLUDE CASES THAT WERE. I'M
NOT USING CASES AND COMPLAINTS
TO SYNONYMOUSLY I'M SORRY IF
THAT CAUSES ANY CONFUSION BUT-
A NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS WE
RECEIVE OUR OUT OF OUR
JURISDICTION THEY EITHER NEED
TO GO TO THE NURSING BOARD. THE
OSTEOPATHIC BOARD- OR ONE OF
THE OTHER ALLIED HEALTH BOARDS
SO. WE IDENTIFY THOSE AS NOT
BEING LICENSED WITH OUR AGENCY
OR UNDER OUR- AREA AND WE'RE
GONNA REFER THOSE OUT SO LAST
YEAR I BELIEVE. THAT WAS. WELL
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CRAP I'M
SORRY- THERE IS APPROXIMATELY.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMPLAINTS
LAST YEAR THAT WERE OUTSIDE OF
OUR JURISDICTION- I'M SORRY NON
JURISDICTIONAL LAST YEAR WERE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED COMPLAINTS
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR- IT ALSO WE
MAY NOT HAVE JURISDICTION OVER
IT MAY BE A BILLING ISSUE- IT
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
FALL UNDER THE UNPROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT- AND THEN- SO YOU. THE
INITIAL REVIEW ALSO INCLUDES IF
WE GET AN ANONYMOUS COMPLAINT
DO WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE A PATIENT NAMED TRYING
TO IDENTIFY SOMEBODY THAT WE
CAN GO TO OR GATHER ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION- THE ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINT CAN BE. A HUGE AN
AMOUNT OF OUR INCOMING
COMPLAINTS. AND THEREFORE.
SOMETIMES A NUMBER OF THOSE ARE
CLOSED- IT THERE'S JUST A LOT
OF FACTORS INVOLVED SOMETIMES
WE WILL SEND A REQUEST FOR
RELEASE OF MEDICAL RECORDS AND
WE SEND A COUPLE OF REALLY
REQUEST AND WE DON'T GET A
RESPONSE- BUT IS THERE A
PROCESS INCLUDE REVIEWS THESE
COMPLAINTS YEAH I GUESS THAT'S
WHAT AND WHAT WHAT IS THIS THE
INTERNAL STRUCTURE FOR
DETERMINING WHERE A CASE FOR A
COMPLAINT. SHOULD EVEN BE FILED
OR MOVE TOWARDS A DETAIL OR IS
OUT OF THE JURISDICTION OKAY SO
WHEN THE COMPLAINT FIRST HITS
OUR OFFICER IT'S GOING TO GO TO
OUR TRIAGE UNIT WHICH IS CALLED
THE CENTRAL COMPLAINT UNIT.
THAT IS THEIR ROLE IS TO TRIAGE
THAT COMPLAINT OR AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION OF TV REPORT- NEWS
ARTICLE THE- MALPRACTICE
REPORT. AN ARREST REPORT IT
WHATEVER THAT MAY BE THAT IS
EVALUATED BY THE CENTRAL
COMPLAINT UNIT AND STARTED ON
THE PROCESS. OF MOVING TOWARDS.
THE BEING SENT MORE. BUT OUR
INITIAL STEPS ARE. BUT THE
MAJORITY ARE IN THE CENTRAL
COMPLAINT UNIT THERE PUT IT THE
MAJORITY OF THE COMPLAINTS ARE
CLOSED WITHIN THIS UNIT SO I'M
TRYING TO. FIGURE OUT WHO ARE
THE DECISION MAKERS WITHIN THIS
UNIT THAT. MAKE THE DECISION TO
CLOSE THE A COMPLAINT- THE
ANALYSTS WE HAVE A STAFF OF
ANALYSTS AND MANAGERS AND THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE REVIEWING
THE CASES WE ALSO SEND THOSE
CASES BEFORE A MEDICAL
CONSULTANT GROUP- AND THEY'RE
HELPING US REVIEW THE CASES TO
DETERMINE IF THE CASES. APPEAR
TO HAVE A POSSIBLE VIOLATION.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
COMPLAINT DOESN'T GO TO A
MEDICAL CONSULTANT AND LESS
IT'S- CONSIDERED NOW AN
INVESTIGATION IS THAT ACCURATE-
THAT IS. NOT ACCURATE HE CASES
THAT WE RECEIVE THE RECORDS ON
THAT WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN
RECORDS ON AND WE FEEL THAT
THERE MAY BE AT A POSSIBLE
VIOLATION. THOSE ALL GO TO A
MEDICAL CONSULTANT REVIEW- THE
EX. THE MEDICAL CONSULTANT
REVIEW IS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
ONE OF THE STATUES TWENTY TO
TWENTY POINT AWAIT WHERE
SOMEONE WHO HAS SIMILAR
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE REVIEWS
THE RECORD RECORD SOME SORRY
AND DETERMINES IF THERE'S A
POSSIBLE VIOLATION IN THE
MATTER. AND THAT IS ONCE WE
CLEARED THAT HURDLE THEN THE
CASE GOES OUT TO H. Q. ARE YOU
OVER CHAU. FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION. OKAY AND I KNOW
YOU DID MENTION AT THE
BEGINNING THERE THAT THERE'S
ANALYSTS AND MANAGERS A TRIAGE
WITHIN THE- COMPLETE UNIT.
RIGHT YES DO YOU DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE- THEY ARE
THEY'RE PREPARED TO PROVIDE THE
PROOF FOR AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE STANDARD OF CARE- THIS
PRODUCT- CENTER THEY'RE NOT
DETERMINING THE STANDARD OF
CARE THEY'RE VALUING IT TO
PRESENT IT TO THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANT WHO IS A LICENSED
PHYSICIAN WHO WILL BE
DETERMINING OF A STANDARD. OF
CARE WAS VIOLATED. BUT SOME
DON'T GO TO THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS RATE I MEAN THEY
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION IF IT
GOES TO THE MEDICAL CONSULTANT
NEXT. AS AT ARBOR. WELL IF IT'S
AS IF IT'S SOME A SITUATION
WHERE- OFFICE STAFF WERE RUDE
TO THE ALLEGE THE ALLEGATION IS
THAT THE STAFF FROM OF CLINICAL
RUDE OR SOMETHING YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT WOULD NOT GO TO A
MEDICAL CONSULTANT AND THAT IS
THE CASE THAT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE JURISDICTION
ON- IF IT'S- REGARDING A
PHYSICIAN'S CARE SO YOU KNOW IT
YES I'M NOT GONNA SAY EVERY
CASE GOES TO THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANT. BUT IF IT'S
INVOLVING PATIENT CARE YES IT
IS GOING TO THE MEADOW WALKER
SENATE WOULD YOU SAY AND THE
POINT AT THAT THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANT. OF THE THAT. I
WOULD BE HAPPY RESEARCH SEVEN
GET YOUR NUMBER I'M SORRY I
DON'T HAVE THAT WITH TODAY THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAVE REGARDING
THE CENTRAL COMPLAINT UNIT AND
OR WHEN A COMPLAINT GOES TO-
THE MEDICAL CONSULTANT IS THERE
ANY SCREENING- THAT IS DONE
THROUGH THE NATIONAL
PRACTITIONER DATA BANK- WE
RECEIVED COMPLAINTS- WE RECEIVE
REPORTS ON THE NATIONAL
PRACTITIONER DATA BANK AND WE
INITIATE COMPLAINTS FROM THOSE.
BUT A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
PROCESS. AS A CHEN USUALLY NAY
STARTED ANOTHER OUT OF STATE
PRACTICE OR OUT OF STATE ACTION.
WHICH ONE CAN YOU CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THAT FOR TO MYSELF AND
OTHERS LISTEN IN AND-
ABSOLUTELY SO IF. WE RECEIVE A
REPORT FROM THE NATIONAL
PRACTITIONER DATA BANK- THAT
COULD BE- ACTION TAKEN BY A
HOSPITAL- WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW
UP AND SEE IF WE ALREADY HAVE
AN EIGHT OO. FIVE PORT WHICH IS
A MANDATORY REPORT ON THAT- IT
MAY ALSO BE AN OUT OF STATE
ACTION TAKEN AGAINST A POSITION
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
INITIATED AND- COMPLAINTS GOING
TO BE INITIATED BUT IT'S GOING
TO BE CONSIDERED AN OUT OF
STATE. CASE AND THAT THAT'S
WHEN WE START GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM THE OTHER
STATE- AND WE TAKE. A LOOK AT
JURISDICTION TO OBTAIN ALL OF
THE RECORDS FROM THE HOSPITALS
IN THOSE STATES BUT WE'RE
ATTAINING ANY OTHER STATES
ACTION THAT THEY TOOK AGAINST
THE LICENSEE AND MOVING FORWARD
IF. FORWARD WITH A COMPLAINT OR
CASE BASED ON THAT MATTER BUT
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY. TO GO
INTO THE DATABASE AND- LOOK UP
A DOCTOR THAT. MAYBE ARE
THERE'S A COMPLAINT ABOUT IN
FRONT OF YOU AND GET BACKGROUND
OF INFORMATION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THERE'S BEEN DISCIPLINARY
ACTION IN THE PAST. AND SOME
OTHER STATE IN REGARDS TO THIS
DOCTOR. WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAVE THAT IN OUR DATABASE. SO
ARE YOU REVIEWING YOUR DATABASE.
AT THE MOMENT AND DOES THAT
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT- A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION IN OTHER
STATES. IF IT'S BEEN REPORTED
THROUGH THE NATIONAL BACK
PRACTITIONER DATABANK YES IT'S
GOING TO BE IN OUR DATABASE SO
YOU TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT IN
TERMS OF THE DO YOU TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT OR THE INFORMATION
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THE TRIAGE-
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
HISTORY YES- IT IT ALL DEPENDS
ON WHAT THE MATTER WAS IS IT
CURRENT IS IT TEN YEARS AGO- SO
IT'S GOING TO BE EVALUATED. BUT
IT DEPENDS ON THE CIRCUIT
DEPENDS ON THE DETAILS INVOLVED.
N. E. I KNOW THAT YOU THERE WAS
MENTION OF- SOME SORT OF A
DOCUMENT THAT YOU RECEIVED OR
OR NOTIFICATION IF THERE'S A
YOU KNOW AN INDIVIDUAL THAT
RECEIVED- DISCIPLINARY ACTION
IT AND OTHER STATE OR BEEN YOU
LOOK INTO IT AND THEN YOU. I'M
I'M ASSUMING TO REVOKE THE
LICENSE AT THAT POINT- IT WOULD
DEPEND ON THE DISCIPLINE TAKEN
ANY OTHER STATE- IF THEY WERE
GIVEN A PUBLIC REPRIMAND- THAT
WOULD WE USUALLY GENERALLY
FOLLOW WHAT THE OTHER STATE HAS
DONE- WITH OUR OWN ACTION. IT
WOULD DEPEND ON THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE ACTION TAKEN AND THE
OTHER STATE. I DON'T WANT TO
SHIFT A LITTLE BIT IT TOOK THAT
BACK TO THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS- THE MMHM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE IN
TERMS OF THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS YOU HAVE THAT THE
PERMANENT INTERMITTENT OR THE
PART TIME CAN YOU EXPLAIN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THEIR
ACTUAL ROLE IF THEY'RE ACTUALLY
STATE EMPLOYEES HOW OFTEN THEY
COME AND HOME AND I KNOW YOU
THERE WAS MENTION THAT THERE'S
ABOUT THIRTY THREE CONSULTANCY
HAVE MET. MEDICAL CONSULTANTS.
FROM THE MEDICAL CONSULTANTS
FOR THE MOST PART ARE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS- THAT
WE HAVE CONTRACTORS MORE THAN
THIRTY THREE YOU MAY BE
SPEAKING. WE HAVE A FULL PANEL
OF MEDICAL CONSULTANTS YOU MAY
BE FOCUSING ON THE NUMBER THAT
ARE INVOLVED WITH THE H. Q. WHY
YOU. ANSWERED THEM DIRECTLY WE
DO HAVE A CHIEF MEDICAL
CONSULTANT- THAT IS ON STAFF.
BUT THE OTHER MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS THAT WERE FOR IN
THESE CASES TO ARE NOT FULL
TIME. EMPLOYEES OF THE BOARD
THEY'RE ALL CONTRACTORS. SO
THEIR CONTRACT EMPLOYEES ARE
NOT STATE EMPLOYEES IS THAT
CORRECT. YES MA'AM. OKAY AND
ANOTHER IS ALSO EXPERT
REVIEWERS ARE THOSE CONTRACT
EMPLOYEES AS WELL. YES MA'AM
THEY ARE. AND HOW MANY EXPERT
REVIEWERS DO YOU HAVE. I
BELIEVE THE LAST NUMBER IN THE
POOL WAS SOMEWHERE OVER. SIX
HUNDRED. OVER SIX HUNDRED YES
MA'AM. DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY DO
YOU HAVE FOR SPECIALTY- I COULD
GET THAT INFORMATION FOR YOU I
DO NOT HAVE THAT. AT THIS
MOMENT. I WANNA ALSO JUST
BRIEFLY MENTION- THAT RIGHT
SORRY I REPRESENTED THE PARTS
OF A FRESNO TULARE KINGS AND
KERN COUNTIES I DID SOME MORE
OR ADDITIONAL RESEARCH- I
LOOKED THROUGH THE ACT OF
LICENSES WITH DISCIPLINARY
ACTION- WITH NO PUBLIC DOCUMENT
THERE'S- ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT ACTIVE LICENSES
WITH DISCIPLINARY ACTION BUT-
AND WITH A PUBLIC DOCUMENT
AVAILABLE THERE'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY SIX- IT ALSO
WANTED TO MENTION THAT THERE
WERE. IN FORTY LICENSES THAT
WERE SURRENDERED BUT SOME AFTER
THE FACT. AND I THINK YOU
TOUCHED ON THIS JUST A LITTLE
BIT EARLIER BACK WHEN YOU GET
THE NOTIFICATION THE NATIONAL
NOTIFICATION THEN YOU TAKE
ACTION AND IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
THE CASE AND SO THAT'S WHY I
ASKED EARLIER IF YOU LOOKED
INTO THEN. IF YOU DID. KIND OF
LIKE IN A PERMANENT WAY IT
LOOKED AT THE DATA BASE TO LOOK
AT THAT- LOOK UP DOCTORS THAT
HAVE COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEM-
BECAUSE IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A
LOT OF. IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF INFORMATION. THAT
IS BEING- IT COLLECTED FROM THE
ERRORS THAT WERE INFORMING
OURSELVES- FROM THE FROM THE
NATIONAL. DATABASE SO WANTED
JUST TO POINT THAT OUT. BUT IT
JUST A STATEMENT. I'M NOT. YEAH
THANK YOU. JUST. SO I NOTED IN
MY ORIGINAL- QUESTION- IT OR
THE LETTER THAT I SENT LAST
YEAR THE ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTION I ASKED WAS CAN YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE A REVIEW OF WHY
LICENSE REVOCATION WAS.
ORIGINALLY CONSIDERED AS PART
OF A DISCIPLINARY ACTION BUT
WAS NOT ISSUED CAN YOU. DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
OR OUR RESPONSE TO THAT. IF I
CAN TAKE THAT UP SENATOR IT'S
THE FORM OF PLEADING THAT IS
DONE AS PART OF THE LEGAL
PROCESS IN THE ACCUSATION STAGE
IS THAT WE SET OUT A WHOLE
RANGE OF WHAT POSSIBLE
SANCTIONS MAY BE AVAILABLE. BUT
IT'S ONLY AFTER THE CONCLUSION
OF THE INVESTIGATION- THAT WE
HAVE A BETTER SENSE AS TO WHAT
IS ACHIEVABLE SO IT IS
ROUTINELY STATED AND
ACCUSATIONS THAT ONE OF THE
OPTIONS IS REVOCATION. BUT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE THE APPROPRIATE
SANCTION. THERE WERE A TOPIC I
WANTED TO KIND OF COVERS
PROBATION. WHEN THE WHEN THE
DOCTOR HAS BEEN DISCIPLINED AND
THERE'S SOMEONE THAT ACTUALLY
MONITORS MONITORS THEM LOCALLY.
WHY WHY ARE THE NAMES KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL I MEAN IF I AM
MADE- I MEET CONSUMER RIGHT I'M
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT GO TO THE
RIGHT DOCTOR BUT THERE'S A
DOCTOR THAT'S BEEN- DISCIPLINE
IN MY REGION. I MEAN IF I HAVE
EVEN A COMPLAINT ABOUT A DOCTOR
OR- HAVE SOME CONCERNS HOW DO.
I MEAN HOW DO I USE EXPRESSES
CONCERNS IF WE'D HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF WHO THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS. YOU MEAN WHO
THAT PRATT WHO THE PROBATION
MONITORS. IT IS THE ONE THAT
WORKS DIRECTLY WITH THE DOCTOR.
LOCALLY. IS THAT WHAT THEY'RE
CALLED PROBATION MONITORS- SO
B. BOARD EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD
BE READ MONITORING THE DOCTORS
ON PROBATION WOULD BE OUR
PROBATION MONITORS- I AM. NOT
AWARE THAT SHE OR THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS. HAS NOT BEEN- I
UNDERSTAND THAT INDIVIDUAL HAS
HAD CONTACT WITH- A HIGH
PROFILE CASE THAT I BELIEVE
YOU'RE REFERRING TO- BUT I WAS
NOT AWARE THAT- THEIR IDENTITY
WAS CONFIDENTIAL. SO THE SOUL
PROBATION MONITORS INFORMATION
IS NOT CONFIDENTIAL IT'S PUBLIC
RECORD IS WHAT YOU'RE TELLING
ME. I COULD I CAN HAVE ACCESS
OR IF I CALL AND I CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION IF I REQUESTED.
MMHM I WILL DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT. YOU CAN. MAY I GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE- THANK. DO YOU
HAVE ANY GUIDELINES- SET UP. IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU KIND OF JUST
IT'S A CASE BY CASE BASIS BUT
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY SORT OF
GUIDELINES THAT YOU USED TO
ISSUE CITATIONS UNDER PROBATION.
YES. CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT A
LITTLE BIT. IF AN INDIVIDUAL ON
PROBATION IS DETERMINED TO NOT
BE COMPLYING WITH SOME OF THE
EITHER. A SPECIFIC TERM- OF A
PROBATIONARY ORDER- THE FIRST
STEP IS A CITATION PROCESS
DEPENDING ON THE- THE EXTENT OF
THE VIOLATION- BUT IF A
CITATION MAY BE UTILIZED. TO
ADDRESS NONCOMPLIANCE. NOW DID
IT DOES THE CONSUMER HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BUY ALL THE I DON'T
KNOW DID SOME SORT OF. IF
THERE'S AN OUTCOME AND A
PARTICULAR COMPLAINT AND OR
KEYS DOES A CONSUMER HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. DISAGREE WITH THAT
OUTCOME AND IT. PETITION ONCE
AGAIN. THE INDIVIDUAL
COMPLAINANTS MAY CERTAINLY
WRITE US AND LET US KNOW- THAT
THEIR OWN HAPPIER DISPLEASED
WITH THE FINAL OUTCOME. BUT. AS
FAR AS AMENDING THAT OUTCOME. I
AM NOT AWARE THAT THAT. IS AN
OPTION. BECAUSE THE MATTER IS
ALREADY BECOME PUBLIC AND HAS
BEEN FINALIZED. WELL I'M
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AFTER THE FACT I
MEAN ISN'T THIS FORD ABOUT
PATIENT PROTECTION. YES MA'AM.
BUT THERE IS A PROCESS FOR
DOCTORS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
KIND OF THING IF THEY'RE IF
THEY DON'T IF THEY DISAGREE
WITH THE OUTCOME THEY CAN FILE.
ARE A SYMPTOM OF. YES A COUNTER
COMPLAINT IS THAT ACCURATE
SENATOR I COULD ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION- IF I COULD ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION YES YOU HAVE
POINTED OUT TO WHAT HAVE MANY
PEOPLE IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
OF THOUGHT IS AN ANOMALY IN THE
ACT. BASICALLY THE COMPLAINANT
IS THE MEDICAL BOARD- THE
DOCTOR IS THE RESPONSE THAT IF
THE DOCTORS ARE HAPPY WITH THE
OUTCOME THERE IS NO RIGHT OF
APPEAL THERE'S NO SUCH RIGHT OF
APPEAL ABOUT THE COMPLAINANTS
NOW IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS WHAT
THEY DO IS THEY HAVE ANOTHER
BOARD. WHICH HAS A RIGHT TO
APPEAL DECISIONS ON THE BASIS
OF PUBLIC PROTECTION AND
PARTICULARLY ON THE BASIS THAT
THERE THAT THE SANCTION IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM THERE'S A BODY
CALLED THE PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS AUTHORITY A SORT OF A
REGULATOR OF REGULATORS WHICH
HAS THAT ROLE. THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
NO RIGHT IF THE COMPLAINANT.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THE PATIENT TO
APPEAL RIGHT. THAT'S MY DIRECT.
MY NEXT QUESTION IS WHAT
PROPORTION OF CASES
INVESTIGATED BY THE BORDER
CASES INVOLVED PATIENTS USING
MEDIC CALPERS IS COMMERCIAL
INSURERS. I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THAT INFORMATION CENTER
WILL BE HAPPY TO TRY TO GET IT
BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
CAPTURED ON OUR DATABASE
ANYWHERE. WELL I HAVE. BE HERE
ALL DAY AND ASK ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- BUT I WILL- IT LEAVE
IT AT THE MOMENT AS AS AS THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR ANSWERS. WELCOME
THANK CENTER TELL A MEMBER
GRAYSON. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU CHAIR OFTEN ALSO
CHAIR ROLE ROUTE LOWS WELL AND
I UNDERSTAND TODAY'S HEARING
THE SUBJECT MATTER IS
SPECIFICALLY ON ENFORCEMENT AND
SO IN REFERENCE TO YOUR POWER
POINT- THE SLIDE- RIGHT BEFORE
THE LAST ONE. IT TOUGH TALKS
ABOUT FORMS REQUIRED AND FIRST
A STATEMENT AND THAT IS
ASSEMBLY THIS THAT HAVING HEARD
THE TESTIMONY AND THE BACK AND
FORTH ESPECIALLY ABOUT THE NEWS
ARTICLE- I NOW SEE THE FIRST
BULLET POINT AS CLOSER
ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN NBC. AND THE
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT. AS UNDER
INSTITUTIONAL AS A REFORM
REQUIRED- THAT STATEMENT THERE
SPEAKS VOLUMES NOW AND I WOULD
EVEN PROBABLY INCLUDE THE-
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AS FAR AS CLOSER ENGAGEMENT MY
QUESTION IS- THE SECOND
BALANCES INCREASED FLEXIBILITY
TO MOVE INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES. FROM SWORN TO NON
SWORN STAFF- WHAT WOULD BE. THE
BENEFIT FOR THE IMPROVEMENT
THAT THE BOARD IS EXPECTING OR
LOOKING FOR FROM HAVING
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY AND WHAT
EXACTLY DOES IN FLEET THE
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY. AND
RESOURCES OF MEAN. YEAH I WILL
BE HAPPY TO BEGIN THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION- THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT WE'RE HAVING.
SWORN OFFICERS IN TOO MANY
CASES TO DO WORK THAT COULD BE
DONE BY NON SWORN OFFICERS. THE
EFFECT OF THIS IS THE DIRECT
EFFECT ON COST AND ON TIME. SO
WE'RE LOOKING TO BE AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE AS THIS
IS IN THE BACKDROP OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD THAT HAS IT-
LOOMING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. SO
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND THIS IS
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IN A NUMBER
OF AREAS. IS TO DEAL WITH EACH
CASE APPROPRIATELY WE BELIEVE
HAT MORE CASES CAN BE DEALT
WITH IN A NON ADVERSARIAL
FASHION. WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
CAN BE SETTLED AT AN EARLIER
STAGE AND- REMEDIATION CAN BE
INITIATED FASTER AND IN MORE
CASES. SIMILARLY WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE MANY OF THE
ADVERSARIAL CASES THAT CAN BE
RESOLVED BY NON SWORN.
PERSONNEL FASTER AND IN A MORE
<c.blue>FFICIENT WAY. AND AT THE END</c>
OF THE DAY THE GOAL HERE IS TO
FREE UP RESOURCES FOR THE VERY
DIFFICULT CASES THE VERY
SERIOUS CASES. MANY OF WHICH
CAN BE QUITE COMPLICATED
WITCHER VERY STRENUOUSLY
CONTESTED AND WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE RESOURCES FOR THOSE SO
THAT'S. THE GOAL IN ALL OF
THESE REFORMS. FOR THANK YOU
ROOM GRAYSON DUCT FAN. I THANK
YOU AS CHAIRMAN OF- FREESHEET
THE OPPORTUNITY JUST TO ASK A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO ENFORCEMENT- FIRST QUESTION
ACTUALLY SOLD A FOLLOW UP FROM
A SERVER TIED UP SO- CERTAINLY-
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH A
PHYSICIAN WHO IS FOUND TO BE-
DECISION OR NEGLIGENT- WHICH IS
A PLACED ON PROBATION AND THEIR
PRACTICE NEEDS TO BE
SUPERVISED. NOW I KNOW IN ONE
CASE OF A PHYSICIAN WHO-
BASICALLY CHAU POOR
DOCUMENTATION ALSO HAD A RECORD
OF- READY INAPPROPRIATE
EXEMPTIONS FOR VACCINATIONS
THAT- PART OF THE BOARD'S
DISCIPLINE INCLUDED A- AT THE
PROVISION INCLUDED SUPERVISION.
BY ANOTHER PHYSICIAN BUT
INTERESTING ENOUGH HE GOT TO
SELECT A POSITION HE WAS
SUPERVISING HIM DURING HIS
PROBATION IS THAT NORMAL COURSE
FOR THE BOARD I FIND THAT- WHY
WOULD THE PERSON WHO ACTUALLY
COMMITTED THE VIOLATION YOU GET
TO PICK THE PERSON WHO GETS TO
WATCH. THIS PERFORMANCE. GOING
TO THE FUTURE DURING PROBATION-
SENATOR PAM I BELIEVE THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IS THEY PRESENTS THE
LICENSEE PRESENTS. OPTIONS TO
THE PRACTICE MANAGER- I'M SORRY
TO THE PROBATION MONITOR- AND
IT SAY. PROCESS. THAT THEY HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS OF
EVALUATION AND- UNDERSTANDING-
THEY CAN'T BE THEY CAN'T WORK
WITH THEM THEY CAN'T BE RELATED
TO- IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE AT AN
ARM'S LENGTH- WELL THAT THAT
WASN'T CERTAINLY INDICATING THE
DOCUMENTATION I THINK IT'S
APROPOS TO SEND HER TARDIS
QUESTION. SHOULDN'T THE MEDICAL
BOARD ITSELF TAKE ON
RESPONSIBILITY PERHAPS WORKING
WITH LOCAL PROFESSIONALS SIZE
SUPPORT AND THEN A FINE
INDEPENDENT MONITOR INSTEAD OF
RELYING ON THE VERY PHYSICIAN
HE'S BEING PUT ON PROBATION TO
IDENTIFY THEIR OWN MONITOR. YES
I WILL- I AGREE WITH YOU AND I
WILL CERTAINLY LOOK INTO THAT I
MEAN I APPRECIATE YOU SAYING
THEY HAVE TO BE OBSOLETE EXCEPT
YOU'RE ASKING THE VERY PERSONS
BEING PUNISHED TO IDENTIFY
SOME. INITIAL CANDIDATES THAT'S
NOT ARMS LIKE THAT POINT AS
SOON AS THEY'RE INVOLVED IT'S
NOT ARMS LIKE THAT ANYMORE. NO
MATTER WHO THEY BECAUSE THERE'S
YOU KNOW I DON'T I DON'T THINK
THAT PERSON'S EXACTLY AN
OBJECTIVE PERSON TO ADD BE
ASKING. WHO SHOULD MONITOR
THEIR OWN DEFICIENCIES. OKAY
I'M GLAD WE HAVE AGREEMENT
HERE- THE SECOND ONE ACTUALLY
IN THE SAME CASE IS INTERESTING
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE WERE
SEVERAL AGAIN APPRECIATE- AND
THIS. THE YOU KNOW SEVERAL
STEPS THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
DID TAKE BUT ONE THE FASTENING
PARTS THOUGH WAS IS THAT- YOU
KNOW. THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM
THAT LED TO HIS. HIS BEING
SANCTIONED WAS NOT ACTUALLY
PROHIBITED FOR HIM DOING IN THE
FUTURE. SO IT WASN'T BANNED
FROM WRITING FOR THEIR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS NOW SUBSEQUENT LAW
HAS CHANGED THAT CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT- SHOULDN'T THE PERSON WHO.
IS DEFICIENT. IN THE AREA THAT
THEY WERE ARE BEING. RELATIONS
SHOULD THERE BE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES SOME CITY YOU
KNOW SHOULDN'T BE SANCTIONED
ALSO INVOLVE AT LEAST CERTAINLY
IF IT'S NOT. ESSENTIAL TO THEIR
PATIENT CARE DUTIES- NOT
ENGAGING IN THE VERY BEHAVIOR
THAT TRIGGERED THE REASON THAT
THEY'RE BEING PLACED ON.
PROBATION ARE THE OBVIOUS HERE
LET'S BY SUSPEND THEY CAN'T BUT
THEY BEING PLACED ON PROBATION
SHOULD THAT BE ALWAYS INCLUDED
IN THE US SANCTIONS FOR THE
POSITION. CERTIFICATION IF I
COULD INTERJECT HERE ALL OF
THESE SETTLEMENTS AND SANCTIONS
ARE VERY MUCH HE SPOKE THE RISE
OUT OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE IT MAY BE
THE CASE IN CERTAIN TYPES OF
CASES THAT THERE IS A IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A
PROHIBITION ORDER IN RELATION
TO THE CONDUCT UNDER QUESTION
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS APPROPRIATE
IN EVERY CASE IN FACT I WOULD
THINK PROHIBITION SOME PRACTICE
OR SOMETHING WHICH WOULD BE
MORE THE EXCEPTION RATHER THAN
THE RULE IT ALL DEPENDS ON THE
FACTS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE.
WE WILL BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT IN
THE ANY MORE DETAIL THAT IN THE
INDIVIDUAL CASE BUT JUST TO SAY
THAT THE SANCTIONS THEY ARE
MEANT TO BE VERY SPECIFIC TO
THE FACT THAT WELL IN THE SOME
OF THE SAME WAY- DAHLE GO
ACROSS TO THE SAME FORMULA OKAY
WELL I UNDERSTAND THERE'S IN
THE FORMULA BUT LET'S PUT IT
THIS WAY IF FURTHER SANCTION
HAS TO DEAL WITH THEIR- ABUSE
OF THEIR AUTHORITY THE LICENSE
AUTHORITY- THAT HAS AN IMPACT
ON PUBLIC HEALTH RADIOWORKS
ENABLES FRAUD- AND- IT ISN'T
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE ACTUAL
TERROR OF- YOU KNOW THERE'S. A
PROVISION OF CLINICAL CARE. I
THINK SOMEONE ENGAGE IN THAT
SHOULD BE PER. FROM BEING ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT SO THEY LET'S SAY- MISS
CERTIFIED DISABILITY PAYMENTS-
DAY- MET YOU KNOW PROVIDED THE
INCORRECT- INFORMATION- TO.
STATE AGENCIES LOCAL AGENCIES-
USING THEIR MEDICAL LICENSE
AUTHORITY TO ALLOW. PATIENTS TO
ESSENTIALLY- EITHER RECEIVE
HEALTH SERVICES OR BENEFITS
THEY WERE ENTITLED TO OR- BE
ABLE TO PERFORM YOU KNOW. THAT
THAT IS A PUT OTHER PEOPLE AT
RISK SO BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTION TO YOUR
AGENCY OF THE STATE. THAT WHY
SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
EITHER. OUR COMMUNITIES OR-
CONTINUE TO DEFRAUD THE THAT
THE THAT THE PUBLIC. ESPECIALLY
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEY WERE BEING A- WELL THE
REASON THAT THE CLIENTS. AND
WONDER REASONS ARE BEING
SANCTIONED. THIS SENATOR I CAN
ASSURE YOU. THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
A FRESH LOOK AT THESE CASES.
ISSUES OF FINANCIAL FRAUD OR
THINGS THAT COME TO FREQUENTLY
BEFORE THE MEDICAL BOARD. I
TAKE THE VIEW OF PRETTY MUCH
CLOSE TO ZERO TOLERANCE.
POSITION IN THESE KINDS OF
THINGS THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
ARISE ONE IS THE FINANCIAL
FRAUD. IT BECAUSE IT'S A FRAUD
AS YOU IDENTIFIED ON THE ENTIRE
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. SECONDLY
I HAVE DEEP CONCERNS THAT A
PHYSICIAN WHO COMMITS FINANCIAL
FRAUD. IS WELL NOT THE KIND OF
PERSON THAT REALLY SHOULD BE A
PHYSICIAN FULL STOP IT IS
LIKELY NOT TO PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE TO PATIENTS SO I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE TAKE THESE THINGS
VERY SERIOUSLY. WE HAVE ENGAGED
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE COURSE OF ACTION.
IN THESE TYPES OF CASES AND WE
HAVE TAKEN ACTIONS TO HAVE MUCH
MORE. STRENUOUS AND STRICT
APPROACHES TO THESE CASES I
THINK THERE ARE SOME OF THE
MOST SERIOUS CASES THAT COME
BEFORE THE MEDICAL BOARD. AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO DEAL WITH
THEM. IN THE IN THE MOST
APPROPRIATE WAY WHICH IN MANY
CASES. WILL HAVE TO BE
REVOCATION SO I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND I KNOW THAT
WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
TO REVIEW THE ENTIRE ISSUE OF
SANCTIONS IN THESE TYPES OF
CASES I APPRECIATE THAT I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT SOMETIMES I
WONDER WHY EVERYTHING ON
PROBATION WHICH JUST REVOKED
LICENSE- SO- AND I REALIZE THAT
THERE'S CHALLENGES FOR YOU AS
YOU'VE EXPLAINED- TO. INITIALLY
GO DOWN THAT PATH ENTIRELY BUT
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO BE SURE THAT
MEDICAL BOARD NOT ONLY OF
COURSE PROTECTS INDIVIDUAL
PATIENTS BUT PROTECTS ALL OF US
IN CALIFORNIA AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
TRYING. TO AND THIS PANDEMIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR PAN
LET ME- YOU KNOW WHEN WE
REFERENCE THESE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES AND I ACTUALLY%
LOOKED AT THEM AND IT APPEARS
THAT THE BOARD HAS ISSUED
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES IN THE
FORM OF. REGULATIONS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY SET OUT IN OUR
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
AND IT IT APPEARS THAT YOU'VE
ALSO PUBLISHED A MANUAL FOR
MODEL DISCIPLINARY ORDERS AND
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES. IN
REVIEWING THIS MANUAL I KNOW TO
DO A FEW STATEMENTS THAT I
THOUGHT WERE SIGNIFICANT ONE
IS- IN THE PREAMBLE THESE
GUIDELINES SET FORTH THE
DISCIPLINE THE BOARD FINDS
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY FOR
THE- IDENTIFIED VIOLATIONS AND
THERE ARE VIOLATIONS THAT ARE
SPECIFIED. IN THE MANUAL
GENERAL CLASSIFICATIONS AND
THEN THERE'S A FURTHER
STATEMENT IN ADDITION TO
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND WE'RE
NOT IN AND WE'RE NOT
INCONSISTENT. REHABILITATING
THE LICENSEE. THE BOARD FINDS
THAT IMPOSITION OF THE
DISCIPLINE SET FORTH IN THE
GUIDELINES WILL PROMOTE
UNIFORMITY CERTAINTY. AND
FAIRNESS AND DETERRENCE AND IN
TURN FURTHER PUBLIC. A
PROTECTION WITH RESPECT TO
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
DEVIATIONS FROM THE GUIDELINES
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
MANUAL PROVIDES. ANY PROPOSED
DECISION OR SETTLEMENT THAT
DEPARTS FROM THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES SHALL IDENTIFY THE
DEPARTURES AND THE FACTS
SUPPORTING THE DEPARTURE SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU. IS THIS IN
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE CASES
WERE STIPULATED SETTLEMENT
WHICH USED. WHERE THE
GUIDELINES FOLLOWED. ANYONE US
SENATOR THIS IS A QUESTION THAT
WE HAVE LOOKED AT IN SOME
DETAIL FROM TIME TO TIME. THE
SETTLEMENTS ALL DEPEND ON THE
FACTS THAT INDIVIDUAL CASES AS
WE INDICATED THE GUIDELINES ARE
BASED ON THE SUPPOSITION THAT
ALL PARTS OF THE CASE HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO A CLEAR AND
CONVINCING STANDARD. AND THEY
SIMPLY DO NOT- THEY CANNOT
APPLY IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES TO
ALL CASES THE SETTLEMENTS ARE
THE GUIDELINES ALSO GENERALLY
HAVE A RANGE OF SANCTIONS. SO
WE DON'T KEEP RECORDS IN TERMS
OF PERCENTAGE DEVIATION FROM
THE GUIDELINES IN THE CONTEXT
OF EVERY FASCICULATA CASE WHAT
I WANTED TO DO THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO REBUILD SORT OF A
DATABASE AND IT WOULD BE QUITE
DIFFICULT TO DO. WELL I'D BE
INTERESTED IN THE IN THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION SO ONE OF
THESE YOU CAN ADD THIS TO MY
LIST OF QUESTIONS AND
INFORMATION THAT I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO PROVIDE O THE
COMMITTEES THROUGH THE-
RESPECTIVE CHIEF CONSULTANTS
AND THAT IS LOOKING BACK OVER
THELAST. YEAR WHETHER IT'S
CALENDAR OR FISCAL HOWEVER YOU
CAN. PAGLIA RECORDS I'D LIKE TO.
HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE CASES- THOSE STIPULATED
SETTLEMENT CASES. WORE THE
GUIDELINES FOLLOWED. LET ME ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION. HELLO IN
THOSE CASES WHERE THE
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT DEVIATED
FROM THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES THAT ARE PUBLISHED
IN THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS TO DO YOUR WRITTEN
RECORDS TO THE BOARDS WRITTEN
RECORDS IDENTIFY THE GUIDELINE
DEPARTURE AND THE FACTS AND THE
RATIONALE SUPPORTING THE
DEPARTURE AS REQUIRED BY THE
REGULATIONS. SENATOR ROB THE
FINANCER THAT. BUT THE PROPOSED
DECISIONS TO CONTAIN THE
RATIONALE OR THEY SHOULD FOR A
DEVIATION FROM THE GUIDELINES
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THE BOARD
MEMBERS LOOK FOR WHEN THEY'RE
REVIEWING A PROPOSED DECISION
AND DETERMINING WHETHER THE-
DISCIPLINE IMPOSED IS
APPROPRIATE. FOR PROPOSED
STIPULATIONS THE REASONS FOR
DEVIATIONS FROM THE GUIDELINES
ARE CONTAINED IN THE MEMO FROM
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHICH I ASSUME IS PRIVILEGE YES
IT IS SANTA CLAUS WILL BECAUSE-
LET'S FOCUS ON ON PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENTATION AND I REALLY I
WAS FOCUSED ON OF STIPULATED
SETTLEMENTS THAT ARE APPROVED
WHAT WOULD BE THE RECORD. THAT
IDENTIFIES THE DEPARTURE AND
THE FACTS AND RATIONALE
SUPPORTING THE DEPARTURE WOULD
THAT BE AN ACTUAL BOARD
DECISION. THE STIPULATION
ITSELF THAT IS PUBLISHED DOES
NOT CONTAIN A DISCUSSION ON THE
REASONS WHY THE STIPULATION
WAS- AGREE TO IT AND BY.
DEVIATION FROM THE GUIDELINES
WHERE APPROPRIATE. REASONS ARE
ARE CONFIDENTIAL PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION PROCESS AND IT IT
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR
THAT TO BE CONTAINED IN A
PUBLIC DOCUMENT. WELL THAT'S
SORT OF CONTRARY TO THE TO THE
MANUAL THAT THE BOARD IS
PUBLISHED. WHAT THE COURT DOES
GET THE REASONS FOR DEVIATION
AND THAT DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL GUIDELINES IN THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL MEMO.
THAT MUST BE INCLUDED IN THEIR
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE RECORDS
REQUEST OR ISSUED A SUBPOENA.
WHAT DOCUMENT ON PRIVILEGED
DOCUMENT WOULD I BE REQUESTING.
HAVING REDACTED PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION OF
COURSE WHAT DOCUMENT WOULD I
REQUEST THAT WOULD GIVE ME THE
REASONS WHY THE GUIDELINES WERE
DEVIATED FROM IT IN ANY
PARTICULAR CASE. REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE SAID PREAMBLE TO THE
GUIDELINES- HILLS REASONS WHY
PROMOTE ORCHARD MY QUESTION IN
A PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH
COMPLAINANTS PRODUCT PART OF
THE ISSUES ISSUES THAT CONTINUE
TO BE BROUGHT TO THE- TO THIS
BODY THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE AND HE'S COMMITTEES. IS
IT PEOPLE. CAN'T FIGURE OUT THE
WHY. AND IT DOESN'T HAVE. NEED
TO LEAD TO IDENTIFYING
PARTICULAR PHYSICIANS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENED TO BE
BEFORE YOUR BOARD. BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE WHY SO
MY QUESTION IS WHAT DOCUMENT
WOULD I REQUEST IN THE POSITION
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT WOULD
TELL ME IN ANY GIVEN
DISCIPLINARY CASE WERE
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT WE USED.
WHAT THE RED AND DEEP THE
GUIDELINES WERE DEVIATED FROM
WHAT THE REASONS FOR THE
DEVIATION WERE. DOES ONE EXIST
WELL SAN RAPHAEL THERE THERE
WOULD BE ATTORNEY WORK PRODUCT
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
MEMO ITSELF BUT I CAN'T ACCESS
THE MONTH SOMEBODY RAISE THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE. SO
ABSENT A WAIVER OF THE ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE WHAT
DOCUMENTS. WOULD LET'S SAY THE
LEGISLATURE BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
TO DETERMINE IN CASES WERE
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT AS A
DISCIPLINARY. PROCESS WAS
UTILIZED AND WE'RE GUIDELINES
WERE DEVIATED FROM THE REASONS
FOR THE DEVIATION. IS THAT
INFORMATION CORRECT. YEAH
CREATING A LOT THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YES PLEASE I'M
LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER. THANK
YOU I MEAN THE ANSWER IS THAT
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE RIGHT AND I
MEDIAN HELPFUL FOR ME TO
EXPLAIN OR WHY THAT INFORMATION
PUBLICLY ELLISON I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THE CONFIDENTIALITY.
AND PHYSICIANS AND ALL OF THAT
MY CONCERN IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE AND WHAT I'M
GOING TO BE QUESTIONING THE
FOLKS ABOUT NEXT IS THE
EFFICACY OF THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS AND WHETHER
DISCIPLINARY POSED. THAT IS
EFFECTIVE AND- WE DIDN'T
PUBLISH DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES
THE MEDICAL BOARD PUBLISHED
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES AND DID
MORE THAN THAT PUT THEM IN THE
CALIFORNIA CODE. OF REGULATIONS
AND A MANUAL THAT YOU PUBLISH
SO RIGHT SOMEBODY NEEDS TO TAKE
A LOOK AT CONSISTENCY BETWEEN
THE IMPOSITION OF DISCIPLINE
AND THE DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES
IN EVALUATE DEVIATIONS FROM THE
GUIDELINES. AND IN SOME CASES
WITHOUT GETTING INTO THE
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION. THE Y. AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY I MEAN WE
PRESUME REGULARITY HERE BELIEVE
IT OR NOT. DESPITE THE TENOR OF
SOME OF OUR QUESTIONS BUT
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
AT. AND ALSO LET ME JUST LET ME
JUST MOVE ON CAN SOMEONE TELL
ME WHAT THE RANGE OF MAYBE THIS
IS BEEN ANSWERED. THE RANGE OF
POSSIBLE DISCIPLINE- IS IN A
PHYSICIAN MISCONDUCT. A CASE
MEAN PUBLIC REPRIMAND IS
SOMEWHERE IN THERE AND THEN IT
GOES TO WHAT. WELL I MEAN IF
YOU JUST START WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SANCTION THAT IS
REVOCATION. AND THEN IF YOU GO
DOWN AND IF YOU'RE REVOKED YOU
REVOKE YOU CANNOT PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DID YOU HAVE
SUSPENSION WHERE YOU CAN
PRACTICE FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME. AND THEN YOU HAVE
PROBATION WITH CONDITIONS AND
THE CONDITIONS CAN BE ANYTHING
FROM A RANGE OF PROHIBITION TO
CERTAIN KINDS OF PRACTICE- TO-
NEEDS OR OF A CHEMICAL.
MONITORING FOR A PRACTICE
MONITOR FOR SUPERVISION THEY'RE
CONDITIONS MAY BE LESS ONEROUS
SUCH AS THE TAKING OF A- OF A
COURSE FOR A MEANS OF STUDY.
THEN YOU GO TO A PUBLIC
REPRIMAND. WHICH IS A SIMPLY A
PUBLIC RECORD REPRIMAND AND
THERE MAY BE CONDITIONS
ATTACHED THERE IN TERMS OF
TRAINING OR COURSES. AND THEN
THERE'S SOMETHING CALLED A
WARNING LETTER AND NO ONE
REALLY KNOWS WHAT THAT IS BUT
IT'S NOT BINDING AND IT'S FOR
ADVISORS. SO THERE'S A WHOLE
SPECTER IS A SPECTRUM. WITHIN
THEIR AND IT GOES FOR MORNING
LETTERS AT THE AT THE LOWEST
ONE UP TO REPLICATION AND WITH
RESPECT TO PROBATION WITH OR
WITHOUT CONDITIONS IF AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THIS MAY HAVE
BEEN REFERENCE PREVIOUSLY TO IN
WHICH CASE I APOLOGIZE IF AN
INDIVIDUAL VIOLATES THE
PROBATION WITH OR WITHOUT
CONDITIONS WHAT'S THE SANCTION.
DO YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE AND GO
THROUGH THE COMPLAINT PROCESS
AGAIN OR IS THERE SOMETHING.
THAT AUTOMATICALLY HAPPENS WELL
I MEAN IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE VIOLATE PROBATION AND
PROBATION WAS DONE IN
SUBSTITUTION FOR REPLICATION
YOU CAN RESULT IN REVOCATION
RIGHT BUT THAT'S WHERE YOU HAVE
A DISCIPLINE THAT'S A SUSPENDED
REVOCATION WITH THE PROBATION
CORRECT. CORRECT WHAT HAPPENS
IF THERE'S NO SUSPENDED
SUSPENSION OR REVOCATION AND
THE DISCIPLINE IMPOSED. IS
SIMPLY PROBATION WITH OR
WITHOUT CONDITIONS WHAT HAPPENS
IF THERE'S A VIOLATION OF
PROBATION- IF I MAY. THAT IS
WHERE. THE DEBATE. THE TYPE OF
DEPARTURE FROM THE PROBATION
TERM WOULD BE IDENTIFIED. AND
IT MAY BE A- A CITATION- IT MAY
BE A- CEASE. ORDER A SEIZE
PRACTICE ORDER- OR IT COULD GO
FORWARD FOR A PETITION TO
REVOKE. SEES PRACTICE ORDERS
THAT A TEMPORARY ORDER THAT
DEPENDS ON SOME FOLLOW UP
DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDING- THE
CITY'S PRACTICE ORDER IS IT IS
A TEMPORARY- TO DETERMINE IF
SOMEONE PRACTICE SOMEONE HAS A
LET'S SAY THEY TAKE A- BODILY
FLUID TEST- AND IT COMES PART
COMES BACK POSITIVE- THERE
CERTAIN TERMS THAT ARE
REQUIRED. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT SEES PRACTICE ORDER
LIFTED- BUT AGAIN ALL THE TURNS
ON WHAT THE- NONCOMPLIANCE
ISSUE WAS WITH SOUNDS IKE WITH
THE SEIZE PRACTICE ORDER THAT'S
A TEMPORARY ORDER PENDING.
PENDING THE INITIATION OF A
FURTHER DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDING
AGAINST THE- POSITION INVOLVED
IS THAT CORRECT- I YES I
BELIEVE THAT SERVE AS AN EASY
WAY TO DESCRIBE IT OKAY MAY I
PROVIDE FURTHER INFORMATION
CENTER OFF YES. SO IT HEY SIS
PRACTICE ORDER MAY BE USED IF
THERE'S A AN INITIAL POSITIVE
RESULTS ON A BIOLOGICAL FLUID
TEST BUT THEN THOSE RESULTS-
THE BILL LAB COSTS PROVIDE
LEGAL BE. DEFENSIBLE RESULTS IN
SO IT COULD BE THAT IF IT COMES
BACK- NEGATIVE AFTER FURTHER
TESTING THE **** PRACTICE ORDER
IS LIFTED BUT IT'S INITIALLY
IMPOSED RIGHT AWAY WHEN A
POSITIVE TEST IS RETURNED. FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SITUATION OTHER
POSITION MISCONDUCT WERE
PROBATION ITH OR WITHOUT
CONDITIONS IS IMPOSED WITHOUT A
SUSPENDED REVOCATION OR
SUSPENDED- SUSPENSION. STATUS
PENSION. A TURKISH ADAM THE WAY
IT'S THE REV STAYED WITH A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME FOR
PROBATION THAT ALWAYS THE CASE.
THAT'S AS FAR AS I'M AWARE THAT
IS ALWAYS HOW IT'S WORDED OKAY
AND SO ANOTHER. WAY CASEY'S
PRACTICE ORDER MAY BE ISSUED AS
IF THE PERSON- IS REQUIRED TO
HAVE A PRACTICE MONITOR AND
THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN ONE IN
TIME. THEN THIS IS PART THIS
ORDER WILL BE PUT IN PLACE
UNTIL THEY SECURING APPROPRIATE
PRACTICE MONITOR IF THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO GO FOR A CLINICAL
EVALUATION OR OBTAIN A
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATION. AND
THEY DON'T DO IT WITHIN THE
PRESCRIBED PERIOD OF TIME THE
PORT WILL POSE A SEIZE PRACTICE
ORDER UNTIL. THEY ARE IN
COMPLIANCE. WHEN ONCE AGAIN.
ONCE HAVE A MONITOR IN THAT
CASE THAT YOU'VE JUST
REFERENCED IF THE INDIVIDUAL
ENGAGES IN A VIOLATION OF THE
PROBATION- DID YOU TO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR IN
EVERY CASE WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
IS PLACED ON PROBATION THERE IS
A STATE REVOCATION THAT IS TIED
TO THE PROBATION. YES SIR. OKAY
WITH RESPECT TO THE PUBLIC
REPRIMAND YOUR MANUAL TALKS
ABOUT IT BEING ISSUED FOR MINOR
MINOR VIOLATIONS OR- BUT SIMPLE
DEPARTURES IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE USE OF THE
PUBLIC REPRIMAND. YEAH. I CAN
ASSIST WITH THAT ALSO- IT
SHOULD BE USED FOR MINOR
VIOLATIONS THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES DO YOU OF ALLOW FOR
USE OF A PUBLIC LETTER OF
REPRIMAND EIGHT CASES OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE INVOLVING ONE
PATIENT. WITH WITH TWO SIMPLE
DEPARTURES RIGHT. IT COULD BE A
SITUATION WHERE IT'S AN ACT OF
GROSS NEGLIGENCE WITH ONE
PATIENT SO IT'S AN EVENT THAT.
DOESN'T DEMONSTRATE THAT
THERE'S A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
DEMONSTRATING THAT THIS PERSON
IS BENEFIT FOR PRACTICING NEEDS
CONTINUOUS MONITORING AND IN
THE DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES IN
FACT WITH RESPECT
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY NOTE THAT I.
SAW WHERE PUBLIC REPRIMAND IS
AUTHORIZED IN APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH ONE PATIENT
CORRECT. I DON'T SEE IT FOR
DISHONESTY I DON'T SEE IT.
PROCURING LICENSE FOR FRAUD
EXCESSIVE USE OF ALCOHOL.
EXCESSIVE PRESCRIBING IT'S JUST
ON RATED CATEGORY GENERAL
UNPROFESSIONAL CONDUCT GROSS
NEGLIGENT REPEATED NEGLIGENT
ACTS INCOMPETENCE AND FAILURE
TO MAINTAIN RECORDS CORRECT
WELL. THAT THAT IS TRUE WITH
REGARD THE RANGES WHERE YOU
ASSUME THAT ALL OF THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE PRUDENT NOW
YOU'RE GETTING INTO THE AREA
OF. DISCRETION AND WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR PUBLIC PROTECTION
AND REHABILITATION WHEN IT'S
NOT INCONSISTENT WITH PROVIDING
PUBLIC PROTECTION. WELL WE JUST
CAN'T LET ME JUST MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND IN THE CASE OF
STIPULATED SETTLEMENTS. THOSE
ARE CASES WERE AGREED TO WHERE
THE PHYSICIAN ADMITS TO THE
ALLEGATION OF THE ACCUSATION
AND AGREES TO THE PENALTY IN
THE STIPULATED SETTLEMENT
CORRECT. THAT IS SAID NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE AND USUALLY
WHAT THEY'RE ADMITTING TO IS
THAT IF THE MATTER WERE TO GO
TO HEARING THE BOARD MAY BE
ABLE TO PROVE THE ALLEGATONS-
BY THE CLEAR CONVINCING
EVIDENCE MAY BE ABLE TO. NOT
THAT THERE A GREEN THAT WOULD
HAPPEN THEY'RE NOT AGREEING
THAT THEY- COMMITTED THE
VIOLATIONS. AND THERE'S STILL A
LOT. UP IN THE AIR AND
SOMETIMES WHAT'S AT ISSUE IS
THAT- THERE'S A CONCERN THAT
THE BOARD MADE ONLY BE ABLE TO
PROVE ONE SIMPLE NEGLIGENT
ACTS. AND IF THE CASE WERE TO
GO TO HEARING AND THAT WAS THE
FINDING THEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE WOULD PROPOSE A
DISMISSAL AND THERE WOULDN'T BE
GROUNDS TO OVERTURN THAT
DISMISSAL. SO THE BOARD. IS
WEIGHING. IN MANY CASES. WEBER
EIGHTY SIX SETTLEMENT IS.
SUPPORTIVE OF PUBLIC PROTECTION
BECAUSE THE RISK OF GOING TO
HEARING MAYBE A DISMISSAL IN
WHICH CASE THERE WOULD BE NO
REPORT TO THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHYSICIAN'S PROFILE OR RISK
THAT THE DISCIPLINE COULD BE
LESS THAN WHAT WAS ULTIMATELY
NEGOTIATED. WELL THAT I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF
SOME OF US IN IN THAT THE- THE
FOCUS TENDS TO BE TO. DISPOSE
OF THE MATTER WITH THE LEAST
RISK TO. SOMEONE THE BOARD. THE
RISK OF LOSS IN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING. OR THE OTHER REASON
SHE CHU THE DEAD OF FIDE AND IN
SOME CASES PERHAPS- GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS THREE
THREE HUNDRED AND SOMETHING
THAT- PURSUIT THE MOVE FORWARD
A FORMAL DISCIPLINE AND THE
NUMBER OF THE LIMITED NUMBER OF
CASES THAT ARE ACTUALLY TAKEN
TO TRIAL THAT PERHAPS THAT
NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED LET ME
ASK A QUESTION IN THOSE CASES
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT CASES IN
THIS LAST FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY AND I THINK
SOMEONE INDICATED ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE CASES.
INVOLVE PUBLIC REPRIMAND AS A
PENALTY DO YOU KNOW. I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE
INFORMATION AT THE MOMENT
SENATOR.
SO THE STATS. LAST
YEAR THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT YOUR OUTLOOK OR PREVENT
OKAY. THERE WERE A FEW SAY THEY
WERE A HUNDRED AND EIGHT. YES
SIR AND THAT'S WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CASES.
WILL ALL CONTINUE YOU KNOW-
WHAT OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE
AND CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE ADDRESSED US IN LETTERS TO
THESE COMMITTEES IS THAT THE
BOARD DOESN'T FOLLOW ITS OWN
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES AND- I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT EACH
CASE HAS FACTS OF ITS OWN AND
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF ISSUES
THAT THE BOARD IN THE PANELS
HAVE TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
IN DETERMINING DETERMINING THE
PENALTY TO BE IMPOSED INCLUDING
EVIDENTIARY ISSUE SHOULD THE
MATTER PROCEED FORWARD TO.
TRIAL OR HEARING IN A VARIETY
OF OTHER FACTORS SIMPLY IT'S
COMPLEX I WAS ABLE TO REVIEWS
SORT OF AN INFORMAL SUMMARY- OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED CASES OF- THE
BOARDS WHERE I UNDERSTAND THE
STIPULATED SETTLEMENT WAS
ARRIVED AT- IN THE CASES THAT
WERE RESOLVED IN THIS FASHION
BETWEEN JANUARY ONE AND-
DECEMBER THIRTY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD
AND BY MY COUNT. PUBLIC
REPRIMAND FOR MINOR VIOLATIONS
WAS IMPOSED IN ABOUT. 40% OF
THOSE CASES DOES THAT. I KNOW
YOU I DON'T WANT TO FORCE YOU
TO DO MATH IN PUBLIC BECAUSE I
CAN'T. BUT IS THAT FIGURES
SOUND ABOUT RIGHT. ONE BASED ON
THE NUMBERS I'M LOOKING OUT FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY I WOULD SAY
WOULD BE CLOSER 225% OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD. OKAY HELLO I
WANT TO WALK THROUGH A FEW OF
THE CASES THAT- AT LEAST BASED
ON THE INFORMATION THAT I HAVE
WHICH I ADMIT IS NOT YOUR
INFORMATION SO WE'LL HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT AT THE END OF THIS
HOW WE GET MORE OF YOUR
INFORMATION UNLESS OF THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE BUT
BEFORE I PROCEED I WANT TO SAY
THIS I AS I'VE SAID BEFORE I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS IS COMPLEX
AND IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL. OF SITUATION I DO
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK THAT
THE MEDICAL BOARD AND THE BOARD
MEMBERS- DO EVERY DAY TO
ATTEMPT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA OF
REGULATION AND LICENSURE AND
FRANKLY THE- IT'S SIMPLY
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THAT THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDING
PHYSICIANS- PUT FORTH AND
PERFORM AROUND THE STATE EVERY
DAY PARTICULARLY AND IN THIS
PANDEMIC BUT LET ME TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A FEW CASES AND THEN
I'LL- WRAP THIS THING UP. CASE
NUMBER ONE FOR EXAMPLE
PHYSICIAN ADMITS TO USING THE
IDENTITY OF TRANSIENT PATIENTS
TO SECURE DRUGS AND SELF
PRESCRIBED. RESULTING IN A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION. NOW
ASSUMING THOSE OF THE FAX. YOU
HAVE THE RECORDS LOOKING AT THE
GUIDELINES IN CATEGORIES OF
VARIOUS OFFENSES I ASSUME THIS
COULD BE DISHONESTY ARISING
FROM PATIENT CARE. COULD BE A
CONVICTION OF A CRIME COULD BE
A VIOLATION OF DRUG STATUTES OR
FRANKLY GENERAL UNPROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT ANY OF WHICH IS I READ
THE GUIDELINES CARRY A MINIMUM
PENALTY. IN THE CASE OF
DISHONESTY AND CONVICTION OF A
CRIME- STATE REVOCATION A ONE
YEAR SUSPENSION AND AT LEAST
SEVEN YEARS PROBATION AND IN
THE CASE OF SOME OF THESE OTHER
OFFENSES THAT I'VE LISTED A
STATE REVOCATION AND A
PROBATION PERIOD OF. FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS- THE RECORDS I
RECEIVE REFLECT ONLY A SEVEN
YEAR PROBATION WAS IMPOSED. NOW
I BELIEVE I UNDERSTOOD PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY TO INDICATE THAT IN
ADDITION TO THAT SEVEN YEAR
PROBATION THERE WAS A STATE
REVOCATION. SARAH THAT IS THE
TYPICAL. WAY THAT. ORDERS FOR
PROBATION ARE WORDED STATE
REVOCATION WITH A PERIOD OF
PROBATION FOLLOWING IS THE EVER
DEVIATED FROM IN THE CASE OF
PROBATION AND STATE REVOCATION
SPECIFICALLY. I'VE ASKED BEFORE
LET ME JUST MAKE SURE I WANT TO
ASK AGAIN OR OTHER CASES WHERE
PROBATION IS IMPOSED AS A
PENALTY WITHOUT. ANY STATE
REVOCATION OR SUSPENSION. I
CANNOT THINK OF AN EXAMPLE
WHERE THAT WORDING WAS NOT USED
BUT I CAN'T SAY IT BUT IT'S
NEVER HAPPENED. THERE'S ANOTHER
CASE PHYSICIAN CONVICTED OF THE
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA. FAILED
TO REPORT THAT CONVICTION IS
REQUIRED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD.
NOW I LOOK AT THE GUIDELINES
AND THAT SEEMS TO SPECIFY A
FIVE TO SEVEN YEAR PROBATIONARY
PERIOD IN SOME CASES STATE
REVOCATION. BUT THE RECORDS I
REVIEWED REFLECT THAT THE
POSITION POSITION RECEIVED A
PUBLIC REPRIMAND. NOW I REALIZE
YOU HAVE YOUR RECORDS AND I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE MATERIAL
THAT I RECEIVED BUT GIVEN THE
FACT SITUATION THAT I PRESENTED
WHICH YOU CONSIDER THAT TO BE A
MINOR OFFENSE OR A- SIMPLE
DEPARTURE. ANYONE. SERAPHIM AT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO RESPOND TO
THESE SCENARIOS JUST BASED ON
THAT INFORMATION- THE BOARD.
WOULD NOT CONSIDER THAT TO BE A
MINOR OFFENSE THE ISSUE IS WHAT
IS THE EVIDENCE SURROUNDING IT
THAT THE BOARD HAD ACCESS TO
WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION- AND REHABILITATION
OF THE LAST C. M. WHETHER THIS
IS A SITUATION WHERE CONTINUOUS
MONITORING IS REQUIRED. THE
BOARD DOESN'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO
PUNISH PHYSICIANS AND- IF THE
BOARD GOES BEYOND WHAT IS
NECESSARY FOR PUBLIC PROTECTION
THEN THE BOARD ANTICIPATES THE
PHYSICIAN WOULD SEEK JUDICIAL
REVIEW. AND THAT THE MATTER
WOULD COME BACK TO THE BOARD TO
REVIEW THE PENALTY AGAIN- AND
SO. THAT'S KIND OF SURROUNDING
INFORMATION BUT I AM NOT
COMFORTABLE SPEAKING TO- A
PARTICULAR CASE BASED ON A LINE
OF INFORMATION. WHERE THAT
OTHER ONE PHYSICIAN CONVICTED.
AND SUBSEQUENTLY ALLIED TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD ABOUT THE
CONVICTION. PENALTY IMPOSED
PUBLIC REPRIMAND. YEAH I
REALIZE YOU CAN'T COMMENT ON
SOME OF THESE AND I MAY NOT
HAVE THE FACTS EXACTLY RIGHT
BUT I GUESS THE POINT IS
THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT THE USE
OF THE VERY LEAST PENALTY IN
SOME OF THESE CASES WHICH WERE
THE WERE THE OFFENSES BUT SEEM
TO GO TO THE VERY NATURE OF THE
PHYSICIAN'S OBLIGATION
INTEGRITY HONESTY. RIGHT AMONG
OTHER THINGS HERE'S HERE'S
ANOTHER ELECTED. OKAY I
RESPONSIBILITY OF SENATOR.
BECAUSE I THINK THIS BRINGS UP
A GOOD POINT- ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT WHERE- THE LEGISLATURE.
NOW SPELLS THE BOARD THAT THE
BOARD CAN'T DENY A LICENSE OF A
PHYSICIAN- IS NOT FORTHCOMING
ON INFORMATION THAT- WOULDN'T
BY ITSELF BE GROUNDS FOR
DENIAL- THE BOARD NO LONGER.
ASKS FOR DISCLOSURE OF
CONVICTIONS- FOLLOWING THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION- THE
LEGISLATURE EXPECTS THE BOARD
TO CONSIDER EVIDENCE OF
REHABILITATION. AND UNDER
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT- IF THE
PHYSICIAN HAS SUCCESSFULLY BEEN
ABLE TO YOU KNOW HAVE A
CONVICTION EXPUNGED. THE BOARD
IS NOT TO USE THAT AS GROUNDS
FOR DENIAL WELL DID SO DURING
DURING THE FACT THAT TE
DISCIPLINE AND THE PENALTIES
THAT YOU HAVE DESIGNED AND
BUILT INTO YOUR GUIDELINES IN
YOUR MANAGE MANUAL OR A SLIDING
SCALE AND YOU HAVE THERE'S A
LONG WAY. THERE'S A LONG ROAD
TO WALK OR DRIVE BEFORE BETWEEN
A PUBLIC REPRIMAND FOR MINOR
OFFENSES AND REVOCATION AT THE
TAIL END SO I'M JUST CONCERNED
THAT. THIS IS A BLACK AND WHITE
ISSUE FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD AND
IT'S EITHER X. OR Y. AND
THERE'S NO ROOM IN BETWEEN.
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE PHYSICIAN
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BACK TO CURRENTLY CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT INJURIES TO THE
VICTIM. THE GUIDELINES WOULD
TYPICALLY CALL FOR A MINIMUM
PENALTY BY THE WAY OF STATE
REVOCATION OF FIVE TO SEVEN
YEAR PROBATION AND- AGAIN THE
INFORMATION THAT I WAS PROVIDED
INDICATES A FIVE YEAR PROBATION
WAS THE PENALTY. NO REFERENCE
TO A STATE REVOCATION BUT IF
YOU FOLLOW WHAT YOU'VE
INDICATED BEFORE PERHAPS THAT
WAS PART OF THE PROCESS. HERE'S
AN OTHERS GO THROUGH THESE
QUICKLY I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
IT BECAUSE- PHYSICIANS PRACTICE
RESULTED IN THE DEATHS OF TWO
PATIENTS WITH THE RECORDS
REFLECTING AN EARLIER DEATH OF%
THE THIRD PATIENT. AND ADMITTED
MULTIPLE EXTREME DEPARTURES. SO
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THERE
WAS SEVEN YEAR PROBATION NO
REFERENCE OF A STATE REVOCATION
OR SUSPENSION AT LEAST IN THE
RECORDS. OF THAT I HAVE ANOTHER
ONE UNDER WRAPS AND ARE YOU
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT A DECISION
FROM THE BOARD OR A SUMMARY
THAT SOMEONE NOT BOARD STAFF
PRESENTED TO YOU WELL I'M
LOOKING AT THE SUMMARY THAT WAS
PREPARED I DON'T HAVE BOARD
DECISIONS AND OF COURSE. THAT'S
OUR PROBLEM AND I'LL GET TO
THAT IN A MINUTE. PHYSICIAN
CONVICTED OF BATTERY UPON HIS
OR HER PARTNER. OKAY CONVICTED-
POSITION RECEIVED A PUBLIC
REPRIMAND. PUBLIC REPRIMAND-
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE PHYSICIAN
CONVICTED OF AN ASSAULT WITH A
DEADLY WEAPON. DR HAD A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR ANIMAL CRUELTY.
PROBATION WAS IMPOSED. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THE GUIDELINES
WOULD TEND TO SUGGEST AS A
MINIMUM PENALTY SOMETHING MORE
SEVERE AND ONE FINAL AND I
THINK AND THEN- CLOSE OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE MORE POSITION
APPARENTLY FAILED TO FILE A
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES
REPORT OF ABUSE IN A KNOWN
ABUSE CASE YOUNG CHILD WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY ABUSED FURTHER.
AND DIED. ONE OR MORE OF YOUR
EXPERTS SOMEONE'S EXPERT
CONCLUDED THAT THERE WAS AN
EXTREME DEPARTURE. AND THE
PENALTY IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
WAS A PUBLIC REPRIMAND. SO YOU
KNOW I'M NOT THIS IS NOT A
FRIEND I GOTCHA SITUATION- I
MAY NOT HAVE ALL THE FACTS
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE THEM. AND
THE MORE THESE THAT HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED THE POINT IS THAT
THERE APPEAR TO BE. A VARIETY
OF CASES WHERE. A LESSER
PENALTIES HAVE BEEN IMPOSED.
WHERE THE GUIDELINES SUGGEST
THAT MORE SERIOUS PENALTIES AT
LEAST BE CONSIDERED IF NOT
OPPOSED AS A METHOD OF.
CORRECTIVE ACTION ORDER OF
REVOCATION AS A METHOD OF
CORRECTIVE ACTION AND
REHABILITATION. SO I GUESS TWO
QUESTIONS HOW DO YOU SUGGEST WE
ADDRESS THESE ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED ISSUES. CERTAINLY
ISSUES PERHAPS OF THE NATURE OF
THE PENALTY IMPOSED BUT
CERTAINLY TRANSPARENCY AND ARE
THERE CHANGES IN THIS PROCESS
THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER HERE
TO MAKE THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS MAKE MORE SENSE TO US.
AND TRANSPARENT. APPS WITH
REPORTS REDACTED AS TO PERSONAL.
A DEFINING INFORMATION SO WE
CAN EVALUATE HOW THE BOARD IS
DISCIPLINING PHYSICIANS THAT
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO- REGULATE
LICENSE AND- AND CONTROL IN THE
SENSE OF PERFORMANCE QUALITY
MISCONDUCT. I THOUGHT. US
SENATOR IF I COULD INTERJECT
THERE THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT
HAS BEEN- CONFOUNDING
JURISDICTIONS IN MANY PLACES I
CAN ASSURE YOU OF THAT. THE
DIFFICULTY THAT WE HAVE HERE IS
THAT THERE IS A NEED. TO HAVE A
SETTLEMENT PROCESS- THE MEDICAL
pOUT OF MONEY- WE ARE NOT IN A
FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE BASIS-
AND WE NEED TO FIND EFFICIENT
WAYS OF DEALING WITH CASES. FOR
REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPLAINED THE SETTLEMENT
PROCESS BY ITS VERY NATURE IS
CONFIDENTIAL FOR REASONS THAT
HAPPEN EXPLAINS. WHAT THEREFORE
WE NEED TO CONSIDER. ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT YOU HAVE
SUGGESTED IS A MORE TRANSPARENT
MANNER. OF SETTING FORTH HOW
THESE SETTLEMENTS ARE BASED
WHAT GOES INTO THEM. I AND
PERHAPS IT MEANS- ISSUING
REVISED GUIDELINES ISSUING MORE
COMPLEX GUIDELINES ISSUING
REPORTS WHERE- CASES ARE
ANONYMIZED BUT TO EXPLAIN
BETTER THE RANGE OF SANCTIONS
AND THE FACTORS THAT GO INTO
THE DIFFICULTY THAT WE FACE. IS
THAT GIVEN THE MOUNTAIN OF
CASES THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
IS THAT THE SETTLEMENTS REMAIN
A VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
IT. BUT I TAKE YOUR POINT THAT
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A MORE
TRANSPARENT WAY OF EXPLAINING
HOW THESE CASES ARE RESOLVED.
WHAT FACTORS GO INTO THEM. AND
THE BENEFITS THAT ARE ACHIEVED
BY DOING IT THIS WAY FOR THOSE
OF US WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THESE CASES. ON A DAILY BASIS
WE KNOW THAT BY RESOLVING THEM
QUICKLY. BY GETTING SOMETIMES
VERY STRICT UNDERTAKINGS I
UNDERSTAND THE CASES THAT YOU
HAVE SELECTED. OUR DONE FOR
UPDATE FIT INTO A CERTAIN
PATTERN. WE COULD SELECT OTHER
CASES WHERE THIS THE
STIPULATIONS HAVE BEEN VERY
SEVERE. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
POINT THEY GO INTO A RANGE
BECAUSE THE CASES REQUIRE. THAT
THEY GOING TO ARRANGE BUT I
CERTAINLY TAKE YOUR POINT THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
TRANSPARENCY. IN THE VERY
COMPLEX FACTORS THAT GO INTO IT
AND I THINK THE MEDICAL BOARD
NEEDS TO MAKE A STRONGER CASE
ON HOW RETAINING THESE TYPES OF
SYSTEMS. ARE IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST BUT FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CURRENT PROCESSES
BY WHICH THE STIPULATED
SETTLEMENTS ARE ARRIVED AT IN
OUR APPROVED. THERE IS BOARD
OVERSIGHT OF IT. NOW MAYBE WE
CAN LOOK AT IMPROVED OVERSIGHT
OR A DIFFERENT FORM OF
OVERSIGHT. BUT THAT DOES EXIST
IT DOES EXIST NOW AND I'VE SEEN
IT WORK- BUT I TAKE YOUR POINT
THAT WE NEED TO THINK OF MORE
TRANSPARENT WAYS OF EXPLAINING
WHAT IS. A VERY COMPLICATED.
VERY LEGALISTIC PROCESS. THANK
YOU AND LISTEN I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- N. N. YOUR
ATTEMPT TO RESPOND TO SOME VERY
VERY DIFFICULT QUESTIONS BY
SOME OF US WHO WERE PROBABLY
BEING VERY DIFFICULT AT THE
TIME WE ASK THEM. BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU CAN ADD TO MY
LIST OF QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO.
SEE AN RESPONSES THE NUMBER OF.
CASES WHERE. CASES OF PROBATION
VIOLATION WHERE LICENSES WERE.
REVOKED IN THE CASE OF A STATE
REVOCATION. OF VERSUS THE
NUMBER WERE LICENSES WERE NOT
REVOKED IN THE CASE OF A
PROBATION VIOLATION. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU ALL IF YOU CAN STAY
ON THERE MAY BE FURTHER
QUESTIONS I THINK WE NEED TO
MOVE TO OUR NEXT PANEL AT THIS
POINT IT'S C. OVERVIEW OF
PATIENT IMPACTS. WE ARE.
FORTUNATE TO HAVE WITH US
BRIDGET GRAHAM ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTOR SUPERVISING ATTORNEY
CENTER FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
AND TJ WHAT CAN SAY A CURRENT
MEDICAL BOARD MEMBER TO PRESENT
THANK YOU- BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND LISTENING TO THE
REST OF US DRONE ON AND FOR
WAITING FOR YOUR TIME 2% SO- IS
IT MS GRAHAM. YES THANK YOU
IT'S GRAMMY ACTUALLY IT'S WITH
WHAT'S KEEPING. RAMIE GRAMMY I
APOLOGIZE I HATE TO ME NO
PROBLEM PEOPLE'S NAME NO
PROBLEM IT HAPPENS US THE GOOD
MORNING. ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEES FOR INVITING ME TO
COMMENT TODAY AND FOR THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME AND
EFFORT THAT YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT
INTO THE VERY IMPRESSIVE
BACKGROUND PAPER PREPARED FOR
YOU- I ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE
JUST LISTENING THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ALL HAVE
REYES THIS MORNING AND- IT
REALLY SHOWS THAT YOU'RE TAKING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT
ROLE SERIOUSLY. AND I HOPE THAT
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS WILL BE
USEFUL TEAM THROUGHOUT THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS IT IS IF
YOU WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR WITH CPA
L. WE ARE A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN ACADEMIC AND
ADVOCACY AND ORGANIZATION.
BASED AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SYDNEY. FOR OVER YEARS CTL HAS
STUDIED OCCUPATIONAL LACE. AND
MONITOR CAL AGENTS THAT
REGULATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
AND TRADES INCLUDING THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND OTHER DCA
HEALTHCARE BOARDS. IN TWO
THOUSAN THREE MY PREDECESSOR
JULIE DEANGELIS DIAMOND WAS
APPOINTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
SERVE AS THE BOARD'S
ENFORCEMENT MONITOR. AFTER
CONTINUED REPORTS OF PROBLEMS
WITH THE BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. AFTER TWO YEARS OF
STUDY SHE MADE SIXTY FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS MANY OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED IN THE SERIES
OF REFORM LEGISLATION. DETAIL
CONTINUES TO MONITOR
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR REGULATORY
AGENCIES AND PUBLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA REGULATORY LAW
REPORTER WHICH TRACKS AGENCY
ACTIVITY. THE TITLE OF THIS
HEARING POSES AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION. DOES THE MEDICAL
BOARD PROTECT THE PUBLIC WORKS
POSITIONS. IT IS NOT A QUESTION
THAT CAN BE ANSWERED WITH A
SIMPLE YES OR NOW. AND SO
DURING THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS I URGE YOU TO ASK
YOURSELF A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
QUESTION. WHICH IS DOES THE
PUBLIC BELIEVE THAT THE BOARD
IS PRIORITIZING PUBLIC
PROTECTION OVER PROTECTION OF
PHYSICIANS. AND AS I EXPECT YOU
WILL HEAR DURING TODAY'S PUBLIC
COMMENTS N. AS IN THIS LASSEN
ALLUDED TO AND HER COMMENTS
EARLIER THIS MORNING. THE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION RIGHT NOW
IS NOW. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS MORNING'S DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE BOARD'S ABILITY TO BE PRO
ACTIVE IN ITS REGULATION TO BE
FAIR THE BOARD IS NOT SET UP
RIGHT NOW TO BE A PROACTIVE
REGULATOR. THE CURRENT JUST
DISCIPLINE SYSTEM IS IN FACT A
COMPLAINT DRIVEN SYSTEM. AND AS
WE RAISED IN OUR LETTER THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
CHANGING DURING THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS. WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO WAIT FOR PATIENTS TO BE
HARMED BEFORE. THE BOARD CAN
START TAKING ACTION. FROM A
PURELY OF STAN THE PROCESS TIME
FROM COME TO READ. RIGHT NOW
ARE SIMPLY A- LET'S NOT FOR
THAT INFO OF THE TWO. AND CASES
THAT DISCUSS THE SMART FROM LOS.
AND FROM SENATOR HER TO AND
MEMBER FUNDS TO. THOSE ARE CRAP
THAT RIGHT NOW. AS THEY MOVE
THROUGH THE JUST PROCESS. AS
ATTORNEYS WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT EXCUSE
PHYSICIANS ARE ENTITLED DUE
PROCESS AND ANY PRECEDING THAT
MAY IMPACT THEIR CONTINUED
ABILITY TO PRACTICE MEDICINE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT RIGHT AND
PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
SYSTEM. BUT IN OUR OBSERVATION
AS WE HAVE POINTED OUT IN OUR
LETTER. THIS RATE CAN BE ABUSED
BY PHYSICIANS AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS WHO USE AN ARRAY OF
STALL TACTICS TO DRAG OUT THE
PROCESS AS LONG AS POSSIBLE
OFTEN FOR YEARS AT GREAT RISK
TO THE PUBLIC. AN APPROPRIATE
BALANCE. MUST BE IMPLEMENTED.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PUBLIC.
ISSUE THE BOY SURVEY RESULTS
INDICATE THAT THE PUB
EXPERIENCE THAT THE COMPLAINT.
DOESN'T BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
MAJORITY OF FIRST. LABELING
THEIR- AS OR VERY. WE'VE HER
STORIES OF PATIENT. WHOSE CASES
WERE CLOSED WITHOUT EVER BEING
INTERVIEWED BY ANYONE ON THE
BOARD. CLICK AND AS A TURN WE-
THAT THE BOARD CAN ONLY PROCEED
ON A COMPLAINT IF IT HAD THE
STATUTORY BASIS TO DO SO. BUT
THE PROCEDURES AS THEY EXIST
ARE DEVALUING OFTEN TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES THAT THESE
COMPLAINANTS HAVE INDOOR. AND
TO CONTINUE AND THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO BREAK DOWN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
AND THE BOARD. I THINK SEVERAL
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
TODAY THE BOARD REALLY REFLECT
THAT. A BRING BEAR OUR FORTY
YEARS OF AGE. IN MY- CALIFORNIA
REGULATORY BOARDS AND I. OF THE
YEARS TO HOLD THESE SPORTS. TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC NOT THE PER.
I WILL FOCUS MY COMMENTS TODAY
ON A FOUR RECOMMEND. THAT
ENHANCE THE BOARD'S ABILITY TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC PROTECTION
REMAINS AS PARAMOUNT PRIORITY.
AND IT'S HARD TO TELL MORE
FULLY DETAILED IN OUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THAT WE SUBMITTED.
UNDER NUMBER ONE IS THE BOARD'S
FEES MUST BE A- I REALLY THIS
<c.red>S NOT THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S</c>
HEARING BUT IT IS VERY RELEVANT
TO THE BOARD'S ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN A ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM. THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN INCREASED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND THE BOARD HAS
MORE THAN JUSTIFIED ITS NEED TO
INCREASE ITS FEES. THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR THE BOARD TO
ACCOMPLISH THE MISSION OF
PUBLIC PROTECTION. AND THE FACT
THAT THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WAS
JUST TELLING YOU THAT THEY'RE
NOT IN A FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE POSITION AND
APPEARED TO BE MOTIVATED TO
SETTLE CASES IN ORDER TO SAVE
MONEY. IS EXTREMELY CONCERNING.
THE SECOND RECOMMEND. WE HAVE
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
HAD TO PUT. MEMBERS TO THE
BOARD. CHAU HAS BEEN. FOR A CUP
MEMBER. OF THE BOARD FOR. AND
OF. SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
TWENTY ATKINS RAISE THE
SUGGESTION IF YOU WEEK AGO AT
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
HEARING. AFTER A NUMBER OF
PATIENTS ADVOCATES RACE SERIES
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BOARD'S
ABILITY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
WE COMPLETELY AGREE WITH STOCKS
OBSERVATION THAT ESTABLISHING A
PUBLIC MAJORITY ON THE BOARD.
WOULD DECREASE THE RISK OF
ANTITRUST EXPOSURE AND HAVE
VALUE ADDED OF THE MORE
PATIENTS. FOR AS I EXPLAIN IN
WORDS. AND LETTER IT IS NOW
THEN SIX YEAR SINCE THE U. S.
COURT ISSUED ITS TO TEN. AND
NORTH CAROLINA STATE BOARD OF
DENTAL. VERSUS THE TRADE THAT
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION. THAT
LANDMARK CASE HELD THAT BOARDS
THAT ARE CONTROLLED BY ACTIVE
MARKET PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PROFESSION REGULATED. SUCH AS
THE MEDICAL BOARD WHICH IS
CONTROLLED Y DOCTORS. ARE NOT
AUTOMATICALLY GRANTED IMMUNITY
FROM THE ANTI TRUST LAWS. JUST
BECAUSE THEY ARE A STATE
AGENCY. AND REGULATORY BOARDS
MAKE DECISIONS DECISIONS EVERY
DAY SUCH AS HUMANE INTO THE
PROFESSION. THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ARE
UNQUESTIONABLY ANTI
COMPETITIVE. THE SUPREME COURT
LAID OUT A SERIES OF CHECKS
THAT MUST BE PRESENT TO SHOW
THAT A BOARD IS SUFFICIENTLY
AND ACTIVELY SUPERVISED BY THE
STATE. IN ORDER TO ENJOY A
STATE ACTION IMMUNITY FROM THE
ANTI TRUST LAWS. AND THOSE
CHECKS ARE NOT PRESENT RIGHT
NOW HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IN FACT
CHAU SPONSORED A BILL THAT
WOULD AUTHORIZE DCA TO EXERCISE
ADDITIONAL SUPERVISION. OVER AT
CEMEX SEMI AUTONOMOUS BOARDS
BUT THAT LEGISLATION WAS
UNSUCCESSFUL AFTER HEAVY
OPPOSITION FROM TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS. TO INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PUBLIC MEMBERS ON THE
BOARD WOULD CERTAINLY HELP TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC REMAINS
A KEY FOCUS. OF THE BOARD'S
ACTIVITY AND WITH LESSEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PROFESSION
CONTROL THE BOARD. AND I WOULD
ADD AS A ADDED IN THE LETTER
THERE ARE THREE PUBLIC- AND
PUBLIC MEMBER VACANCIES RIGHT
NOW WHICH ARE JUST EXACERBATING.
THIS PROBLEM. A THIRD. WE
RECOMMEND THAT LEDGERS
LEGISLATURE SET UP. ANOTHER AND-
MONITOR AND A ON ALL THE- TODAY
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE BOARD
EXIST ENFORCE SYSTEM AS I'M- OF
GREAT CONCERN. IT IS UNDER
RESEARCH. IT APPEARS THERE'S
BEEN A BREAKDOWN IN THE REAL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S. OF THE
TRANSFER OF THE- TO DO. AND
TWENTY THIRD CREATE FURTHER.
AND THE PUBLIC. IN THE IS A-
LOW. WHAT IS LESS CLEAR IS WHAT
TO DO ABOUT IT THE BOARD
ABILITY QUICKLY INEFFICIENT I
TELL. IN OUR HARM DR FROM PACK
AS- AS YOU WILL DURING PUBLIC.
A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH.
RESULTING THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUS SITUATION THROUGH THE
POLITICAL PROCESS. WHERE THE
PARTIES WHOSE INTERESTS ARE AT
STAKE OUR LESSEN OBJECTIVES AND
HAD AN EQUAL LEVELS OF INPUT.
WITH THIS MAKERS IS NOT THE WAY
TO DO THIS. SERIOUS REFORM OF
THE DISCIPLINE SYSTEM MUST BE
BASED ON EVIDENCE GATHERED AND
ANALYZED BY AN INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHER. SUCH AN OBJECTIVE
STUDY BENEFITS EVERYONE FOR
PHYSICIANS AND PATIENTS IT
MAKES SENSE TO HAVE A VIGOROUS
TRUSTED REGULATORY PROGRAM IN
PLACE. THAT PREVENTS AS MANY
PATIENTS AS POSSIBLE FROM BEING
DAMAGED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AMONG OTHER ISSUES THE
ENFORCEMENT MONITOR CAN CONDUCT
A THOROUGH. THOROUGH AND
INDEPENDENT STUDY OF THE
INSTANCES IN WHICH THE BOARD
DEVIATES FROM THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES FOR EXAMPLE. THEY
COULD TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THE
EFFICACY OF THE PROBATION
MONITORING PROGRAM. ASSESS
WHETHER THE PUBLIC PROTECTION
IS AT RISK THROUGH THESE ISSUES
AND RECOMMEND AMENDMENTS TO THE
GUIDELINES AND PROCEDURES
INVOLVING SETTLEMENTS. THE
MONITOR COULD ALSO RESEARCH AND
RECOMMEND PROACTIVE REGULATORY
APPROACHES AS WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER. IN THE DAY IN ADDITION
TO THIS EXISTING CLAIM-
COMPLAINT BASED MODEL. THAT
WOULD PERMIT THE BOARD TO
IDENTIFY AND DISCIPLINE
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL PHYSICIANS
BEFORE PATIENTS ARE HARMED.
RATHER THAN WAIT FOR THEM TO BE
HARMED AND THEN FILE A
COMPLAINT. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS IS AN APPROACH
THAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT
MULTIPLE BOARDS INCLUDING THE
STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA. AND
BASED. ON THE QUESTIONS OF THE
MEMBERS THIS MORE IT APPEARS
THAT THE SYSTEM THAT LED TO. MY
BE AND IN X. AND WELL.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU
DECIDE TO APPOINT AN SOMEONE
THIS CREEK ISSUE MUST BE
CONSIDERED DURING THIS REGION
AS THE- HERE SO HELP PLAN OUT
AND GOING TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW I
KNOW WE ARE RUNNING ANTI. BUT
ONE THING THAT HASN'T BEEN
BROUGHT UP VERY MUCH TODAY IS-
THE- PROCESS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO REITERATE CPA I WAS WRECKED.
THE BOY AND THAT SHOULD MOVE TO
ATTORNEY OFFICE A A- MEANT
RECOMMENDED BY THE AND FOR
MONITOR. SO THAT ALL THE TEAM
PROSECUTORS INVEST CAN WORK TO
AS EXTRA AS POSSIBLE TO MEET
CAN PROTECTION THERE FOR AND-
THIS RECOMMENDED WAS NOT AND
FROM AS REC. AND WAS ONLY MADE
MARK. BY THE TRANSFER OF THE
INVESTIGATORS DCA THE BOARD'S
DATA MAKES CLEAR THAT IT WAS
THE TRANSFERRED TO DCA AND NOT
VERTICAL ENFORCEMENT THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE THE UNACCEPTABLY
HIGH. INVESTIGATION TIME. AT A
MINIMUM THE LEGISLATURE SICKENS
REFERRED. MESSIER'S ARMS BY THE
BOARD AND THE GENERAL ASSIGNED
A DEPUTY AND JUST OFFICE WORK
IN EACH BE SEEN FIELD OFFICE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE AND TO. WE
DO NOT THE SIM IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT THE CAN
COME THE POOR TO INVEST AN
PROSECUTE IT'S ON ARE THIS TIME.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THIS WOULD
EXACERBATE THE PUBLIC TRUST
ISSUE AND SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED AND HEALTH RESEARCH
COULD BE CONDUCTED THAT WOULD
SUPPORT SUCH A DEPARTURE. FROM
THE TREE GENERAL PROSECUTION. I
ALSO WANT A HIGH CREEK THE
MANTA A- WORK. AND NUMBER
FIFTEEN. IT'S VERY CONCERNING
THAT THE BOARD SUSPECT THAT'S
NOT RECEIVING MANY OF THESE
MANDATORY REPORTS. AND THESE
ARE CRITICAL TOOLS THAT WILL
LEAD TO IDENTIFICATION OF
DISCIPLINE OF HARMFUL
POSITIONS- AND A SENATOR AS
SENATOR ROSS MENTIONED AS WELL.
IN THE FACT THAT THE ACT THAT
ONE PARTICULAR CASE IN SANTA
CLARA AND WHICH- THIS IS
ESTAMOS PERMIT TO PACKED FOR
MANY YEARS. MANY COMPLAINTS AND
FINDINGS FROM OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND IT RAISES
QUESTIONS AS TO THIS THIS
MANDATORY REPORTING REQUIREMENT
AND WHETHER WE NEED TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL MANDATED REPORTS FOR
A STATE AGENCIES- I DO WANNA
HIGHLIGHT TO THAT WE POINTED
OUT IN OUR LETTER THERE IS. A
REPORT MANDATED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR SETTLEMENTS UP
TO TWENTY NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED. AND FOR SOME OF THE
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WE HAVE
THEN AWARE OF WHAT WE ARE
SUSPECTING MIGHT BE A WIDE.
SPREAD PRACTICE IN WHICH PEOPLE
ARE SETTLING CASES FOR THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO PAY
290-009-0090 NINE DOLLARS AND
THEN STATE. OUT OF POCKET THE
DIFFERENCE TO THE PLAINTIFFS
AND THIS IS A WAY THAT THEY ARE
AVOIDING HAVING TO REPORT THE
SETTLEMENTS ESPECIALLY
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVING TO
REPORT SETTLEMENTS- AND I
BELIEVE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT. THING THAT NEEDS TO
BE INVESTIGATED FURTHER AND
PERHAPS WE SHOULD JUST
ELIMINATE THE THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD AND ALL
SETTLEMENTS SHOULD BE REPORTED
TO THE BOARD. I'M AND THEN IT
NUMBER TWO ON. JUST YOU KNOW.
PRETTY WITH RESPECT TO THE
PHYSICIAN THAT IS. ADAM IN
SENATOR HER TARDIS DISTRICT
THAT PERSON WAS PLACED ON HER.
FOR CHRISTMAS. IT WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT THE EXISTING
PATIENTS RIGHT TO KNOW ACT AND
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR PHYSICIANS
TO DISCLOSE TO THEIR PATIENTS
THEY'RE ON PROBATION. WOULD NOT
APPLY TO THAT DOCTOR. BECAUSE
CURRENTLY CHRIS NEGLIGENCE NOT
ONE OF THE STATUTORY.
REQUIREMENTS FOR DISCLOSURE
THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK IT
EXPOSES A REAL GAPING HOLE. IN
THE SAND AND I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE EXPANDING THE
PATIENTS RIGHT TO KNOW ACT AND
IN IN IN HAND SINK A TRANSFER.
MY FINAL RECOMMENDATION HAS TO
DO WITH AN INDEPENDENT ON THE
OFFICE. AND THIS IDEA IS COMING
FROM LOOKING AT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS INCLUDING THE U.
K. AND WENT TO AN INDEPENDENT
OFFICE TO BE ESTABLISHED TO
HELP COMPLAINTS NAVIGATE SYSTEM-
TO DISTILL. THAT TO HELP
EXPLAIN WHAT GOING ON THE
PROCESS. AND ALSO TO IDENTIFY
POSSIBLE TRENDS THAT MAY BE
CURRENTLY NOT A VIOLATION OF
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE THAT PERHAPS SHOULD BE AND
AT A MINIMUM COULD HELP ASSIST
THE BOARD. WITH PROACTIVE
REGULATION. REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- TO SPEAK TO TODAY AND HOW.
HAPPY THE IN ANY. AND K. L. AS
A BILL TO US THE CAN IN ITS AS
THEY WORK THROUGH THE AND EVERY
PROCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS GRAMMY WE PRE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR REC.
YOU'LL BE US FOR FEW MINUTES
ANYWAY- I ASSUME. LET'S MOVE ON-
BOARD MEMBER CAN IF YOU'RE ON
THE ON THE SCREEN OR ON THE
LINE. MISTER WATKINS. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON- ON ROLE ON BOTH
CHAIR OFFICE AND- ON A BILL.
EVAN LOW. AND TO THE COMMITTEE
AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL FULL TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK. IN THIS
HEARING- FIRST I NEED TO I NEED
TO TANK SOMEONE ON THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE LAST WEEK
AROUND THIS TIME. I WAS PULLING
MY HAIR OUT IN FRUSTRATION. AND
THAT HAS HAPPENED A LOT IN MY
TIME ON THE BOARD. AND EVAN LOW
WAS ASSEMBLY MAN EVAN LOW WAS
TALKING TO THE- EXACTLY OFFICE
ALL TO BE ALREADY IN. ANY
POINTERS OUT THAT PUBLIC MAY
CAN SPEAK IN THIS. AND DID THE
DAY BEFORE WAS JUST SO. BIG
THEY EACH THAT I HAVE. AND IS
BOARD. HAS GONE HER. AND WHEN I
SAY ON HOW I'M- THAT PEOPLE ARE
NICE. AND THEY WILL SMILE AT
YOU BUT THEY WILL DO NOT CREATE.
AND THAT IS BEEN TROUBLING AND
ALLOW FAITH. THAT IN THIS FOR
THIS BOARD FOR. THE EX PROBLEM.
AND TELLING THAT EXIST CAN BE
IN. FOR AND I WILL ARTICULATE
THIS AS I COOK COUNTY. HELLO
THANK YOU. FOR THE THREE AND A
HALF YEARS ENDED UP BEING THE
VICE CHAIR AND ALSO DONE A GOOD
TO THE FEDERAL STATE'S BOARD OF
PHYSICAL THERAPIST. AND DURING
THAT TIME. I'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
TRAINING. AS A IN THE ROLE OF
THE BOARD MEMBER. ONTO A TWO
DECADE OVER I'LL CALL CASES
ALCOHOL USE DISORDERS GROSS
NEGLIGENCE AND ALL OF THESE
THINGS. AND 80% STAYS THE SAME
WHEN YOU COME TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD. AND DIDN'T IS A BAGEL
IDEA ALSO LEGAL STUFF THAT YOU
HAVE TO LEARN. AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WHEN I CAME ACROSS
CASES THAT WAS PROBABLY FROM A
PUBLIC PROTECTION POINT OF
VIEW. AND I RAISE MY HAND. AND
I BROUGHT IT BEFORE SOMEONE
LEGAL THERE WAS DROPPED. AND IT
WAS YOU ARE YOU DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHAT PUBLIC MEMBERS
YOU DO NOT UNDERSTAND- BOARD
COUNCIL SHE WAS ALWAYS NICE TO
HELP YOU UNDERSTAND. AND THAT.
TOLD ME HE GAVE ME THE NEW CASE
AND I NEED. TO ACTUALLY GO IN
AND REALLY LOOK AT THESE CASES.
BECAUSE THE FUNNY THING ABOUT
THESE CASES IS THAT. THEY
REALLY INVOLVE PEOPLE WINNING
BOTH PEOPLE IS A AN IMAGE YOU
ATTACHED TO IT. SO THAT'S MY
BACKDROP WHY DOES THIS BOARD
EVEN EXISTS I'VE HEARD THAT
QUESTION SO MANY TIMES WHY DO
YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE HEAR YOU
ON THE MEDICAL BOOK ONE DATES
AS THEY DO NOTHING ALL THEY YOU
KNOW THEY JUST TAKE LICENSES
I'VE HEARD THAT AS WELL SO
THERE'S DIFFERENT. BETTING
PERCEPTIONS. BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO QUOTE THE BASIS ON WHICH
THIS BOARD IS FOUND AND THAT IS
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
IS TWO THOUSAND AND SUBSECTION
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE POINT ONE
SIX OF THE PRIORITY OF THE
BOARD. PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC.
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC SHALL
BE THE HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN
EXERCISING ITS LICENSING
REGULATORY AND DISCIPLINARY
FUNCTIONS. WHENEVER THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC IS
INCONSISTENT WITH OTHER INTO
SOLD TO BE PROMOTED. THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC SELBY
PARAMOUNT THE PROTECTION OF THE
PUBLIC SHALL BE PARAMOUNT. SO
NOT TODAY AS PART OF MY
CONTINUAL EDUCATION IDEA. THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF POINT TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
STRUGGLE TO NINE. IN WHICH HE
SAYS THAT PUBLIC PROTECTION IS
ONE THING AND THEN DOES HE HAVE
A LOCATION AND THE PRACTICE OF
AND PRACTICE RESTRICTIONS.
BUSINESS CO TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE SAYS IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
COMPETING INTERESTS THIS SHALL
BE PARAMOUNT. BUT DURING THIS
PERIOD I WAS I HAD A WHOLE-
PRESIDENT. A LOT OF NOTES THAT
I WANTED TO PRESENT BUT I DON'T
NEED TO ANYMORE. BECAUSE POINTS
HAVE BEEN MADE AND SO WHAT I
WANT TO EXPLAIN AND CLARIFY.
THAT WOULD BE CAN CARE FOR ME
SO I CAN SLEEP TONIGHT. IS THAT
IS TWO WORLDS THAT WE ARE
SEEING WE'VE SEEN THE WORLD IN
WHICH YOU LEARN AS A BOARD
MEMBER. AND THE BOARD STAFF AND
ALL OF THIS AND BY THE WAY THE
BULLETS THAT DOES INCREDIBLE
WORK. THEY WORK REALLY HARD.
IT'S WE HAS THE BOARD MEMBERS
WHEN WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS
THAT'S FAILED ALL OF THEM
INCLUDING THE PUBLIC. WE
UNDERMINE THE STAFF'S WORK. AND
WE UNDERMINE THE BOARD EXPENSE
BY THE DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE
AND IT'S MOST TROUBLING IS SET
ON A BOARD AND HAVE YOUR
PROFESSIONAL INTEGRITY
CHALLENGED EVERY SINGLE TIME.
EVERY SINGLE TIME. YOU'VE GOT A
STEP OVER WHAT A BIG DEAL
VALUES ALL. THIS BILL IS VALUES
AND THAT IS BEING DEFINED AS
WHAT YOU DO MOST NATURALLY
WITHOUT THINKING. THIS BOARDS
BATTERIES WE PROTECT THE
DOCTORS. AND WE'LL GO- OPEN BAR
IN ORDER TO DO SO. MORE
ACCURATELY BUSINESS PRESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODES DOUBLE TWO
NINE GAVE ME INSIGHT. BECAUSE
IF YOU HAVE A LIMITATION IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AT
THE SEAMANS. THE KEY. TO REDUCE
SENTENCES IT'S THE KEY TO
ANYTHING AND WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
APPLY THE GUIDELINES IT IS TO
SEE THIS PUNISHMENT. BUT WE HAD
A LITTLE. THE ONLY REASON WHY
ANY OF THESE CASES THAT IS SO
PROBABLY COMES BEFORE THIS
BOARD AND ALL DECIDED BY THE
BOARD WE AS THE BOARD MEMBERS
ME INCLUDED. WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THOSE DECISIONS. WE DO NOT
PUSHED BACK. TO THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER ENOUGH WHEN WE COME
ACROSS AS LEGAL ADVICE YEAH
HE'S HOLDING ON IT'S BIASED
IT'S MISLEADING IT IS FILLED
WITH OMISSIONS AND COMMISSIONS.
IT'S LIKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
THEIR DOCTORS. IT'S STRUGGLING
A LOT OF PAIN THE PUBLIC IS
EXPERIENCING. CONTACT IS
CONTAINED IN THOSE DOCUMENTS.
ANY STRUGGLING ON EVERY LEVEL
TO SIT ON THIS BOARD. AND TO
TRY I HAVE A CLOSE THE FORWARD
LOOKING ATTITUDE I GO THROUGH
LIFE AND I AM A PROBLEM SOLVER.
WHAT I DO FOR MY DAY JOB IS
HIRED LOOK FOR PATTERNS AND THE
PATTERNS JUMPED ON ME IN THIS
SPORT. WHY DO I SAY THAT THIS
BOARD CRITICS STOCKS BECAUSE
SOUNDS INFLAMMATORY. BUT I'M
GOING TO I'M GOING TO QUOTE
STATISTICS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN I
DIDN'T SHUT DOWN SO MANY TIMES.
BY THE TIME THE GOOD WAY. THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
DECIDED FOR THE WHOLE OF LAST
YEAR. EVERY CASE EVERY
STIPULATE THE CIRCLING THAT
COMES ACROSS MY DESK. I'M GOING
TO TRACK WITH THAT WE FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES. WHAT EASE THE
PROBATION PERIOD AND WE GONNA.
IMPOSE ON. WHAT ASKING
TROUBLING IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER AND EVERYTHING. AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR EVERYTHING BEING
TROUBLING. I HAD IT'S A IT'S
JUST INTERESTING LET'S CHANGE
THE WEATHER. THE BOARD USES. I
LEGAL BAIL. IN OKAY TO PROTECT
OFFICE AND WE KNOW NOW THAT THE
REHABILITATION IS ON TALK AND
IN PUBLIC INTEREST SOMEONE AS
FOLLOWS AT THE LOWER LEVELS.
AND WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT FROM
THE STATISTICS. AND MAKE ME
BRING YOU SOME OF THE
STATISTICS EVERY CASE ID. ME
PERSONALLY AB THE SEASON ON LAW
CENTER AND ONCE THE OUTCOME OF
THAT THIS SEASON I ASKED HER.
IT'S MY PERSONAL INFORMATION
I'M NOT SHARING THAT
INFORMATION WITH ANYBODY BUT
IT'S INTERESTING ALL CLOSELY
RESEMBLES THE TOPLINE NUMBERS
WITHIN THE SPORT. I DON'T GO TO
THEM QUICKLY. BUT BEFORE I DO
THAT SOMETHING POPPED OUT AT ME
A QUESTION WAS AKED ABOUT. THE
BOARD MEMBER COMPOSITION. AND
NOBODY FROM THE BOARD NO ONE
ANSWERED IT. WE WAS SAYING THEY
WERE SEVEN AUTHORIZED MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD WE WAS SAYING GET
OUT OF THE EAST THERE WAS SIX
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD SO LET ME
JUST HEAR THAT. BECAUSE IT'S A
SMALL THING BUT IT'S A SYMPTOM
OF A BIGGER PROBLEM. AND A
PROBLEM THAT IS CONSISTENT.
IT'S A LITTLE MISSION. RIGHT
LET ME GIVE YOU THE FACTS ABOUT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE I
WHILE THIS WAS HAPPENING I WENT
TO GO LOOK FOR THOSE NUMBERS.
TWENTY THE THING. IT WAS SIX
DOCTOR MEMBERS ON THIS BOARD
WHEN THEY APPEARED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND THEY WERE FULL
PUBLIC MEMBERS A DOCTOR
MAJORITY BOARD. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SO THE FOLLOWING YEAR
OFF THAT THAT MAKES SENSE OF
THE REVIEW THERE WAS A DOCTOR'S
AND SIX MEMBERS. AND NOW THIS
YEAR AT SUNSET REVIEW. THEY ALL
EIGHT MEMBERS TALK TO MEMBERS
AND THEY WERE FULL MEMBERS UP
TO THE LAST BOARD MEETING THEY
JUST APPOINTED ANOTHER ONE. IS
AN INTERESTING IMPLICATION WITH
THAT. BOTH PANELS ASIK UP IN A
WAY THAT IS A MAJORITY OF
DOCTOR MEMBERS. AND SO IF A
DECISION THAT CAME FROM THE
DAG. AND ALEXANDER THE OFFICE.
HOLES OUT OF THAT. GUIDELINES
WELL WE ARE UNHAPPY ASK PUBLIC
MEMBERS WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
THE VOTES WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
THE VOTES TO OVERRIDE THAT AND
WE HAVE IN THE PAST WE HAVE
DONE THAT SUCCESSFULLY FUNDED
SAY IT CANNOT BE DONE. AND I
WILL SPEAK TO THIS POINT A
LITTLE LATER AGAIN. BUT FIRST I
WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU TO. THE
STATISTICS WHAT I FIND. AND I'M
I'M SO CONFIDENT THAT WHEN YOU
EXTRAPOLATE THESE NUMBERS. THAT
YOU WILL GET WITHIN. FIVE OR 7%
OF WHAT I'M GOING TO QUOTE HERE
TODAY. AND SOME OF THESE KIND
OF FIXING FONG. BUT AND I'M I'M
AND I'M SETTING THE STAGE FOR.
BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY DISTURBING.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT. THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER USING THIS
THERE IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER
SAYS THAT WE SET GOALS SET A
SEVENTY NINE POINT 5% OF ALL
CASES BUT LAST WEEK LAST YEAR
WE DID 84% AND YEAH. IT'S
NORMAL EVERYBODY DOES IT IS
WHAT I KEEP HEARING EVERYBODY
DOES IT ALL THIS IS ALMOST
STANDARD WITHIN THE- WITHIN
THIS COMMUNITY. YES IT IS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MAY BE TO.
BUT IT'S HOW WE DO IT. I MEAN
THE HOME WE FIND EVERYTHING. IF
WE WERE SAID DURING THOSE CASES
FOLLOWING THE GUIDELINES I
WOULD NOT BE SITTING HERE. IF
WE WERE SETTLING THESE CASES
WHAT APPROPRIATE.
REHABILITATIVE REAL
REHABILITATE THIS INITIATIVES
IN PLACE I WOULD NOT BE SITTING
BOTTOM SITTING ON BECAUSE NONE
OF THAT IS FALL IS AS HAPPY AS
THIS ANYTHING. FROM MY
EXPERIENCE MY BOARD MEMBERS MAY
DISAGREE. SO LET ME QUOTE YOU
THIS. AND THE THIS IS ALSO A
KEEN. THE CALLOUSNESS THE YOU
KNOW LIKE INDIFFERENCE WITH
WHICH THIS NUMBERS ARE
REPRESENTED. IS EVEN SO MUCH
MORE TROUBLING BECAUSE I WANT
TO GIVE YOU A SKETCH OF THE
BACKGROUND OF THIS. WHEN YOU
ENTER INTO A STIPULATED
SETTLEMENT. I DOCTOR WALKS AWAY
WITHOUT HAVING TO INCUR ANY
MORE ISSUES. REGARDLESS OF HOW
GOOD HE JUST YOUR FINGERS. HI.
UNDER THE TERMS OR THE PUBLIC
THAT HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
BEHAVIOR OF THAT DOCTOR.
THEY'LL BE LUCKY IF THEY GET A
LETTER. AND THEY ARE LATEST.
HAVING DID YOU CLOSE IS CUT
SHORT BECAUSE NOW WE WANT TO
SAVE MONEY NOW WE WANT TO GO
EFFICIENT OVER BEING EFFECTIVE.
AND THAT SHOWS YOU THAT THE
SYSTEM IS NOT DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. IT IS IT
BECAUSE OF BENEFITS RIGHT. BUT
LET ME BRING YOU INTO THE INTO
THE REAL FEELINGS THINGS THE
STOP AND WE KIND OF AVOID. BUT
IT CAME. HOME TO ROOST AT THE
LAST BOARD MEETING. WHEN FOLKS
CALLING FROM DISPLACED. I'M
ONLY THURMOND PASS. IN THE
HALLS FROM THE HOLIDAY BREAK.
CHOLERIC OF NOT HAVING IT ANSYS.
THE CRY OF A MOTHER WHO LOST
THE DAUGHTER. A COMMA FOLLOWED
WHICH WAS FEELING POWERLESS.
POPULOUS BECAUSE HE COULDN'T
PROTECTIONS AND- WE CREATED. NO
ONE ELSE. I'LL BLOOD PANELS
THAT MAKES THESE DECISIONS. WE
CAN EASILY PUSH BACK WE CAN
REVIEW CASES IF WE WANTED THAT
SO IT WILL BE SO. BECAUSE
EVENTUALLY ALL THE CASES COME
BACK TO US. AND WHEN THEY COME
BACK TO US THEY COME BACK WITH
COMMENTS SO WE COULD GET BETTER
WE COULD BUILD THE SYSTEM
BETTER. IF WE WANTED TO. BUT
THERE'S NO WILL. THERE'S NO
CREATIVITY THAT I HAVE
WITNESSED BUT WHAT THE EAST. IS
CONCEALING. A CLOSED SYSTEM.
SHUTTING EVERYBODY DOWN THAT'S
WHAT HE IS SO BUT IT'S
CONTINUOUS AUTO BETS. SEVENTY
NINE POINTS PLAQUE WAS IN CALL
OF THE CASES THAT EVERYONE DOES
IT. LET ME GIVE YOU MY
STATISTICS. HELLO TO ALL MY
CASES THAT I DID LAST YEAR. IN
THIS MAY INTEREST HIM AND DRAW.
THAT FOR THE STIPULATED
SETTLEMENTS THAT WE DEVIATED
90% OF THE TIME. USING IN MY
OPINION WEEK MITIGATING FACTORS.
MISREPRESENTING FACTS AND- THIS
ONLY ONLY SINCE AND CALL ME
SINCE I'M GOING TO INDICATING.
THIS COULD NOT BE INFLAMMATORY.
BUT THE SENIOR SPENDING
BENEFITS DOCTORS. END MANY
TIMES WHEN I SEE THIS I I'M I'M
TRYING TO THINK WHAT HAPPENS
AND BACCHANAL. SO WHEN I PUSHED
BACK ON TO THIS CASES INCOME CA
BOARD LEADERSHIP IT BECOMES
VERY APPARENT THAT THEY WILL
LISTEN TO ME. BUT YOU ME.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY REALLY
GOING TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FULL TO
MAJORITY ON YOUR BOARD. AND
UNLESS I COME IN A PREPAID
THREE DAYS TWO WEEKS IN ADVANCE
I'VE LEARNED MORE SKILLS ABOUT
PRESENTING CASES THAN I EVER
TOLD I WOULD SIGN VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. BUT ANOTHER IS
ANOTHER INTERESTING TO
STATISTICS HOW MY INFORMATION.
THAT I THINK WILL BE IN THE
REINS WITH THE BOARD'S
INFORMATION IF WE WERE TO
CHANGE FORMATION IF WE ASKED
FOR RECALLS. DR A LOT- JIM IN
THE WORLD ASK FOR HOW MANY
TIMES DID WE ISSUE LETTERS OF
PUBLIC CREEK FROM. AND I HAVE
IT AT 40% OF THE CASE OF CASE.
I DON'T 30% 240% THAT'S WE ALL.
SO WE SET THE LITTERED MORE ALL
OF OUR CASES BY PUBLICLY FROM.
AND I. LEARN SOMETHING TODAY
THAT IT INCLUDES ONE PATIENT
AND TWO. SIMPLE THE POLITICS.
THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
I'VE SEEN. AND I'LL LEAVE THAT
TO ANOTHER POINT ABOVE THE
PUBLIC REPRIMANDS IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. THE BOARD
QUOTED AND CAN BE A LITTLE TEAM.
ONE OF THE THINGS. THE BOOK
BOOK TODAY YEAH WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
COMMENTS THREE YES. WHEN I DO
THAT CALCULATION FOR THE S.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY I
GOT THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE. THAT'S A FEAT. IT'S A
TEAM OF HOW WE PLAY WITH
NUMBERS IT'S A TEAM WHEN YOU
PRESENT TOPLINE NUMBERS AND YOU
DON'T REALLY GET INTO THE
NUMBERS. BUT I DON'T WANT TO GO
TOO DEEP IN THERE SOMEONE ELSE
CAN DO THAT. BECAUSE I'VE DONE
ENOUGH OF THAT. IS ANOTHER
INTERESTING TO STATISTICS OUR-
WE CYNICAL PROBATION CASES
AROUND 72% OF ALL PROBATION
CASES. WITH A LITTLE PUBLIC
REPRIMAND. TWO YEARS PROBATION
THIRTY FIVE MONTHS PROBATION
AND THREE YEARS PROBATION I'LL
TWO YEARS PROBATION WE SET ALL
THAT UP 90% OF THE TIME. SO 73%
OF THE TIME. WE DEVIATE. 40%
FROM THE GUIDELINES ON AVERAGE.
SO JUST THINK ABOUT THAT THINK
THINK THINK WHAT THAT MEANS
THAT MEANS IN THE REST OF THE
TIME. IN THE OTHER 27% OF THE
TIME. THAT'S WHEN WE FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES AND I CAN TELL YOU.
MOST OF THE TIMES WHEN WE DO
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES THOSE
CASES NEEDED TO BE REBUILT.
THOSE CASES ALSO AGREED JUST WE
NEEDED TO TAKE A STAND BUT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE WILL
TO REALLY PROTECT THE PUBLIC HE
CAN SAY THAT ALL DAY AND ALL.
WE CAN SAY THAT IT'S NOT
PRESENT IN THE STATISTICS IT'S
NOT PRESENT IN OUR BEHAVIOR AND
GUESS WHAT THE PUBLIC TELLS US
THAT ALL THE TIME. BY TELLING
US THEY DO NOT TRUST US. YES
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
I KIND OF AGREE WITH THAT. WE
DO NOT WE HAVE NOT AND THE
TALKS. RECENTLY WHEN THE ALL
COLLEAGUES WILL BE FOR THE
SENATE. WELL CONFIRMATION
HEARING SOMEONE WAS ONE OF ALL
COLLEAGUES POINTED OUT THAT YOU
KNOW WE PAYING. THEIR DISPLAYED
THESE FEES AND YOU KNOW. WHAT
WAS ESSENTIALLY SAYING IS THAT
THEY ARE IN STATE BOARD. BUT I
WANT TO EXPLAIN SOMETHING ABOUT
A LICENSING AGREEMENTS BECAUSE
I'VE DONE A FEW OF THOSE IN MY
LIFE. A LICENSING AGREEMENT IS
THAT YOU HAVE. QUIET PLUS IN A
BRAND. AND EVEN. BIASED THAT
BRAND IS BUYING THAT REPUTATION.
AND FOR MANY YEARS THROUGHOUT
THE AGES DOCTORS HAVE BEING.
THE PREMIUM BRAND. IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC TRUST WELL THESE A. WELL
DESERVED BECAUSE THEY'VE ALWAYS
DONE GOOD BUT THE HE'S VERY
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
DOCTORS THAT DEVIATE FROM THAT
STANDARD. SO WHEN WE DO NOT
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES. WE
DILUTE THE VERY INTEGRITY OF
THE PROTECTION. THEN WE SAY WE
CARE ABOUT BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HOLD DOCTORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WRONGDOING AT THE LEVEL THAT WE
CAN KNOCK IS MANY REASONS FOR
THAT. I COULD SIT DOWN WITH OUR
LEGAL COUNSEL AND WE CAN GO TO
SECTIONS OF THIS LAW AND COME
UP WITH NEW WAYS TO DO THIS
THAT WILL AID THIS. AB
SOLUTIONS BUT WE'VE NEVER HAD
THIS CONVERSATION. AND THAT'S
WHY I'M A CHRISTIAN. I'VE
ALWAYS GET BUT JUST WANTED THIS
CONVERSATION. MISTER WATKINS I
NEED TO GIVE YOU A ONE MINUTE
WARNING I APOLOGIZE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE VERY VERY
SHORTLY BECAUSE I SUSPECT THAT
THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT OF THAT
AS WELL. SO I WILL WRAP UP ITS
TEEN THIRTY FORTY SECONDS.
CHECK OUT. THE OTHER THING THAT
ANY USE THAT. WE DO NOT WE SAY
WE APPLIED THE UNIFORMS
STANDARD SIX AND FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE AND WE DON'T. WE SAY WE
UNDERMINE EXPENSE SOME MONTHS
THAT EVERY TIME THAT THAT.
FORTY PERCENT- THAT WE- RIGHT
PUBLIC RECOMMENDS. AND ALL THAT
TIME ALL OF THAT IS BECAUSE
THERE WAS. EXPECTATIONS I'M
GOING TO DISAGREE IT AT ACT ANY
CONCLUSION. I'M LOOKING FORWARD
LOOKING ATTITUDE CON A PROBLEM
SOLVING PERSON THAT'S ONE COME
TO. I WANT TO INVITE THE
COMMITTEE. ONE AND DEFENDING TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S CHALLENGES BECAUSE THEY
ARE INTEGRAL INTEGRAL TO. OUR
SOCIETY. AND I WANT TO ASK OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THEN THEY WORK
WITH US FIND THE RIGHT DATA AND
INFORMATION. SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A REAL DATA TO
WORK FROM. COME UP WITH REAL
SOLUTIONS. I THINK THE
COMMITTEE I THANK EVERYONE THAT
MADE THIS POSSIBLE. AND I AM
CONFIDENT NOW WE WOULD AT LEAST
BEGIN TO START A DIALOGUE IN
THE FIRST PLACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER WATKINS- LET
ME JUST CHECK TO SEE ON THE
COMPUTER SCREEN IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM. MEMBERS OF OUR
PANELISTS NONE HERE IN THE US
SENATE CHAMBERS. OF SO THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU PANELIST WE WILL NOW ACCEPT
TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC REGARDING THIS MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET
REVIEW HEARING LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NO WITNESSES. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES. THANK
YOU WE ILL NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF HIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR AND
BEFORE WE START ONCE FOLKS HAVE
QUEUED UP WOULD YOU GIVE ME A
ESTIMATE OF THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN
THE CABLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES AND CALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE THE
MEMBERS OF THE PIANO WITH THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
MUSICIANS. ALTHOUGH IT WOULD A
GOOD DAY I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THE BACKGROUND. BRIEFING
SESSION ON IT. RIGHT WHICH IS A
MAJOR CONCERN. MEDIA OR MODERN.
EE THANK YOU LET ME JUST
COMMENT FOR THOSE ON THE LINE
WHO PRESENT TEST IT WAS VERY
DIFFERENT. TO HEAR AND
UNDERSTAND THE LAST PRESENTER I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THE PHONE TO
RUN OR IF IT'S OUR CONNECTION
BUT LET'S TRY TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY SO THAT WE CAPTURE
ALL OF THE COMMENTS WE VALUE
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM. NEXT.
THANK YOU AT NINE SEVENTY NINE
THE BILL HAS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- IT HELP AT
ALL WE DO HERE FEEDBACK ON THE
PHONE LINE- LIKE A LIKE AN ECHO
BUT I'LL TRY TO GET YOUR MY
COMMENT AND MEGAN THE BIRTH ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING VERY
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
CLINICS- ALTHOUGH NOT
CRITICALLY DISCUSSED TODAY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THE
ISSUES SURROUNDING THE POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE AT A
FUTURE. OVERSIGHT HEARING
OUTLINED IN YOUR COMMITTEE
BACKGROUND DOCUMENT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT HAVE
COME TO LIGHT DURING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PPL THAT
HAVE NEGATIVELY IMPACTEDTHE
ABILITY FOR RESIDENTS TO
PROVIDE CARE IN COMMUNITIES.
NEED AND THAT THE OVER FORTY
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER THAT-
TRADE RESIDENTS WE APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE CONTENT ON THE ISSUE
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD STAFF YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE NUMBERS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION AND
EQUIPPED WITH ALL OF THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JUST A REMINDER TO THOSE ON THE
LINES PLEASE REMEMBER TO MUTE
THE PIECE OF EQUIPMENT THAT
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
WHETHER IT'S A COMPUTER OR
SOMETHING ELSE. THAT WILL CAUSE
FEEDBACK NEXT. THANK YOU RIGHT
TWO CALL. MY NAME IS JOEL. I'M
AN ADVOCATE WITH THE FOR
INJURED CAMPAIGN AND A
CONSTITUENCY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM'S AND GROVER BEACH
MY HUSBAND FONG WAS A CANCER
SURVIVOR BURKE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WHEN HE WAS
EXPERIENCING SEVERE PSYCHOTIC
SYMPTOMS WHILE ON THE DRUG
PREDNISONE I CONTACTED HIS
DOCTOR AT STANFORD MEDICAL
CLINICS. AFTER TO EVALUATE ON A
PRESCRIBED TREATMENT BUT DON
STOCKTON REFUSED TO TREAT DONE
WITH ANY DRUGS TO CONTROL HIS
PSYCHOTIC SYMPTOMS AND WOULD
NOT BE FOR US TO A PSYCHIATRIST
HE SAID INSTEAD THAT HE WOULD
BE FINE WHEN SHE WAS TAPERED
OFF FRIENDS- AFTER ABOUT THREE
WEEKS MY WORST FEARS WERE
REALIZED. JOHN BECAME VERY
DEPRESSED AND ON THE MORNING
WHEN I DECIDED TO FIND A
PSYCHIATRIST ON MY OWN YOU LEFT
HOME AND NEVER RETURNED LATER
DON'S BODY WAS FOUND HE DIED.
BY A SELF INFLICTED GUNSHOT
WOUND. SUBSEQUENT I RESEARCH
TREATMENT FOR PREGNANT AND DO
SAIKIA YEAH. THE MAJORITY OF
MEDICAL. STATED THAT PATIENTS
SHOULD BE EVALUATED AND CLOSELY
MONITORED. PREDNISONE REDUCED
IMPOSSIBLE IN DRUGS PRESCRIBED
FOR EXTREME CASES. WARNINGS
WERE GIVEN TO WATCH FOR
SUICIDAL BEHAVIOR. WITH THIS
INFORMATION IN MIND I FILED A
COMPLAINT AGAINST THE DOCTOR
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. STATING THAT SHE
HAD BEEN NEGLIGENT BY NOT
EVALUATING AND TREATING DON FOR
HIS PSYCHOTIC SYMPTOMS. TO MY
DISAPPOINTMENT THE BOARD
CONCLUDED THE DONS DOCTOR HAD
ACTED WITHIN THE STANDARDS OF
MEDICAL PRACTICE BY SIMPLY TO
BRING DON OFF THE PREDNISONE. I
THINK YOUR THE WHOLE REASON FOR
MY COMPLAINT THE DORMS DOCTOR
HAD BEEN NEGLIGENT BY NOT
EVALUATED MONITORING. AND
TREATING DON FOR HIS PSYCHOTIC
SYMPTOMS CAUSED BY THE PRINTERS
ON THE UNION TO STAND ON THE
CASE BECAUSE THEY CLOSED IT
WITHOUT ONE SPEAKING TO ME. IT
WAS AS IF THE MEDICAL EXAMINER
PURPOSELY SOUGHT TO EXONERATE
DON'S DOCTOR INSTEAD OF HOLDING
HER ACCOUNTABLE. PLEASE HOLD
THE MEDICAL BOARD MORE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC. BY
MAKING THEM INTERVIEW EVERY
PATIENT WHO SUBMITS A COMPLAINT
CONDUCTED JONES AND BY
INCREASING PUBLIC MEMBERS. SO
DOCTORS ARE NO LONGER IN CHARGE
THANK. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY STORY. THANK YOU
NAY PLEASE. THANK YOU I
FOURTEEN THREE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAROL
BROWN. YOU I'M A MEMBER OF THE
FAIR FOR INJURED BACK CAMPAIGN
IN THE CONSTITUENCY OF SENATOR
PACKER ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
IN REDWOOD CITY. MY HUSBAND
DIED DUE TO MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE
WELL UNDER THE CARE OF A
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT I FILED A
COMPLAINT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THEIR INVESTIGATION RESULTED IN
A FINDING OF THE HIGHEST SCOPE
AND SEVERITY. LEVEL FOR
IMMEDIATE JEOPARDY THE
INFORMATION WAS FORWARDED TO
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
FOR REVIEW AND FURTHER
INVESTIGATION AS IT RELATED TO
THE PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS
OPTIONS. MONTHS LATER I WILL I
WISH DEEPENING AND STRUGGLING
WITH PTSD DUE TO THE INCIDENT I
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
BOARD. HATED BETTER RECORD IN
THE INCIDENT WOULD BE PLACED IN
THE PHYSICIAN'S. FILE IN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WOULD BE
CONSIDERED ONLY IF THERE WERE
ADDITIONAL INCIDENTS I WAS
APPALLED BY THE BOARD'S
DECISION AND FAILED TO
DISCIPLINE AND HOLD THE
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANT
ACCOUNTABLE EVEN THOUGH THERE
WAS A LOSS OF LIFE. JUSTICE WAS
NOT SERVED. I'M A HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL AND BY THEIR
INACTION THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD HAS LOST MY RESPECT I
WILL FOR EVER BE LEFT WITH THE
IMPRESSION THAT ONE AGENCIES
YOU CAN USE THE INCIDENT THAT
SUB STANDARD QUALITY OF CARE
WITH THE LOSS OF LIFE THAT
REQUIRED IMMEDIATE CORRECTION.
WELL THE OTHER PLACE TO DO IN
THE FINAL. THE FACT THAT A
LICENSE LOSS DIDN'T SEEM TO
MATTER SHE CENTROLEGAL LIFE
LOSS QUICKLY OUT OF. MY BELOVED
HUSBAND MICHAEL. CLEAR THAT
YOUR FIRST PRIORITY IS TO. THE
SHIPPING AND NOT THE KIDS.
POLICE REFORM THE BOARD TO
INCLUDE MORE NEW OF THE CLUB.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO PRESENT YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY. MA'AM MODERATOR- NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU OF
MINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BURGER KING LOUIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SENATORS SENATOR SUSAN
EGGMAN AND CULTURES CRISTINA
LAWSON PUBLIC CROWD THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR GIVING THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HATING- COMMITTEE OR A
FEW YEARS AGO- BOARD MEMBER DR
IN FACT MEDICAL OF AUDIO. IN
MANY ACT AND GET THE LAW AND-
AT THE DISCIPLINE OFTEN A BLANK
BLACK FEATURES BY THE OF
MEDICAL. WITHOUT ANY HEATING
OPENING PACKED IT IS NO OKAY
SCHEDULES COMING BOARD- DOCTOR
HAS NOT I TOOK. A CRACK APART
REQUEST- I HAVE SPOKEN BEFORE
HUNDRED COULD NOT BRING UP I
SPOKEN STATE JACKETED ON COULD.
AND TO TELL THE THIRTEEN BIKE
AND I WITH. DOES LEE HAVE BOTH
PUBLISHED BECAUSE AND CLOSER
THAN EGGMAN AND ACT ABOUT I
DON'T- ABOUT PUBLIC AND ATTEND
COME. I'M GOING TO MENTION A
BRIEF. FEELING ABOUT SOME THAT
THAT I THAT LOOKING AT THE IN
THE NAME OF THE MEDICAL. AND
LOOK COUNTY- DOUBLE BECAUSE IN
THE CENTER NEEDS OF BY.
RESPECTABLE SUPERVISORS. CHEN
LAST MINUTE DOC COUNTY HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEE AND DOUBLE THE
EMPLOYEE HAS COME UNDER CLOSE
HE COULD COMPOSE A CONVERSATION.
AND DATA SENTENCE IN. ARE
DENYING FLIGHTS BEIJING ALLEGED
COURTNEY COMPLETE TWENTY FOUR
YEAH THEM TO TRAINING. THE
TEXANS LEGAL THE EVIDENCE SHORT
DAY POLITICOS HARPER KIND OF
PULLED BACK SHE COMPLETELY
TWENTY MONTHS I'VE KICKING AND
DAY. THANK AYE CONNECTED FIVE
WELL IF YOU CAN HELP. WE CAN BE
UP AND COMPUTER THAT THEY HAD
NO MADE FALSE STATEMENTS AND
TONIGHT LICENSE BUT- DIFFICULT
DOESN'T SAYING BACK SHE HAD NOT
COMPLETED TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AS
TEACHING. SINCE BEEN AT THREE
ONE HAS BEEN GETTING LIKE CRY.
IN YEARS ACCOUNTING BECAUSE
THEY ARE CONTROLLED BY THE THEN
LOOKING COUNTY SAID. ABOARD
IMPLY THE CAN BE DISCIPLINED BY.
BOARD MEMBERS THE STATE'S LIKE.
AND WE ARE JUST THAT NO ONE HAS
CAN. ACT TO HOLD GUYS TO COME.
RIGHT AND IN START DATE COULD
NOT THE HARSH ACTION AND
CONNECTED CAR THAT INTO
TREATMENT. SORT OF CRACKED
ATTACK. ENTANGLED ON SOMEONE
GOING TO GET. ALL THE WHAT THE
PARTY HAD BEEN DECLINED RIGHT
BECAUSE HAVE BEEN FROM THE ACT
BY MEDICAL AND THAT OF TWENTY
TO DISTANCE DEDUCTIBLE MAY ACT
BECAUSE ALL IN THE SHOW FOR
KILEY ACCORDING TO THEM THAT I
COULD ONLY TAKE FOUR YEARS BUT
THIS IS BEING. MORE THAN TEN
YEARS AND TAX A LOOK AT. THE
ACCOUNT. BUT THE CONDITION LIKE
SPOKE COUNTY HOSPITAL AND THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND ARE GENERAL.
SHOULD STICK WITH SHANDA INCE
CORRECT TAX MEETING CAMPAIGN.
OR DEMAND COMPRESSION AND ALL
YOUR I COULD. SHE I PICKING
QUESTION PORCH BECAUSE- LAWSON
SHE IS A TALENT OR TECHNO AND-
CASE. RENDON BECALI HOOPS BONTA
BROUGH CRYING. FORTY NINE BACK.
RIGHT A VERY DIFFICULT FOR
CONVINCE. DR FOR THE INITIATIVE
SHE- SHE TRAINED AND CSX FORM
COMPLETE YOU MUST BE BY POST
MOSTLY CARE ACT A CAL.
ACCORDING TO MEDIC PROFESSOR
AND THE THEY HAVE. A LACK OF
FUNDS. THE INDISCIPLINE BATCH
HAS BEEN AT THE DAMAGE HARPER
AND COMPASSION POSITION SHE
OPEN THE VOTED EXTRA TIME TO
PENSION OKAY BUT COMPARED. SO
THIS READY TO IT'S NOT BAD BUT
YOU'D LIKE TO CATCH THAT I'M
THE MEDICAL MEMBER BY THE CLASS
CRUNCH. AND BOTH THE HOSPITAL
CAN THE BOARD IMPLY TO TAKE A
CRACK AT THE I COULD CRY LIKE
TO AMERICAN TAX FLOOD HAS
PROVIDED. WHO JUST FOR SO.
RESPONSIVE TO PROTECT. CLICK
HARPER FOR THE RECORD WE HAD WE
HIRED AN ATTORNEY WHO WROTE A
LETTER TO THE BIG NAME LOG HOME
THE LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND PUT A MEDICAL BOARD
REQUESTING A CURRENT AND I HAVE
PERSONALLY REQUESTED TRIED AND
I HAVE TRAVELED TO OPEN IT AND
PRETENDED FOR MAKING THE FUEL
FLOW I THANK BOARD MEETING
MINUTES ON WHO DOESN'T SEVEN I
HAVE ATTENDED MAKING AND
BECAUSE RIGHT WE ARE ONLY
SCRATCHING I COULD. SIR I'M
GOING TO HAVE LOT BEING A
SERVER AND SERVER AND TO HAVE
TO YOU TO UP I LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING YOUR WRITTEN OF YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AND WE WILL I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WE WILL
CAREFULLY CONSIDER IT JUST AS
WE WILL DO YOUR COMMENTS UP. TO
THIS POINT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TWO. THAT ONLY BE POLITICAL
AT THAT LETTER TO ONLY.
SPEAKING WITH NOW. OKAY SIR I
DID NOT A DID NOT HEAR WHAT
WHAT WAS YOUR- I. AM NOT IN THE
SOME POINT I AM ON THE PHONE
CALL I CANNOT YOU I AM I
APOLOGIZE I CANNOT BE HOME
SPEAKING WITH. WHILE YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO RICHARD ROTH OF
MUCH OF THIS. A BILL PER AND-
DEVELOPMENT CAN WHICH IS ONE OF
THE TWO. CA THIS CHOICE HERE
TODAY. WE DO HAVE NUMBER OF WE
DO HAVE A OF I THINK WE DO A
NUMBER PUBLIC- PUBLIC MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC WHO WISH ALSO OFFER.
COMMENT TRY NOT TO LIMIT- THE
TESTIMONY BUT I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO ASK YOU TO- TO WRAP UP AT
THIS POINT SO PLEASE. SEND THE
STRUGGLING ECONOMY LET ME.
ELEVEN OUR KINDA BUDGET THE
COMPLETE TECH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR YOUR MISSED BY MY NEXT
MA'AM. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES YES HELLO
MY NAME IS ROSE ANNA DAVIS
THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A
LICENSED MIDWIVES. THANK YOU
TODAY FOR- IN GREAT DETAIL
ADDRESSING ENFORCEMENT UNDER
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
I WILL TOUCH ON IT BRIEFLY IN
MY COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
LICENSED MIDWIFE PROGRAM UNDER
THE MEDICAL BOARD MEMBER ME
JUST MAKE A COMMENT FIRST OF
MA'AM BEFORE YOU PROCEED. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SEPARATE
HEARING ON LICENSING SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD
RESTRICT YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
MATERIAL COVERED TODAY WHICH
HAS TO DO WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. BUT THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA AND THEN I CAN
ASSURE YOU OF THAT I WILL GIVE
YOU AN AMPLE OPPORTUNITY DURING
OUR NEXT MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA SUNSET OVERSIGHT
HEARING WHICH IS EITHER ON THE
FILE OR WILL BE SHORTLY. TO
TALK ABOUT- LICENSING AND OTHER
ISSUES HAVING TO DO WITH YOUR
SUBJECT. OKAY RIGHT THEN I WILL
BE VERY BRIEFLY COMMENT ON
ENFORCEMENT AND- AND THAT IS-
UNDER ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER HOW WILL
LICENSE MIDWIVES BOARD BENEFIT
PATIENTS- WITH. NO TRAINING IN
MIDWIFERY SERVICES POSITION TO
EXPERT REVIEW LICENSED MIDWIFE
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS OF CARE AND WHEN OR
IF THEY HAVE BEEN THAT
ADDITIONALLY WITHOUT THE RIGHT
TO REVIEW COMPLAINTS. THE
MIDWIFERY PROFESSION IS
OPERATING IN THE DARK WHEN IT
COMES TO IDENTIFYING PATTERNS
WHICH MAY POSE A THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY OR THAT SHOULD
INFORM QUALITY CONTROL
INITIATIVES. J. EVERYONE'S TIME
TODAY AND WITHOUT AYE I WILL
CONCLUDE I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT. SUN
RISING A LICENSED MIDWIFE
PROGRAM THANK YOU WHICH TAKES A
MOMENT LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU AT THE NEXT HEARING
NEXT. MARIA THANK YOU NINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS WENDY CONNECT
AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT THE
PATIENT I WAS THE VICTIM OF MY
SURGEON CONFLICT THAT INTERESTS
WHEN I HAD RECONSTRUCTION FOR
PREVENTIVE FOR PROJECT WITH YOU
THINK PREVENTATIVE DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY YOU MIGHT DIAGNOSIS
OF THE BRACKET EUGENE. I HAD
IDEA MY DOCTOR HAD BEEN PAID.
ALMOST HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
PER DEVICE FEES NEVER
DISCLOSING THAT IT WAS
EXPERIMENTAL. THAT DEVICE
EXPLODED INSIDE ME MY INITIAL
COMPLAINT TO THE BOARD WAS
CLOSED WITHOUT INVESTIGATION I
WOULD NOT CONTRIBUTE. OPENED
AGAIN AFTER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
SETTLEMENT CLOSED AGAIN AND
THEN NOW WE OPEN. BUT ALMOST
FIVE YEARS HAVE GONE BY. AND
MANY MORE PATIENTS HAVE BEEN
HARMED ANYONE THAT I KNOW HAVE
HAD DIED. WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT IS THE PRO
LEGISLATION. AB ONE TWO SEVEN
EIGHT WHICH IS NOW BEFORE THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONAL
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD HAVE
ELIMINATED THE NEED. FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AB ONE TWO SEVEN EIGHT
WOMEN MANDATE A DOCTOR THE
CLOSURE OF FINANCIAL CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST. INVOLVED IN THE
PATIENT'S CARE. MADE BY DRUG
AND DEVICE COMPANIES. THIS
INFORMATION IS VITAL TO THE
RIGHT OF THE PATIENT TO HAVE
FULLY INFORMED CONSENT. AND WE
AND I SHOULD MENTION NOW THAT
MY HUSBAND IS THE POSITION. HAD
ANY IDEA THAT MY THIRD UNIT
BEING PAID THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
HI I'M LOOKING FOR THE DEVICE
IMPLANTED IN ME. WE HAVE HAD
POWERFUL INFORMATION TO ASK THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS. THE OWNERS
SHOULD NOT BE ON THE PATIENT TO
KNOW THAT THE OPEN PAYMENTS%
NINETY FIFTH. DO THE RESEARCH
AND THEN TALK TO THE DOCTOR AB
ONE TWO SEVEN EIGHT WILL ALSO
MAKE THE OPEN PAYMENTS WEBSITE
PROMINENT AND KNOWN TO
PATIENTS. BILLING THE INTENTION
OF THE PHYSICIAN PAYMENT
SUNSHINE ACT. IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR POSITION AS ACCOUNTABLE AS
YOUR REAL ESTATE AGENT OR YOUR
FINANCIAL ADVISOR. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THE DOCTOR TO DISCLOSE
THEIR FINANCIAL INTERESTS. IN A
FACILITY THEY ARE SENDING YOU
TO. SURELY IT MAKES EVEN MORE
SENSE TO KNOW ABOUT THEIR
FINANCIAL INVOLVEMENT IN A DRUG
OR DEVICE. THEY PLAN TO USE IN
YOUR TREATMENT. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING AB ONE TWO SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
FOR COMMONSENSE BUT RETURN NEXT.
THANK YOU RIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED
OKAY. MY NAME IS MONIQUE HìNH
AND I AM FROM BAKER I AM WITH
THE FAIRNESS FOR INJURED
PATIENTS. MY RECORD THAT THERE
ARE DEFINITE AND PROFESSION
COMMITTEE MEMBER MOLESTED HER
TO. I UNDERSTAND BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS NUMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS JUNIOR. I WOULD
ALL LIKE TO THANK MY BIG.
LEGISLATOR FOR THEIR- FOR
MOTHERS AND BAKER BOB. MIKE AND
WEBER HOURS. IN A MATTER
NEGLIGENCE THE MOTHER I THINK
AT THREE O'CLOCK YEAH WERE
IGNORE BY KEEP LEVY MY GRANDPA
AND ALLOW IF THEY A PRO MORTEM.
NOW TO MAKE. WITH MOTHER BUT HE
SAID A MEDICAL INDEPENDENT-
SORRY IN CHARGE OF HIS CARE
MADE A CAP OF AIR. ENJOY FOR
MEDICAL RECORDS THERE IS NO
CLEAR TO FOR HIS. HE WOULD NOT
GIVEN AN MEDICARE AND THAT
WOULD BE GOOD FOR BY
RESPIRATORY SYNDROME AND THE
DOCTOR CHECK YOU LONG TO HIM BY.
TO ANOTHER HOSPITAL KNOWING
THEY DID NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO SAVE HIS LIFE. YOUR
OUT MY FAMILY PUBLIC GRIEF. WE
HAVE RECEIVED NOTHING BUT GRIEF
FROM THE MEDICAL BOARD. WE WERE
DISCOURAGED FROM FILING
COMPLAINTS ON BEHALF OF
MOLOKAI. WE WERE TOLD THAT IT
WOULD NOT MATTER AND THAT WE
CANNOT USE THE THING DOCTOR
TWICE. IN ANOTHER ACCUSATION
NOW TRIED REFER TO A DEFEAT AT.
IT ALL STATED THAT HE WAS BORN
AND HE DIED END OF STORY. MY
GRANDSON WOULD NOT EAT IT. YOU
HAVE BEEN ALMOST FIVE POUND
BABY OY. HIS NAME IS NOW OKAY.
HE RIGHT. TWENTY FOUR THE. NO
MATTER IF YOU WERE. EIGHT
EIGHT. OR EIGHTEEN DAYS THE
MEDICAL IS NOT. THE PUBLIC
BOARD MAJORITY. WE'LL BEGIN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR MORE AND
POLICY WE HAVE THE MAJORITY
PARTY. YOU NEED. THANK YOU IN
THE COUNTY BOARD RETURNS TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THEY ARE NO
PROTECTION. WHICH WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
IMPORT OUT. RECOVERY SHOULD
EMPLOYED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD I
SAID THE BOARD PAPER ALL THE.
PER PROP THE PEOPLE. PAGE
PROBATE WHEN THE IS FACING AND-
WITH THE VISION FOR THEIR AND
WHAT BENCHMARK HUGHES CASE.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE FIGHTING
EVERY. REGIS CAN'T TALK TO SHE
WE HAVE TO TAKE NOW I DO I
RATHER THAN BE LIKE MY GRAN
WHAT DO YOU THINK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M VERY SORRY FOR
YOUR IN I DO A THE FACT THE
USED WAITED ON THE TO PER YOUR-
YOUR TESTING SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. MODERATOR NEXT. THANK YOU
TWENTY PLEASED AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES LOGICALLY
PLEASE PROCEED. EXCELLENT I GET
AFTERNOON SHARES MEMBERS- NAME
IS THE MOM CAL MAN SO. WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK BURKE
STAFF AND THE BACKGROUND PART
LOOK FOR THE CAN TO WITH BOTH
TO MAKE AS WELL AS THE MEDICAL
IN ORDER TO ENSURE MATCH.
EFFICIENCY IN AFRICA THREE A
MEDICAL BOARD. THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS TASKED WITH PROTECTION
OF CONSUMER AND ABOUT. TO
QUALITY CARE THROUGH LICENSE
THE- REGULATIONS TO THE. WHILE
THE CAR MEDICAL. SUPPORTS THE
CONTINUE OPERATE SUBMIT BOARD
AMERICA BOARDS CURRENT FISCAL
CAN COULD A SIX. CHALLENGE AND
ITS OBJECTIVE. PRIVACY MAKE THE
POOR SESSION AT AFFECT.
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS THAT
PROTECTS CONSUMERS IF YOU
CALIFORNIA BASED. WE SUPPORT
TOO MUCH OF WILSON'S MEDICAL
BOARD AT THE TO ABOUT. RESPOND
TO APPROACH PRICE RESOURCE THAT
WILL HELP ENSURE SAFETY THE
PUBLIC. WE SUPPORT STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTION. WE ALSO
RECKON THAT. OF DUE TO. AND
CONFIDENCE CAN. AGAIN WE THANK
YOU ALL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD. UP TO BE THEM PARDON
RATTUS AND THROUGH THE UP
COMING HERE THIS IS ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT. THANK
YOU OF MINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ACTUALLY GETTING AN ISLAND IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA MY
REPRESENTATIVE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE MEMORY
SENATOR RICHARD. I'M HERE AT
THE IN YOUR CASE OF OUR AND I'M
HERE BECAUSE THE STORY OF MY
MATTER YOU THINK IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN ABOUT MESSAGES WHICH
ULTIMATELY. REMEMBER THE
PROJECT IN MEMORY WHO. WERE
DIFFICULTY ON. IS SO YOU- SPEAK
SLOWLY AND TRYING OUR TO. ITS
OUR SYSTEM BUT I TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE'LL- WE'LL HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS SO WE CAN AKE THEM IN
THE CAREFUL CONSIDERATION
PLEASE. YEAH SORRY I HAD MY
HEADPHONES AND FIGHT WITH THE
OUT LEAD TO BETTER THE BETTER
IT IS BETTER THANK YOU. YEAH
HI. HELLO MY NAME IS ASHLEY CAN
I LIVE IN ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
MY REPRESENTATIVE BENEFIT. OF
THE QUESTION NUMBER ONE-
RICHARD CLARK. I'M WITH THE
SENATE FOR INJURED PATIENTS ACT
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE THE
STORY OF MY MOTHER JUNE SECOND.
WAS A BIG OF MEDICAL. WHICH ARE
COSTING THE. MY MOM THIRTY.
EXCRUCIATING HEADACHE THE ONLY
EIGHT. AFTER INFLICTING PAYMENT
FOR HEADACHE IF YOU. INFORMED
BY BRING. WITH YOU RELATED. I
FIND WITHIN IN MY- I THANK AT
THE WILL MOST LIKELY. TUMORS
KNOWN TO BE GROW ANY HARM. AND
NOT THE CAGR HEAD. AFTER SIX
MONTHS THE THING BRUSHLESS
ADMITTED THEY HAD OVERLOOKED MY
MOM. HERE IN DETERMINES SURGERY
BUT IN FACT HOLDING- TO THE
FEDERAL ATTACK AGAINST WHAT
WERE BELIEVED BE HARDWORKING IN
FACTORED OUT TO BE A RARE
DISEASE- HI CHECK YOUR
COMPLETE. RIGHT THERE ARE HER
BODY FOR OVER WITHOUT ANYONE.
TO BY THE TIME THE DISEASES
THAT DISCOVERED IN JULY OF
TWENTY. MY MOM A FEW WEEKS TO
UNDERGO CHEMO AND THEREFORE DO
NOT HAVE A CHANCE AGAINST THE
DISEASE. OCTOBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY NINETEEN MY MOM LOST HER
LIFE I JUST SIXTY THREE YEARS
OLD BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HER HEALTH AND
WELL BEING IGNORED HER CRIES
FOR HELP. WHEN I FILE TO KEEP
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD MY
MOTHER CASE WAS DISMISSED WITH
NO INTERVIEW AND NO
COMMUNICATION PROTECT THE BASIC
FORM LETTER. MY MOTHER SEVEN
BRAIN TUMORS ARE LEFT
UNTREATED. INTENSELY DIAGNOSE
OKAY IN OUR PROVIDER ADMITTED
THAT THEY HAD OVERLOOKED YOUR
CANCER ON HOW ACCORDING TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD. TRANSLATED INTO
TREATMENT. WITHIN THE STANDARD
OF CARE. THE PUBLIC HAVE LAW
TRUST THE MEDICAL. AND I
BELIEVE THE FIRST STEP IN
MAKING PUBLIC TRUST IS BY
REFORM. THE AND A PUBLIC MEMBER
MITCHELL. THE MAJORITY BOARD ME
NO ATTEMPT YOU CAN MAKE I THINK
TO PROTECT. IT IS TIME TO
EXPAND THE BOARD DOING FEW.
PUBLIC MEMBER. I FAMILY WE NEED
A COW. THE FIRST IN THE COUNTED
FOR. BY MINE IF YOU I THINK THE
MICRA. AND THREE BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD INTO A DIFFERENT PUBLIC
BOARD MEMBER MAJORITY. THE ONLY
WAY WE CAN IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS BY HOLDING OUR
PROVIDERS. ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING YOUR TIME TODAY TO WITH
MY STORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO PRESENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WAITING ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE- IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
AT A MINIMUM. TWENTY COLORS
LEFT IN THE QUEUE. WE HAD A
TARGET TO- COMPLETION TIME HERE
ACTUALLY AT ONE O'CLOCK AND
I'VE OBTAINED AN EXTENSION TILL
TWO AND- THAT LEAVES US THIRTY
MINUTES LEFT TO DO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO AND THEY'RE AND DEADLY
MAYBE MORE CALLERS WHO JOINED
THE LINE SO. I'M NOT GOING TO
BELABOR THIS WHAT I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU TO DO IS TO TRY TO.
SHORTEN YOUR COMMENTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN OF. PROVIDING
SUGGESTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
SPECIFIC- CHANGES AS PART OF
THE SUNSET PROCESS PERHAPS YOU
COULD ADOPT THE COMMENTS OF ONE
OF THE PRAYER CALLERS IF YOU
WILL. SO MODERATOR NEXT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU TO OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS BILLY
EARLY I AM A NATIONAL ADVISER
FOR BLACK DOCTORS MATTER
NATIONAL ADVISOR FOR THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE ADVOCATE FOR
THE WORLD TO COASTAL
FEDERATION. I'M A CONTRIBUTING
MEMBER FOR DOCTORS COURAGE AND
MUST ASSISTANT HEALTHCARE
ADVOCATE AND FORMER PRINT.
ANALYST BRIEFING PANELISTS IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ON DOJ
CORRECT. UP OF ALL I WOULD LIKE
THE MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT I
THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
ESTABLISH A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO UNDERSTANDING. WHAT
IS REALLY GOING ON WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE DATE
THAT THE MONEY PROVIDES THAT
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOCTORS ARE
INVESTIGATING EACH YEAR I
MEDICAL BOARDING THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. HOWEVER THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO REFERENCE TO HOW
MANY FOR STATE POLICE OFFICERS.
PROSECUTORS ARE UNDER
GOVERNMENT POLICE ARE
INVESTIGATING- I HAVE THE
ANSWER I BELIEVE THERE ARE THIS
IS THE COMMONSENSE QUESTION TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND OUR RESPONSE
IMAGINE THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED
OVER ONE MILLION INVESTIGATIONS
A YEAR BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE DOJ AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
THESE ARE TWENTY ONE AGENCIES
ALL THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND
ALLEGEDLY. THERE'S NONE OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVED
STATE POLICE THE- JERRY HARPER
MEDICAL BOARD MISCONDUCT THEIR
EMPLOYEE. THIS IS- BASICALLY
GET TRAPPED BY THE COMMITTEE
AND- TO WRAP IT UP- YOU KNOW
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS ALREADY
HOW. THAT THEY WILL NOT
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS MADE. BY
THE PUBLIC. AND IT'S WRITTEN I
HAVE NOT I WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE A TO THE BOARD. I WOULD
ALSO TO- ACTS THE BOARD TO
CONSIDER A REVIEW COME. OR BY
DOCTORS BLACK PATIENTS BECAUSE
THE PACE. STOCK RELATIONSHIP
THIS CALL. THEY CAN. BY DR ARE.
LOW NUMBERS IT WHICH RESPOND TO
RECORD. AND THIS ALL NEEDS TO.
THIS FOUR THIS GROUP HAS A
POWER TO HELP BLACK DOCTORS IN
FACT A- YOU KNOW. AGAIN AND
BUILD THAT RELATIONSHIP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR DENTURE
CONCLU. STOCK MARKET CLOSED I
WOULD TO SET UP TO TWO YEARS
PLEASE STOP AND I WOULDN'T BUT
PLEASE HAVE GIVEN OUR TIME CAN
IMAGE WRITTEN SUBMIT ARE
APPRECIATED ANY. OF THE COLOR
ON THE LINE NECK PLEASE. THANK
YOU FORTY THREE THREE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HELLO- NINETY IS HAN AND
I'M A PHYSICIAN COLOR- A CO
DIRECTOR OF THE PATIENTS MATTER.
BY THE ONE THREE SO BETWEEN THE
MEDICAL THAT ENOUGH LENGTH AND
THAT THE COST TO RICA TO. THAT
THE POSITION I AM TO TELL YOU
THE REASON WHY. IT IS BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT AT THE- FRIENDS OF
THE BOARD THE MAN BOARD IS
BEING THAT YOU TO TARGET
POSITION TREAT PATIENTS OF. I'M
THE ONLY PERSON TODAY WHO IS.
BLACK DOUBLE. THAT BLACKIE AT
THE A LICENSE BUSINESS. COULD
NOT CALIFORNIA. AND. THE WINNER
OF MULTIPLE CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWSUIT TO DEFER JURORS.
UNFORTUNATELY AT THE TIME I'D
LIKE WHICH WAS REVOKED. I WAS
ALSO WITH A- I AM HERE TO YOU
THAT- AT LEAST EARLY STATE
THERE IS A DEAL OF.
AGUIAR-CURRY WHAT HAPPENED
MIGHT WITH THE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I WAS LOOKING AT HOT
IN. I COMPLAINED THE STATED
THAT I ACTING ODD STRANGE
MEDICAL BY IN THE- I. SAID
ORDER BASED ON THE THAT. ACT
THOUGHT I'D THEIR LIKE HIGH
STATED THERE'S NO MAN ILL BUT
THE MEDICAL BOARD ALL DAY TIME
AND TIME. TWO WE MIGHT AND THE-
THEN I FILED A FEDERAL CIVIL
RIGHTS LAW IT'S STILL ON. GEN
TWENTY EIGHT. AND DURING THAT.
BE REVOKED BY LAW AND AWAITING
DID IT WAS VERY OF WELL ILLEGAL
AND. DEGREE FROM. REFERENCE TO
OFFER YOU. FIRST AND FOR. HE TO
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE MOTHER
BOARD THAT HAVE CIGNA WORKING.
IN PROMOTING RACIAL THE AND
RELIGIOUS HOLIDAY. SO DR KRAUSE
WHO I KNOW QUITE WELL DO YOU-
WOULD YOU GATHER AT THAT EVEN
SEVERAL AS A FORMER MEMBER THIS
YEAR. AND OTHER GOOD. I DON'T
DOUBT HEBREW AND AM I THE
RESUMES AB DE WALKED. IF YOU
READ REALLY. AT SOME WHO OF.
AVOID ANY TYPE OF. ARE IN
RELATION TO RACIAL DIVIDE IN
THE BUDGET TOLERANCE WE CANNOT
HAVE THAT INDICATED CAL.
GRANTED YOU KNOW PEOPLE THE
MEDICAL THEIR STAR ITS NOT JUST.
OUR TARGET IS ALSO LAW. ABOUT
DOCTOR WHO DOCTOR ON FOR. GIVEN
ART CONSTRAINTS WE DON'T HAVE
TIME FOR LAW- PRESENTATION. I
WOULD SUGGEST YOU GET TO POINT
FOR THE FALCONS THIRTY OKAY SO
THE SOLUTION IS NOT THAT- THAT
MEDICAL X. THEY HAVE A MEDICAL
THEY HAD BE SENSITIVE PRACTICE
RESONATE BUT- THE RESUME. THE
AND THEN NOT- HAVE ANY OF
WORKING. IN RACIAL TO. OF
TOLERANCE SO IT'S BE FOR GOOD
FOR THAT IN HEALTH DIVERSE AT
THE ALL WE NEED TO REPORT.
REQUIRE NOT A EXPERTS IN OUR
COULD. TO DO THE KIND OF
DIVERSITY TRAINING IT DOESN'T
IT DOESN'T WORK NOWWE SHOULD
HAVE THEM RE. TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPERIENCE YOU
KNOW THEM GOING ON AND I T. ON
THAT VERY IMPRESSIVE BUT- WHAT
IS THE TELEPHONE IF DON'T TO
GIVE WORKING. IMAGE OF THE
RELIGIOUS HOW AND LGBT Q.
pTHANK YOU THANK YOU DR. BUT
RETURN NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU
LINE SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND OTHER PEAK MY
NAME IS THE MARKET I'M IN THE
RING ROOM READ OF THIS IF YOU A
MEDICAL. I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
THE CENTER PROCESS FOR THAT PTL
TO THE CORPORATE FOR THAT. I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
UNION SEIU DAY ARBOR READ OF
THIS. CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY TO
RAISE CONCERN ABOUT IN OF TH
POSTER TRAINING LIKE
CONSERVATIVE. ON MY AM
CELEBRATE TO THIS- WE ASSIST
GOING TO HELP PEOPLE IN THE PPO
HAVE BEEN FOR HER PATIENTS
ACCESS TO CARE. ESPECIALLY TO
THE TIME THE OF THE- PRESIDENT
JUST ONE YOUR ABOUT ME HAVING
UNDER STRICT LICENSE AND MUCH
OF THEIR FREAK TO COMMUTE
CLINICS. AND HOSPITALS HOPING
OUR MOST MORE AND GAINING VALUE
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
MEDICATIONS SIR I AND MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES- YEAH. WE'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING THIS WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING THIS IS UP THE
NEXT HEARING SON. RIDGE OVER.
HEARING OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND THAT HEARING WILL COVER
LICENSING IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
ISSUES. INCLUDING THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE THAT YOU'RE ADDRESSING
SO. WHAT I WOULD ASK YOU TO DO
IS READ VISIT US AT OUR NEXT
HEARING WORRIED THAT THAT ISSUE
WILL BECOME. A MORE RELEVANT TO
THE TESTIMONY IN THE
PRESENTATIONS IS THAT OKAY.
PERFECT YES THANK YOU SORRY
ABOUT THAT WHAT DO YOU KNOW
WHEN THAT WOULD BE. WE'LL IF
YOU'LL CONTACT MY- THE
CONSULTANTS OF EITHER
COMMITTEE- WITH THEY WILL BRIEF
YOU ON THE TIMING AND MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE A COPY OF THE AGENDA
OKAY. PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR MODERATOR
NEXT. THANK YOU LINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE
PROCEED HERE ME GETS PLEASE
PERCENT HI. OKAY MY NAME IS-
TRACY DOMINGUEZ. I AM FROM
BAKERSFIELD I AM WITH THE
SENATE FOR INJURED PATIENTS
THAT. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
BIXEL. WHO HAVE SHOWN SUPPORT
FOR KERN COUNTY MOTHER CINDY.
MY DAUGHTER WAS HEALTH. I AM
HONORED MODERN HER PREGNANCY
CLOSELY. SHE WAS STILL TO
ATTEND COLLEGE GRADUATION. BUT
SHE NEVER GOT TO WEAR HER CAP
AND GOWN. EXCEPT FOR TO CREATE.
BECAUSE SHE DIED DUE TO MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE ONE MONTH BEFORE HER
COLLEGE GRADUATION. RIGHT RIGHT
HAD A HEALTHY. UNTIL IT STRANGE
WELL INTERNET A CONDITION. WELL
MY DAUGHTER COULDN'T BREATHE.
SHE HAD VISION PROBLEMS PROTEIN
IN HER URINE AND BLOOD PRESSURE
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE. SHE HAD
EVERY SIGN A PRE CRAPPIE. BUT
THOSE WERE IGNORED BY TWO
DOCTORS. SHE TRIED SO HARD TO
GET HELP FOR HER- AND FORMS
THAT. BUT HER DOCTORS WOULD NOT
HELP HER. SHE WAS IN TROUBLE.
BUT HER REGULAR OBGYN WOULD NOT
SEE- HELLO. SHE WENT TO THE
LOCAL HOSPITAL IN NEED OF CARE.
FOR HERSELF AND HER UNBORN SON.
WHAT SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THAT
THE HOSPITAL ON CALL DOCTOR
WHAT THE REPEAT OFFENDER THAT
THE MEDICAL BOARD ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE KNOWING
THAT HE WAS GOING TO DEATH OF
SIX. MOTHER AND BABIES. THEY
WERE NOT ONLY HIS VICTIM
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF VICTIM
WITH A CLEAR PATTERN OF
DAUGHTER'S DEATH. WE HAVE BEEN
DISCOURAGED FROM FILING
COMPLAINTS. WE HAD AN
INVESTIGATOR COME TO MY HOME
WITHOUT WARNING BEFORE WE EVEN
FILED A COMPLAINT. WE HAVE BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY AN INVESTIGATOR
INTEGRATE TAKE RATED BY MAKING
US FEEL LIKE WE DID SOMETHING
WRONG. WHEN WE WERE FINALLY
ABLE TO PREPARE OUR COMPLAINT.
WE WERE DISCOURAGED FROM DOING
SO. DOING SO TELLING US THAT WE
ALREADY HAD BEEN INTERVIEWED
WELL WE WERE INTERVIEWED
WITHOUT. EVEN GOING THROUGH THE
MEDICAL RECORDS WITHOUT PREPARE.
GRACIA WE CAME FOR WITH NEW
INFORMATION AND WE HAVE TO
FIGHT IT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
TO GET IT TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
TO ACCEPT OUR NEW INFORMATION.
I HAVE. I LEARNED THAT ONE OF
HER DOCTORS HAD BEEN HARMING
MOTHERS AND BABIES THE
BAKERSFIELD FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. SADLY SHE HAD.
PREVIOUSLY CHANGED WILL BE WHAT
SHE HAD LEARNED THAT HER PRIOR
DOCTOR HAD BEEN DISCIPLINED FOR
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. SEARCHING
FOR NEVER HEALTHCARE SHE
CHANGED DOCTORS ONLY TO DIE AT
THE HANDS OF ANOTHER DANGEROUS
DR. THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS NO
VALUE FOR MOTHERS BY. HOW COULD
THE MEDICAL BOARD JUSTIFY
ALLOWING A DOCTOR. TO CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE KNOWING HE IS
LINKED TO DEATH OF THE BABY.
AND HARMING WOMEN FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS THE POOR KEEP
OFFERING HIM PROBATION HOW MANY
MOTHERS WILL HAVE TO DIE BEFORE
THAT MEDICAL COURT REVOKED HIS
LICENSE. THE MEDICAL BOARD'S MY
DAUGHTER AND MANY OTHER YOUNG
MOTHERS AND BABIES. CURRENT
SYSTEM IS BROKE IN. WE NEED A
CHANGE AND I BELIEVE A PUBLIC
BOARD MEMBER MAJORITY IS THAT
CHANGE WE NEED. STARTING POINT
TO REBUILDTHE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN THE BOARD THAT
PUTS THE LIKELIHOOD OF DOCTOR.
WHERE ARE YOU LIFE. WHAT THE
MICHAEL CAPTAIN PLACE AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR FAMILY
PLEASE FILE COMPLAINTS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD. IF I KNOW
ACCOUNTABLE THERE EITHER. HI
BLAME THE MEDICAL CORK WITH THE
DEATH OF MY DAUGHTER AND
GRANDSON. IT IS THE BOARD'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE A CLEAR
PATTERN OF EXTREME NEGLIGENCE.
AFFECTED MOTHERS AND BABIES
WHERE ELSE CAN SOMEONE BE
LINKED TO THE DEATHS OF SIX
PEOPLE AND BE PRETTY ON
PROBATION. THE MEDICAL BOARD
KEEPS GIVING HIM HER PROBATION
AND PROTECTING THE DOCTOR OVER
PATIENT FRAZIER. IT IS NOW THE
TRYING TO OVERHAUL THE MEDICAL
CORPS. IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
WILL TO DO IT. SO BAD THAT THE
BOARD. YOU DID NOT PROTECT MY
DAUGHTER. YOU TO MY DAUGHTER'S
FUTURE AWAY FROM HER FAMILY.
YEAH IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MEMBER VERY SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS I KNOW IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO TALK ABOUT BUT I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THATWE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
MODERATOR. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK MY NAME IS ALL GARY
AND I'M COMPARISON. THE
REPRESENTATIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHILIP TANG IT'S A MEMBER OF
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE I AM A VOLUNTEER WITH
THE FAIRNESS FOR INJURED
PATIENTS ACT CAMPAIGN AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE HOW THE
MEDICAL BOARD FAILED MY SISTER
AND OUR FAMILY. I BELIEVE HER
FORM IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
RESTORE THE. PUBLIC'S TRUST IN
THE MEDICAL BOARD. I LOVE MY
SISTER CHAU BY TO MEDICAL
MEDICAL. ANESTHESIA ERR AT AGE
FORTY THREE. DESTROYED MY
SISTER'S ONE. WE REQUIRING A
DOUBLE LINE RAMPS- PHYSICIAN
WAITED TOO LONG TO LIST HER FOR
A LONG TRANSPLANT. AND SHE DIED
JUST ONE MONTH AFTER HER
ELECTION. SHE NEVER RECEIVED A
LONG TRANSPLANT- GAS ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE. MY REPRESENTED OUR
FAMILY FROM HOLDING THE
PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITALS
ACCOUNTABLE AFTER HER DEATH LET
ME TURN TO THE MEDICAL BOARD IN
THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
WITHIN WEEKS OF FILING A
COMPLAINT THE MEDICAL BOARD
DISMISSED ARE COMPLETE WITHOUT
ACTION THERE WERE NO INTERVIEWS
THAT ASKED FOR THE POSITION.
EVIDENCE OUTSIDE. OF THE
MEDICAL RECORDS WOULD NOT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC. MADE A
FASTER QUICKER TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD BUT THERE WAS NO FOLLOW
UP I EVEN REACHED OUT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICE AND AGAIN NO RESPONSE.
EVENTUALLY AFTER MUCH
PERSISTENCE I SPOKE WITH THE
COORDINATOR AT THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO CONFIRM THERE ARE NO
REVIEWS AND LOTS OF COMPLAINTS
ESCALATE HAPPEN NATIONALLY DO
WHICH IS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE. HIS VISION FOR
GIVEN OPTIONAL QUESTIONNAIRE TO
COMPLETE AND DO YOU EVER DO.
ONLY THE MEDIC RECORD IS VERY
CUTE. EMAIL VOICE OR EVEN
PATIENT NOTES ARE NOT RUBIO.
THERE IS NO APPEAL PROCESS
AFTER COMPLAINTS DOES NOT. I
DON'T BELIEVE THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S CURRENT INVESTIGATION
PROCESSES ADEQUATE. SHOP
COMMITTEE CALLED INVESTIGATION
WITHOUT A SINGLE INTERVIEW
WITHOUT A REVIEW OF ALL RECORD
AND WITHOUT ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BACK. BY REFUSING TO REVIEW
EVIDENCE OUTSIDE OF THE MEDICAL
RECORDS THE MEDICAL COURT
DEMONSTRATES A BIAS IN FAVOR OF
PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITAL. IT
ISN'T SURPRISING THAT THE
PUBLIC COULD BLOCK STATE IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD AT THE OVERSIGHT
BODY. WE CANNOT TO STATUS QUO
THE MEDICAL BOARD. WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT FOR MORE
LIFE ARE LOST MEDICAL. THANK
YOU. FOR YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
MODERATE NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT. OVERLYING FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MONTARA RON IS AND I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M THE CAFE OPEN
PATIENT SAFETY ADVOCATE
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND I WORK
WITH FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHO'S BEEN HARMED
BY MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE. I BECAME
STATEWIDE AND NATIONAL.
FOLLOWING THE TRAGIC DEATH OF
MY HUSBAND TO BE LIKE MONSTER
DOT. LOGIN TO THE LOS ANGELES
PUBLIC RESEARCH AND DIED THREE
DAYS LATER WHEN YOUR CAR GIVE
ME FOR STAFF. I HAD A LARGE AN
INVESTIGATION ON MY- TWO
CORNERS REPORT CONCLUDED THAT
LLOYD DIED FROM SURGICAL ERRORS
AND UNTREATED SURGICAL SITE
INFECTION AND SEPTIC SHOCK. I
ALSO DISCOVERED THAT LLOYD
SERGENT HAD A LONGER REST
RECORD FOR POSSESSION OF CRACK.
COCAINE AND PROSECUTION. THEY
WERE OTHER VICTIMS OF WELL.
WHAT HE YOU NEED FOR THAT I
WANT TO MAKE BOARD WHERE. IN
SEARCH IN FOR ONLINE DOCTOR.
BUT IT'S PROFILE WITH CLEAN.
WE'RE HEADING FOR ON WHICH
THIRD. THAT HE DID NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW. THIS BACK TREND.
POSSIBLE HIS. I CAN'T ENOUGH
HOW CREDIT GUESTBOOK. YES MY
MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE OR DEATH
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
IS TO COPE WITH. ONE FAMILY
SEEK ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUSTICE
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD WE CAN
FIND OUT THERE IS NONE THERE
WAS NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
LAKE HE DIED TRAGICALLY AT THE
MEDICAL BOARD FOUND HIS DEATH
NOT WORTHY OF INVESTIGATION HIS.
WAS DISMISSED AT THE CENTRAL
COMPLAINING IT WOULD NO
INTERVIEW NO OPPORTUNITY TO
CHALLENGE. IT NOTHING. I ALSO
THINK THE LACK OF ACCOUNT DUE
TO MY CAP FORTY SIX YEARS AGO
WHEN THE LEAD. ND THE CAP.
EXACTLY THE TEACHER I FOR HARM
DONE BY. THE MEDICAL BOARD HOW.
WERE ON HAND WITH PROMISE THAT
THE BOARD WOULD FILL IN THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY GAP. GAP COMICS
WAS NEVER REALIZED. THIS IS NOT
MY FIRST SENT THAT REVIEW AND
IT IS NOT CONSUMER WATCHDOGS
FOR EXTENSIVE REVIEW FOR
DECADES WE'LL WATCH THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE CHANGES AROUND
THE MARGINS. THANK YOU THE
MEDICAL BOARD ANOTHER FOUR
YEARS WITH A PROMISE TO CHANGE
YES THE SAME VALUES CONTINUE.
IT IS TIME FOR A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL. OF THE BOARDS. IF YOU
DIE ANYWHERE IN. YEAH BE IN THE-
YET WHEN I LOW WHEN YOU DIE AT
THE HAND OF THE DOCK. THE MAJOR
OF THE JEFF. WHITE LLOYD'S ARE
NEVER DOUBT. I WORK WITH MANY
OF THE FAMILIES YOUR HEARING ON
EVERY SINGLE DAY. WE NEED YOU
TO COME. AMERICANS AND OUR SAN.
THAT YOU'LL HOW THIS FOR AND
TRULY NEED CONSUMER. PARAMOUNT
THANK YOU. OKAY SO VERY MUCH OF
HERE'S THE BATTING ORDER NEXT.
WE HAVE. INDIVIDUALS STILL IN
THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE LINE
Q. THERE MAY BE MORE. WE HAVE
TEN MINUTES TO GO TILL TWO PM-
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE-
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FUTURE TRY
TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE BECAUSE FOR EVERY MINUTE
OVER THAT. YOU USE YOU MAY BE
CUTTING OFF SOMEONE ELSE AT THE
END OF THE QUEUE WHO MAY OR MAY
NOT BE ABLE. TO COMMENT SO
LET'S TRY TO WILL LIMIT
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO YOU SHOULD GO AHEAD.
NEXT MODERATOR. BY TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU- AND I DO WANT MY
TIME TO SPEAK BECAUSE HE GAVE
THE MEDICAL BOARD AT TIME TO
TELL THEIR LIVES I DIDN'T WANT
TO START ON A CONTENTIOUS
MOMENT BUT- I'VE BEEN HEALTH
FOUND FOR ME IN A PLACE CALLED
FOR OVER NINE YEARS. AND I
THINK THAT I DESERVE A CHANCE.
TO SPEAK. MORE THAN THE MEDICAL
BOARD. MY FATHER WAS A HIGHLY
REGARDED ETHICAL. AND
RESEARCHER WHO WROTE MULTIPLE
PAPERS THAT BETTERED MEDICAL
CARE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
AND THIS FIELD IN CALIFORNIA IS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
I GREW UP WITH MY OWN CAREER
WAS OF THE PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL THERAPIST. A
GROUNDED SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE
UNTIL FALL BURGER SURGICALLY
BATTERED ME NOW I'M IN A LIVING
HELL AND AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. SO HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
MY DOCTOR REFERRED ME TO FALL
BURGER FOR CONSERVATIVE FRENCH.
CHECK REASONS I REALLY THAT I
TO RUSH TO THE PHONE THE WAY IT
IS NOT OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
SHOULD'VE DONE IT MAKE MORE
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. THIS
IS HUGE. THE ANYWAY. M. O.
MEXICAN MA'AM HELLO. MAKE A
SUGGESTION INSTEAD OF ON THE
PROCESS ERE DON'T YOU GO ON
YOUR STAY AND SEE HOW LONG WE
CAN FOR WE CAN GET THROUGH OKAY.
YEAH BUT I FEEL LIKE I'M
LETTING OTHER PEOPLE. DO NOT
COME AT THE END AND IF YOU PUT
ME IN A BAD PLACE. INCREDIBLE
PHYSICAL PAIN. MEMBERS OF THE-
HAD THEM LET ME WORRY ABOUT
THE- LINE IN THE QUEUE I JUST
ASK. PUBLIC COMMENT. CALLERS TO
TRY TO LIMIT THEIR- I MAKE IT
MY PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN
EXPERIMENT INCREDIBLE PHYSICAL
PAIN TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN.
BURGER AMBULATORY CENTER
PRESENTED A FLICK THE SIDE
WALLS WITH CERTIFICATES WHICH
IMBUES THE BELIEF I LIVE IN A
SAFE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT HIS
CREDENTIALS CHECKED OUT BE A
MEDICAL BOARD I TRUSTED THESE
DOCTORS UNTIL BURGER
EGREGIOUSLY INSULTED ME. MOYERS
AND OTHERS SAY IT LOOKS LIKE A
DOCTOR AMENDOLA'S JOB I THANK
YOU A TEN SECOND VIDEO WHICH
ILLUSTRATES THE UNDENIABLE TALK
TO THE BURGER GET BY THE WAY
I'VE BEEN SPENDING ALL OF YOUR
OFFICERS THAT THE VIDEO AND
INFORMATION FOR ALL THESE YEARS
NO ONE IS HELP YET. BERMAN LEFT
ME EXCESSIVELY BLOODIED IN
INTRACTABLE PAIN UNABLE TO
SUPPORT MYSELF A COMPLETE TASK
DAILY LIFE I COULDN'T EVEN
DRIVE TO GET HELP AND THE
REFERRING DOCTOR COLLUDED WITH
BURGER SHE WOULDN'T EVEN PUT ME
IN A COUNTY EXAMINE ME WHAT
BURGER DID WAS BRUTAL AND BILE
NOT THERE. AFTER HIS LIKE
DESTROYING ASSAULT YOU LIED TO
COVER UP IN SOUTH WHICH COST ME
MORE MEDICAL HARM UNBELIEVABLY
THE MEDICAL BOARD FOR THE LIFE
OF HIM I FILED A MEDICAL
COMPLAINT AGAINST BURGER FOR
ASSAULT. NEGLIGENCE AND FRAUD
IT'S PAST THE INITIAL.
INTERVIEW WHICH WAS REALLY
NOTHING FROM COMING IN MY
LIVING ROOM THE DOCTOR WROTE MY
DOCTOR WROTE TO THE BOARD ABOUT
HOW I'VE BEEN SCARRED FOR LIFE.
FIFTY GET PERMANENTLY CONSTANT
PAIN- CHINA RUSHED THIS-
BECAUSE OF THE OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE AND I'M CONTENTED
SURGICAL PROCEDURES THE DOCTOR
BURGER PERFORMED THIS
CONSTITUTES SURGICAL ASSAULT
THERE ARE OTHER. DOCTORS AND
EXPERTS WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
INTENSIFIED THAT HE'S M. EVERY
OF THE DAMAGES NOT BEEN A
CHANGE THE DID NOT MY CASE. OF
ALL THE ALL. APRIL TWENTY FOUR
TWO THOUSAND AND- IT'S NOT COMP.
THE BOARD REACHED OUT TO MY OWN
DOCTOR. I PROVIDE PLENTY OF
CLEARING. IT'S A- SURGICAL
CUTTING BODILY IS A OF THE
STATE CARE CRISTINA DEL D. O.
EAT URGED ME TO TAKE THE CASE
TO THE POLICE AND THE- BUT WHAT
COURSE SAID MET BACK IS OUTSIDE
THEIR PER. UNLESS THE MEDIC
BOARD TELL TO END. SINCE THE
MEDICAL BOARD DOESN'T DO REAL
AND- PUTS DOCTORS A FALL ABOUT
THE LAW AND CAL SEPARATELY IT I
FEEL THE TO CONSUME AFFAIRS
WHICH BY WAS BY TWO PURCHASE
WHO HAD GAS LET ME. DCA IS
STILL THE FRAUD IN LANDER
BURGER IS NOT JUST THE APPLE
BUT STILL BEFORE I ADVERTISING
AGENCY OF FINANCIAL UNTRUTHFUL
AND DOCTOR LOBBY THE BOARD SO
AGAINST PATIENTS STATE OF THE
FOR HAS I'M GOING THING OF
BECAUSE FOR BAPTIST. IT'S
COMPLETELY OFF BASE BECAUSE
LIKE AND OTHER PROCEDURES THERE
ARE SCAMMING AND THERE TO FIVE
PROVEN TO BE. AND LYFT INSURED
MAKE STATE THAT BIOLOGY ABOUT
BASE NATURE KARPLUS AND UP THIS
ISN'T EVEN THAT AT THAT THE
STOCK CAN TALK HE SAID STATES
LIKE HELL HAS PASSED LIKE LIKE
A SECULAR BASED ON A- THERE'S
NO DOUBT OF THE IT NO SCIENCE
THE L. BY THE WAY TO PRESS. THE
L. A. CORNER LISTED WHO DIED
WITH IS. THEY WANT THEY WANT
CHANGES IN THE BODY OF THEIR
RIGHT TO GET THEM BUT HUNDREDS
OF WOMEN I KNOW. AND THOUSANDS
OF REVIEWS ON NINE ELEVEN
HEALTH DOWN STUDY ENOUGH FOR
NINE YEARS. THAT THEY WERE LIED
TO AND HARMED BY PLASTIC
SURGEONS THE COMMON WISHES THAT
SHE HAD A TIME. TO GET A GOOD
LIFE BASS THE OTHER THE FACT
ROBERT. HE HAD TO WIN THE
DINERS GREECE. OTHERS YOUR
COMPLAINT TWELVE MEDICAL MOUNT
BY THAT- I. DR KENNETH CAME
BEFORE THE BOARD ON TWO COUNTS
OF. DEATH IN MAY THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THE MEDICAL BOARD SO
THEIR OWN EXPERT WAS HOOKED UP.
AND LA PROFUSELY THE CASES WERE
DRY. LORD FAILING WELL YOU
DON'T WANT CASES DUE TO MY- HE
IF YOU GET TO TRY LIKE I DID.
REALIZE TO BE WITH DOCTORS IN
LAWYERS TO PROP. A PATIENT HARM
NOW REALITIES. SURGEON. THERE
YOU GO THANK YOU AND BURGER THE
TOPIC IN THE CAMPUS IS NOT A
SUFFICIENT MEDICAL BOARD
INVESTIGATION. THE MEDICAL
BOARD HIRES TO GROW AS AN
EXPERT NOW THIS EMPOWER HIM.
PRACTICE YOU SHOULD JUST READ
YOUR QUICK PREFERRED. I T. V.
AND LINE COURT IT'S LOS THE MET
FIELD OF CONTROL BY MONEY SO
PLAINTIFF LAWYERS TO GET THE
THAT BETWEEN NINE. NINE HUNDRED
A NIGHT NINTH WITH THE FULL GAG
SO THEY CAN PAID WALK AWAY IN
THE DOCK PROTECTED WHEN I WAS
BEGAN SERVE WITH LIMITED-
TRYING TO RIP. WHATEVER I CAN
HEAR- THERE'S A RUSH TO GET
MURDERS OFF THE STREET BUT NOT
SO WITH YOUR DEADLY DISABLING
DOCTORS WHO CALIFORNIA- AND
KEEPING MOST OKAY- SO MOSTLY. I
KNOW HOW DON'T BY MEN WORKING
EVERY KNOWS. THAT THE BORDER
GOING TO DO ANYTHING I WOULD
MUTILATED A LOT LOOKS LIKE A
MENTAL CASE THEY DID NOTHING
WHEN YOU DON'T WANT TO GO TO
MORE. AND ONE DOCTOR IN THE
BOARD SAYS CAN'T. EVERYONE THAT.
ANYWAY SO IT MY QUESTION WHERE
DOES ONE WERE. CALIFORNIA BUT
CHAO EIGHT OF THE- IN CASE THE
MET BOARD AND THE C. ACTIVE
CORRUPTLY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IS. HARD DISMISSIVE THE MAYOR
GAVE ASSAULT THESE. FACT TWENTY
FIVE YEAR. ACTIVE HERE AFTER
THE FALL REALLY THINK I
CONTACTED HIS OFFICE FOR YEARS
THEY DO NOTHING. BUT NEGLIGENCE
IN POWER THE BUTTE THERE'S AN
MEDICAL AND ROB PRIVACY THEIR
VOICE. NOW IF YOU CAN TO AND
THE DANGER DR. AND. TRYING TO
SKIP THE YOU WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FIRST OF ALL THE CLASS
CARE WHO WHO CRACKED CAMP
FEATURES LIKE BY. ENOUGH ARE
THE LAST PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
CALLED AS REVIEWERS ARE
EXPECTING FELLOW CASES THEY'RE
ALL COVERING EACH OTHER AND
THEY'RE ALL DOING THE DAM DOING
SO COMPETITIVE PERPETRATE THE
DUPLICITOUS BRANCH OF MEDICINE
CONSIDERING THAT RAPISTS IN A
SOFTER. DO NOT WRITE ABOUT
ABUSES IN THEIR NOTES LOOK INTO
A DOCTOR'S RECORDS BASELESS IF
YOU CLICK. THEIR HARD. PATIENT
CO AUTHORING THEIR RECORD
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT YOU. JUST
ABOUT EVERY WHO SUFFERED NO.
WILL TELL YOU THE RECORD WHAT
WHAT. THEY'RE WRONG. AND. ONLY
DOCTORS TO GET THINGS OFF
MEMBERS. FINISHING UP-
INITIALLY NOT I WOULD HAVE BY
THE BOARD WHAT THE AND NO
BEARING ON REALITY NOT JUST
SAMANTHA AND- IF YOU BOTH TO
ALLOW THE COURTS CONTINUE IT
LOOKS YOUR CHOI TO PARTICIPATE
IN PRIMED ONE AND I'M URGING
NOT KILL AND I WANT A BETTER
QUORUM YOU GET THANK THAT WILL
ACTUALLY PUT ASIAN I HAVE BEEN
THIS FOR YEARS NINETY A HALF
YEAR AND I WANT YOU. GIVE ME OH
WAIT BECAUSE EVERY OF YOU
EVERYONE YOUR OFFICES EXCEPT
THE NEW PEOPLE- I HAVE GOTTEN
MULTIPLE CALLS AND LETTERS FROM
ME AND YOU'VE DONE NOTHING LET.
ME MAKE IT. WHEN SOMEONE ELSE
WITH A MEMO ME MAKE IT. YOU OF
HAVE. MATERIAL WRITTEN. A IF
YOU WILL SAID YOUR STATE. WHICH
YOU OBVIOUSLY MUST HAVE. IF
YOU'RE SKIPPING THROUGH IF
YOU'LL SEND YOUR WRITTEN
STATEMENT AND DIRECTED TO ME
ROSS R. O. T. H. I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S A PART OF THE
RECORD OF THIS PROCEEDING AND
WILL BE COULD CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED. AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE SUN SITE SUNSET OVERSIGHT
PROCESS AND DETERMINE CHANGES-
AND PROCEDURES FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD MOVING FORWARD IN THE
FUTURE. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN WAITING AND- AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT OUR
INTERNET STE. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS ERIC ANDERSON THE
PATIENT SAFETY LEGAL MY DOCTOR
HAD FOUR MINUTES PREPARED WILL
BE DOWN TO TWO AND I HAD TO
THROW EVERYTHING OUT BECAUSE I
NEED TO ADDRESS SOME THINGS
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD LIE TO
YOU DURING THE CONFERENCE
PLEASE READ OUR REPORT THAT WE
SENT TO YOU EARLIER THIS WEEK.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT MR
PRESIDENT HAS FEELING BULLIED
BECAUSE THAT HELPS VICTIMS THE
FABRIC IT FEEL TREATED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD AT EVERY TURN AND
EVERY QUARTERLY MEETING THAT WE
ATTEND HE SAYS THE LOOKING TO
ANY SUGGESTIONS TO IMPROVE BUT
HE WON'T EVEN INTERACT WITH ME
REFUSING TO ANSWER MY EMAIL I
SENT THAT. THERE IS A MANDATE I
BURKE AT THE BOARD YOU NEVER
INTERACT WITH ME THEY DON'T
LIKE THAT I CAN USE THEIR OWN
WORDS TO PREPARE MORE. TALK
ABOUT THE MAN TECH CARRY
WEAPONS OFTEN QUICK TO SAY
THEY'RE NOT A LOT OF MONEY BUT
AS ANY DOCTOR WHO'S BEEN
RAILROADED BY THE BOARD AND TO
REPLICATION IF THEY DON'T THINK
THEY'RE BEING PUNISHED.
REGARDING YOUR EARLY QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE CON- CONTACT THE
COMPLAINANT THE BOARD NEVER
CONTACT THE COMPLAINANT UPON
RECEIVING A COMPLAINT AND I
HAVE EMAIL FROM THE NBP
EMPLOYEES STATING THAT IT IS
NOT THEIR POLICY TO DO SO WHICH
I CAN PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE. I
HAVE NEVER BEEN CONTACTED ON
ANY COMPLAINTS I FIND IN MY
SISTER'S DEATH CASE NOT ONLY
DID THEY NEVER CONTACT ME THEY
NEVER GOT A CERTIFIED COPY OF
HER MEDICAL RECORDS FROM THE
HOSPITAL AND THEY NEVER EVEN
BOTHER PRIVATE AUTOPSY REPORT
THEY JUST CLOSED THE COMPLAINT
OUTRIGHT. WHEN I DID A PUBLIC
RECORD REQUESTS TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE IF THEY
EXPERT WOULD EVEN QUALIFY BE
DENIED IT IN ITS ENTIRETY THEY
DIDN'T EVEN TRY TO GET AFTER.
REGARDING THE CASE THE GENERAL
ROB BROUGHT UP ABOUT DOCTOR
KLEIN MISTER PERCENT TRYING TO
PULL THE WOOL OVER YOUR EYES
INDEED THE NEW ABOUT THIS CASE
AS FAR BACK AS TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN AND LIKELY EARLIER AND
THAT INFORMATION IS EXPOSED IN
THE MERCURY NEWS ARTICLE OF
AUGUST TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT.
THE MEDICAL BOARD KNOWING ABOUT.
FRANK THE DEATH SEXUAL.
SUPPOSED TO TAKE PRECEDENCE.
YOU ARE ASKED ABOUT. FROM THE
GUY. IN SURE THE PLANE THE
PUBLIC THE- OFF THE NOT PUT
THAT IN FOR. IN DOCK AND THEY-
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT RAMP.
OFF DENYING WRITTEN. ALL RIGHT
INSTEAD OF READ. AND OR ONE
THING CHANGE. TARGET AMOUNT. TO
A TO MAKE THEIR- UNBEATABLE TO
THE RIVER- WHICH ISN'T.
DEFIANCE OF THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT. ONE THIRTIETH EMPLOYER K.
THE DOCTOR DANIEL. WHO THE
YOUNG MAN TO DEATH HE WAS
CHARGED WITH RAPE. NEGLIGENT
I'M PROFESSIONAL CON AND
FAILURE TO MAINTAIN ADEQUATE
ACCURATE RECORD. THE MINIMUM
ACCORDING TO THE GUIDELINES TO
FIVE YEARS PROBATION FOR JUST
ONE OF THOSE THINGS. HE ENDED
UP GETTING A PUBLIC REPRIMAND
AND THERE'S NO EXPLANATION IN
THE DECISION AS TO WHY THE.
GUIDELINE REPEATING IT FROM. SO
GOT A PUBLIC. WHEN SOMEONE DIED.
THIS DOCTRINE WENT ON TO PLAY
PEOPLE AND BROWN ABOUT THE LEAN.
DISCIPLINE BY THE FOR. DR PAN
THEY CAN'T EVEN DEAL WITH THAT
THE MEDIC CAN SERVER COMPLAINT
THAT THE DEBT LET ALONE GAMPER.
TO INITIATE BUT TO INITIATE
THEMSELVES. THEY DO NOT
INVESTIGATE AFTER FINDING OUT
ABOUT MALPRACTICE SETTLEMENTS
WE CAN PROVE IT WITH MULTIPLE
CASES IN OUR DATABASE. JANET
JONES WAS NOT TRUTHFUL WITH YOU
ON THAT THANK YOU SIR DR KRAUSE
SAID NEVER BEEN THERE. I
DISCUTER PARTIES WRAP IT UP WE
WE'VE. GOT A- WE'VE GOT.
SEVERAL OTHERS IN THE QUEUE AND
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AT TWO THIRTY
IS THE- PHONE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE LINE OF. OPERATORS
VENDORS ARE GOING TO PULL THE
PLUG ON THIS AND WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THE WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE- WITHOUT OF A FORUM SO
WOULD YOU OKAY I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT I WILL SEND YOU
THAT STUFF BUT YOU REALLY
SHOULD HAVE PLANNED FOR THAT
BECAUSE WE KNOW FROM PATHANKOT
REVIEWS THAT THE PUBLIC ALWAYS
TAKES A LONG TIME TO TALK TO
WORK FEELING A LITTLE BIT. BY
THAT FIGURE NOT ALL THANK YOU
ALLOWED THEM SO MUCH NINETY
THREE AND NOW YOU'RE CUTTING
ALL OF THE POSSIBLE I WILL
SPEND THE REST OF THE TEAM
BECAUSE I HAVE ENORMOUS AMOUNT
OF EVIDENCE THAT I CAN PROVE
ALMOST EVERYTHING WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD TOLD YOU GUYS DAY
WRONG THANK. YOU I TELL YOU
WHAT- MOST CHAIRS LIMIT PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ONE OR TWO MINUTES
AND I THINK YOU WILL AGREE IF
YOU'VE BEEN LISTENING THAT I AM
NOT ONE OF THOSE SO I WOULD ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP AND IF YOU HAVE
IT IN WRITING SUBMIT TO US AND
I'LL MAKE SURE TAT IT BECOMES
PART OF THE RECORD AND IS
CONSIDERED AS PART OF OUR
SUNSET OVERSIGHT. OF PROCESS.
BUT EVERYBODY READ THREE. THAT
WE SUBMITTED YOU ALL ON. ON
MONDAY BECAUSE IT'S NINETY FIVE
PAGES A VERY STRONG EVIDENCE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR WRITTEN
REPORTS OR NEXT MODERATOR.
THANK YOU I TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI I AM OFFERING
TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF KIMBERLY
ORTIZ GRANDMOTHER TO SELECT OR
KEEPS MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
ORGIES AND I AM THE BAKERSFIELD
I AM WITH THE FAIRNESS FOR
EDUCATION ACT AND MY
REPRESENTATIVES ARE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
MELISSA HER TADO. AND ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS
JUNIOR. MY GRANDDAUGHTER
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVERED HER
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER WITH NO
PROBLEMS. SHE WAS SO HAPPY TO
SEE HER BABY FOR THE FIRST TIME
BUT THEN THE UNTHINKABLE
HAPPENED IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
GIVING BIRTH AND WITH NO
CONSENT HER DOCTOR FORCIBLY
REMOVED A PLACENTA. FIRST BY
HAND THEN BY FORCE THAT AND
THEN AGAIN BY HAND. I COULD
HEAR MY GRANDDAUGHTERS
AGONIZING SCREAMS FROM DOWN THE
HALLWAY. WHILE FORCIBLY
REMOVING HER PLACENTA HE
PORTRAYED AT HER UTERUS AND
CERVIX MY GRANDDAUGHTER BLED TO
DEATH WELL THE NURSES BACKING A
DOCTOR TO HELP HER. HER DOCTOR
GAVE HER NO LIFESAVING SUPPORT.
HER VITALS COMMITTED WHILE SHE
DIED. WE WERE FACED WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF THE- PROGRESS MY
CRAFT WITH NO ACCOUNTABILITY IN
SIGHT WE WENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND FILED A COMPLAINT. MY
COMPLAINT WAS INVESTIGATED AND
I WAS TOLD THAT THIS REPEAT
OFFENDER DR. WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO A HEARING BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE. HE
HAD BEEN ON PROBATION BEFORE
FOR THE DEATHS OF TWO BABIES.
WHY ARE WE FELT THAT HE WOULD
FINALLY BE DISCIPLINED BUT THE
GROUND. FOR MY GRANDDAUGHTER'S
DEATH. BUT DID NOT HAVE. HE WAS
OFFERED A SETTLEMENT A PLEA
DEAL. THAT GAVE HIM PROBATION
ONCE AGAIN THE MEDICAL BOARD
REVIEW THAT THIS DOCTOR HAD
BEEN HARMING MOTHERS AND BABIES
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS. BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THEM TO
PRACTICE AND CONTINUE. TO HARM
OTHERS HOW THE MEDICAL BOARD
TAKEN ADVISES EARLIER A YOUNG
MOTHER AND BABY WHO DIED AFTER
MY GRANDDAUGHTER CELESTE. WOULD
BE HERE TODAY I AM DEVASTATED.
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS FAILING
OUR FAMILIES AND KERN COUNTY.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO HAVE
DOCTORS POLICE OTHER DOCTORS. I
BELIEVE THAT A PUBLIC BOARD
MEMBER MAJORITY IS OUR ONLY
HOPE FOR SOME PROTECTION. FOR
FAMILIES WE NEED ACTION NOW. WE
NEED A COMPLETE OVERHAUL OF THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS MY
GRANDDAUGHTER DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE. TO MAKE A CHANGE TO
SAVE ANOTHER MOTHER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TAKING THE TIME TO
PROVIDE THOSE VALUABLE
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SIXTY
EIGHT IS THAT ME. YES CLASS
PERSON I HAD. EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM AND I WANT TO START BY
SAYING FIRST AND FOREMOST DO NO
HARM. IT IS CLEAR TO ME THAT
THE GOVERNING BODY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD TOTALLY LOST
TRACK OF THE HIPPOCRATIC OATH
AND THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE EVEN
LIMITING CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
TELLING PERSONAL AND PAINFUL
STORIES. IN THE HEARING IS SUCH
AN INSULT. AND OFFENSIVE. NO WE
YOU COULD NOT STAY UNTIL FIVE
O'CLOCK EVEN AT MIDNIGHT TO
LISTEN TO CALIFORNIANS. YOU THE
PEOPLE. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME ACQUAINTED WITH AND
ATTEND THE BOARD MEETING OF THE
PERSON PRIOR TO THE WALK DOWN.
THEY SHOCKED ME I COULD NOT
BELIEVE THE INSTANCE OF THE
BATH AND SUFFERING WITH ZERO
ACCOUNTABILITY LISTENING TO THE
OF CHRONIC TODAY. THERE'S ONE
THING I AM SURE ALL. STORIES
AND SUFFERING. BY CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE ACCOUNTABILITY THE
CALIFORNIA MY BOARD IT IS GOING
TO MEET THE INJURY AND- IN.
THANK YOU. YOUR COMPLETE AND IT
AND YOU. YOU'RE ON THE-
LIMITING PEOPLE TO ONE TO CALL.
WELL. THE ONLY REMEMBER THIS I
WOULD IS. S. Q. I WOULD ASK YOU.
TO DR MODERATE NEXT. THANK
MODERATE NEXT. THANK YOU I TRY
FOURTH GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME WELL. CAN YOU GIVE ME FIVE
PERFECTLY LOVING PLEASED. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL ONE AND I AM
FROM CYCLE YOU. AT AGE FORTY
TWO I YOUR BY NEGATIVE DECISION.
THERE SHE MAY SECOND ME REPEAT
THE- ONE WAY FIVE OF THE VIEWS.
MORE ENSURE THAT A LOCAL. WITH
THIS THE HIRING. I FINDING HERE
CARE NEEDED. WHILE I HAVE YOU
LOOKING AT IT FOR THE OF MY
LIFE HI ELEVEN NINETY FIVE OF
COMPLAIN WHAT SHALE FIELD I
GREW. NORTH ASIAN NO I DON'T
THE NORCOM OF AB LAWSUIT BOARD.
NO RESPECT ONE OF THE YOUR FACE
ON THE COMMON. IF YOU HAVE ANY
ACTION EITHER LOOKING MOST HARD
EVEN USELESS LETTERS OF
REPRIMAND. WHY DO YOU ALSO IF
YOU EVER ENCOUNTER PROBATION
ALL SUSPENSIONS AND IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE IT IS NOT CERTAIN THAT
BOOKSTORES TO CLEAN THEMSELVES
WE KNOW ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE
PUBLIC. WHY EVEN THOSE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
THE MAJORITY OF THE MEDICAL
MORE BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW JONES MOVIES. LIKE
POLICEMEN HELLO THIS IN LAGOS
THE THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
OVERSEE. AB ALTHOUGH SENESCHAL
BUT THE COMPLAINT FOR OFFICE
DEPOT CONRAD I'M OPEN TO THE
PATIENT WE CLEAR TIMELINE ON
COMMUNICATION DURING THE
BIRTHING IS SHOWN DURING THE
MITIGATION PROCESS. BECAUSE IT
IS RIGHT NOW IF YOU COULD BE
SETTING UP A BLOCK VOTE OF
WHICH NOT SEEN RESENTMENT JUST
KEEPS GONZALEZ. NOT ONLY THAT
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PHYSICIAN BE PRESENT OR AT
LEAST CLOSE EITHER WAY HE'S
GOING TO KEEP AN EYE OUT SINC.
THE MOVIE IN A CRIMINAL TRIAL
NGUYEN TENDENCIES BECAUSE I
KNOW HOW HARD THAT HE HAD A
HOBBY PRESIDENT OF SUCH HEARING
ON GEORGIA HEALTH. HARD DIDN'T
NEED MIGHT WHILE WHOLE
APPLICATION GOALS BY AGES WE
JUST LANDED IN A RECORD. LAS
THERE SHOULD BE ON PART ALL
HUMAN FEEDING. THE HOUSE IS NOT.
WE GO ON LEGAL AUTHORITY. TO
ACT BEHALF OF THE ALL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN. EVERY AT THE
END OF THE LOOKING. THANK YOU.
WITHOUT ANY ASSESSMENT OR
CONSENT WHICH CAUSED TWO YEAH
THIS WAS TOTALLY PREVENTABLE.
AFTER I COMPLAINED TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE INVESTIGATOR
PROMISED AN ACCUSATION AND
CORPORATION FOR THE DOCTOR
OVERPRESCRIBED AND THEN
FALSIFIED A DO NOT RESUSCITATE
ORDER. LATER I RECEIVED A
LETTER THAT THE DOCTOR HAD BEEN
ALLOWED TO YOU DOWN TO A PUBLIC
LETTER OF REPRIMAND. IT TOOK
TWO OR THREE YEARS HELLO PLR.
ANOTHER DOCTOR IN MY FATHER'S
CASE JUST GOT A COLD
EDUCATIONAL LETTER OR SO I'M
TOLD. I APPEAL THE DECISION A
WARNING THAT THE DOCTOR COULD
HARM ANYBODY ELSE. HE WAS NOT.
JUST SIX WEEKS MY WARNING ONE
OF THE- PATIENT DIED FROM AN
OVERDOSE. THIS IS PAR OF THE
BOARD ONLY DEFINITELY SHOULD BE
PROJECT. THE DOCTOR WITH JUDGE
GIVEN THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
PROBATION AFTER THAT THE MENTAL
OF FIVE YEARS UNDER THE BOARD
OWN DID. GUIDELINES. IF THE-
HAD BEEN GIVEN FOR YEARS. THAT
GUIDELINE. RECOMMEND HE WILL
AHEAD TO NOTED HIS PATIENT BUT
THE- UNDER AT FOUR POINT. EIGHT
ADVOCATE I WOULD EVERY
DIFFERENT AND I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE GUY ARE REAL FOLLOWED.
BY HAPPEN THAT THEY ARE YOU
CLOSE TO THE RECORD. THIS YEAR
ALONE RECORD TO BE CHRIS
DECREASE BY A- BABIES WOMEN IN.
SETTLEMENT AND DRIVER THE LEFT.
ONE DOCTOR HAD PATIENTS YEAH
YEAH WHICH GIVEN YEARS. I THINK
THE MESSAGE DR OF THE BOARD
WILL ALSO HAVE THE BACK. IT
ALSO PEOPLE WHO WANT ONE AND
WELL COVERED FELT THAT THEY
DON'T. WHO ARE YOU TO CONTACTED
TO CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD. YOU SEE HOW IT
IS FAILING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S TIME CHANGES
WERE MADE AND FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE PEOPLE TO COME FIRST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM IN IT TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU HAVE THAT
WRITTEN DOWN I HOPE YOU WILL
SUBMIT YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS.
TO BOTH COMMITTEES SO WE CAN
MAKE THIS A MATTER OF THE
RECORD AND CONSIDER THIS DURING
OUR- FURTHER SUNSET TO. REVIEW
DELIBERATIONS WITH REGARD TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD. THANK YOU
AGAIN. MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY SEVEN FOUR
I HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS A
GREATER DELEON AND I'M FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I AM
WITH THE FURNITURE EDUCATION
BACK BY REPRESENTATIVES ARE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
MELISSA HURTADO AND ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS
UNION. I HELD MY SON UNTIL HE
TOOK HIS LAST BREATH. HE ONLY
LIVED FOR EIGHTEEN HOURS AND
DIED DUE TO MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE.
MY SON BOUGHT TO LIVE BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE BECAUSE THE
DOCTORS OVERSEEING HIS CARE
MADE ERROR AFTER ERROR. IN HIS
MEDICAL RECORDS THE DOCTORS
CLAIM THAT THEY TRANSFERRED MY
SON IMMEDIATELY TO THE NEXT
YEAR BUT THAT IS THE TRUTH.
WHEN I FIRST SAW MY SON HE WAS
IN A FULL SEASON ALONG WITH NO
DOCTOR SPENDING AND- MY SON WAS
ONLY TRANSFERRED TO THE NECK-YOU ONCE I WAS THERE. HOW COULD
ANY DOCTOR KNOWING MY SON
CONDITION LEAVE HIM UNATTENDED.
AND THE NEXT YEAR THE DOCTOR
WASTED TIME TRYING TO ENROLL
MALACHI INTO A CLINICAL TRIAL
INSTEAD OF IMMEDIATELY
AIRLIFTING AND FOR A HOSPITAL
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT YOU
NEED IT. THEY WAITED ALMOST
NINE HOURS TO TRANSFER MY SON
TO ANOTHER HOSPITAL AT THE
FOUGHT FOR HIS LIFE. AFTER MY
SON'S DEATH I LEARNED THAT ONE
OF HIS DOCTORS HAD LOTS
HOSPITAL PRIVILEGES FOLLOWING
THE DEATH OF ANOTHER PRODUCT.
FOLLOWING MY SON AND HIS
MOTHER'S DEATH THE SAME DOCTOR
ALSO LOST PRIVILEGES AT A
HOSPITAL LEAVING THE DOCTOR
WITH NO PRIVILEGES AT ANY
HOSPITAL IN THE MEDICAL BOARD
TOOK NO ACTION ON THIS DOCTOR
LOSING HOSPITAL PRIVILEGES.
WITHIN A LOT OF HOSPITAL
PRIVILEGES BORN A MEDICAL BOARD
INVESTIGATION. THE MEDICAL
BOARD IT'S FAILING FAMILIES I
BELIEVE A PUBLIC BOARD MAJID
MEMBER MAJORITY WILL PROVIDE A
MORE DIVERSE VOICES AT THE
MICRO CAP IS NOT PROVIDING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR FAMILY. WE
GO TO THE MEDICAL BOARD TO MAKE
THE DOCTORS ACCOUNTABLE BUT
THEIR FOCUS IS ON PROTECTING
DOCTORS OVER PATIENTS. I
BELIEVE THAT ADDING TWO STEPS
FOR FAMILIES IN THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS INCLUDING THE
INTERVIEWING THE FAMILY BEFORE
DISMISSING A COMPLAINT. AND
GIVING THE FAMILY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AFTER
THE POSITIONS INTERVIEW WILL
GIVE FAMILIES ABLE. CHANGE
NEEDS TO HAPPEN SO NO OTHER
FATHER IS FACED WITH LOSING HIS
FAMILY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO TESTIFY NEXT MODERATOR. I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DENISE
JOHNSON. I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE FAIR ENOUGH FOR INJURED
PATIENTS ACT CAMPAIGN AND IF
THE ISSUE WHEN SENATOR EGGMAN
INCREASED THE- I LOST MY TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD SON. THEBRAIN
CANCER SURVIVOR WHEN HE WAS
NEGLIGENTLY DENIED TREATMENT
FOR PNEUMONIA. I THOUGHT OUT
LOUD LEGAL COUNSEL BUT DUE TO
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE LAW
CAPPING DAMAGES THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO HOLD ANYONE
RESPONSIBLE. I WAS TOLD THAT MY
ONLY RECOURSE WOULD BE YOUR
FILE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD. I FILED SEVERAL
COMPLAINTS. THREE YEARS LATER
WILD BILL GRIEVING THE
UNEXPECTED LOSS OF MY SON I GOT
A PHONE CALL FROM A WOMAN WHO
SAID SHE WAS IN IT. HE WAS AN
INVESTIGATOR WITH THE STATE
MEDICAL BOARD IT WAS
INVESTIGATING MY KERN ST. AS
REQUESTED I EXPLAINED FOR MY
STORY. SHE GIGGLED AND LAUGHED
UNBELIEVING ONE. I WAS UNABLE
TO CONTINUE THE PHONE CALL
BECAUSE I WAS SO DISTURBED AND
UPSET THAT BY HER LACK OF
COMPASSION. BOB FIVE YEARS
AFTER MARK STONE YEAH I REPEAT
THE FIRST FOUR LETTERS OFFERING
THE SAME THING. THAT THEY'RE
GONNA DEFECATION WHICH CITED
QUOTE DIRECT OBSERVATION
INTERVIEWS AND DOCUMENTS
FINDING VIOLATIONS UNRELATED
ARTWORK ALLOCATE. AND QUOTE.
STATED THAT THEY WERE UNABLE TO
OUR HUMBLE OUR COME. INFLOWS HE
DID ON FAIRLY THEY WERE WITH
KNOWING THAT. I WOULD HAVE
YOU'RE NOT A BUT MADE
THROUGHOUT THE CARE MIGHT BURN
BUT AT CONFIDENCE OF THE-
MEDICAL BOARD WITH THEM STRONG
DEFENSE. BUT THE PATIENT AND OF
HUMAN LIFE. I WOULD CAREFULLY
RUN. IT WOULD KNOW IT THAT THE
NEW RESPONSIBLE REINFORCING IT
I REPEAT PERSONAL. EXCEPT WHEN
IN. IT'S INTERESTING PERSONAL
THE PHONE AN ADDITIONAL
COLDNESS FOR MORE OF THEIR FIVE
YEARS LATER. WHY PARENTS LIVE
DID NOT BEING THE MATTER
WHENEVER ONE THE BOARD ONLY
INSULT. I ACTED INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL OF PUBLIC
MEMBERS ON THE BOARD WE NEED A
STRONG ACCOUNT SYSTEM THAT
AFFECTED IT IN ITS INTERACTION
WITH FAMILY. THOROUGH IN ITS
INVESTIGATIONS UNTIMELY IN IT.
WE ALL DESERVE HIGH QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE BUT YOU CAN'T
POSSIBLE WITHOUT A STRONG.
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THEM. DO
YOU THE FORM THE RECORD THERE
PUBLIC IN OF PROTECTING DOCTORS
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY PHONE. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH YOUR TAKING THE TIME
TO PROVIDE IT TO US. MODERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU OF I
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHARLES JOHNSON AND I'M THE
CHAIRMAN. PATIENTS THAT PERSON
FOREMOST I WANTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THE
BRAVERY OF THE FAMILIES WHO
SHARED THEIR STORIES TODAY- IT
SIMPLY REMARKABLE- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD IS KILLING MOTHERS AND
BABIES MY WIFE HERE WHEN IN
FULL SUPPOSED TO BE A ROUTINE
COURTESY SECTION AT CEDAR SINAI
HOSPITAL APRIL FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. AND IN HOURS
SHE WAS ALLOWED TO PLEAD
INTERNALLY BY MYSELF MY FAMILY
BAG THE STAFF WITH YOUR SON OUR
HEALTH AND OUR CHRYSLER HEALTH
SOMEONE THAT. DR NINE WHO ONE
OF THE DOCTORS FOR MY WIFE'S
DEATH. AFTER AN INVESTIGATION
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD. THANKYOU BROWN'S MOSTLY
NEGLIGENT CAN CURE THAT. SHE
WAS FOUND RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
NEAR MISS DATA. OF FIVE OTHER
WOMEN. FOUR OF WHICH TOOK PLACE
WITHIN A THREE MONTH TIME SPAN
OF MY WIFE'S THAT. WOULD YOU
SPEAK UP A LITTLE LOUDER I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HEAR YOU.
ABSOLUTELY CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
IT'S BETTER PLEASE EMOTE OR
WHATEVER THE WORD IS THANK YOU.
OKAY SO MANY CLEARLY CHARACTER
MEET THAT. DR NINETEEN WOULD
NOW BE FOUND WILL BE NEGLIGENT
IN MY WIFE THAT HE WAS FOUND
NEGLIGENT IN THE DEATH OF FIVE
OTHER WOMEN THREE OF WHICH TOOK
PLACE IN A- THREE MONTH TIME
SPAN OF MY WIFE THAT. IT WAS
ONLY GIVEN FOUR YEARS PROBATION.
FOUR YEARS PROBATION WHICH IS
FAR BELOW THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD MINIMUM STANDARDS
AND GUIDELINES. AND WHILE I'M
GLAD. THIS MAN HAS BEEN ALLOWED
TO GO ON WITH HIS WIFE WELL I'M
GLAD TO EXPLAINS MY TWO SONS
WHY THEIR MOTHER IS NEVER
COMING HOME. CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE SO MUCH BETTER.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE. A
RECOURSE. BOB BECKEL ACTION.
FAR BETTER THAN THE OUTDATED
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MICRO CAP
THAT LIMIT THE VALUE OF HUMAN
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO KNOW
ABOUT POLITICIANS WILL BE
PRESSURED INTO EIGHTEEN IN
SIGNING WAGES IN RETURN FOR
CAMPAIGN DONATIONS UP HOLD THE
MARKER CAPS WHERE ONCE YOU
UNDERSTAND IS THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEND OF ROUTE
MESSAGE YOUR CONSTITUENS THAT
PATIENTS AND. FAMILIES MATTER.
ANY WILL TO SAY TALL AND HOLD
DOCTORS ACCOUNTABLE. I WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND IS FOR BOTH YOUR
WHO ARE NOT WITH MAYBE ON THE
DEBATE YOU ARE COMPLICIT IN THE
DEATH OF THESE PEOPLE YOU ARE
COMPLICIT IN THE MAIN MENU AND
INJURIES. OUR CORE. DO THE
RIGHT THING TO STAND AS WELL
ONCE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
IS A NEW DAY COMING CALIFORNIA
WORK PATIENTS AND FAMILIES ARE
GONNA STAND TOGETHER AND HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IF YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO WE WILL BE SURE
TO MAKE THESE DOCTORS TRAINED
IN. THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SIR I'M SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. I WILL NOTE FOR
THE FOLKS ON THE LINE THAT.
THIS IS NOT A HEARING IN THE
MICRO THIS IS A HEARING. AS
PARTOF OUR NORMAL PROCESS TO
CONDUCT A SUNSET. OVERSIGHT
REVIEW OF THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. REVIEW ITS
PROCEDURES AND PROCESSES. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE EFFECTIVE.
AND EFFICIENT AND IF NOT.
PROPOSE AND IMPLEMENT
PROCEDURES- THAT ARE THROUGH A
SUNSET REVIEW BILLS SO. I DO
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY NEXT-
MISTER MODERATOR. PERMIT MATTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY. THANK
YOU BYE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I COULD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SANDRA PRESENT I'M FROM
HYSTERIA SUMMARY COUNTY AND I'M
HERE TODAY WITH MY HUSBAND
ASKED ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
OUR FAMILY AND OTHER PATIENTS
WHO HAVE SUFFERED HARM DUE TO
MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE. AND WE'RE
ALSO REPRESENTING THE PARENTS
FOR INJURED PATIENTS ACT
CAMPAIGN. WE ARE SENATOR
CONSTITUENTS OF SENATOR WILK
WHO IS NOT A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A MONTH BEFORE HER
EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY IN TWO
MONTHS BEFORE HER HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION OUR SEVENTEEN YEAR
RESULT OF THE EGREGIOUS MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE. JORDAN MORE THAN
JUST MISDIAGNOSIS. SHE SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WE TRUSTED TO
HELP FOR. PHYSICIANS LIKE NORTH
HER SYMPTOMS HER TEST RESULTS.
AND LACKED ANY COORDINATED CARE
BETWEEN THE SPECIALISTS TO
CONTINUE TO PASS ALONG. WITHOUT
DIRECTION DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT. WE WERE LATER TOLD
HOW THE DOCTORS ON THEIR JOB
JORDAN WOULD STILL BE HERE AND
TO DATE NOBODY HAS BEEN HELD
RESPONSIBLE. IN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AFTER
JORDAN'S DAD. WE FILED MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD AFTER INQUIRY WITH MISS
JENNA JONES OFFICE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALL OF OUR COMPLAINTS
WERE COMPOSED. CAUSED BY THE
CENTRAL COMPLAINT UNIT WITHOUT
A COMPLAIN INTERVIEW AND NO
MEDICAL CONSULTANT REVIEW. WE
HAVE HAD NO RECOURSE TO APPEAL
AND NO KNOWLEDGE OF WE CAN
RESUBMIT AS A NEW COMPLAINT. WE
WERE INFORMED BY MULTIPLE
PERSONS OUTSIDE THE STATE
AGENCIES THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
FREQUENTLY CLOSES COMPLAINTS
FOR THE POSITION MAY BE PART OF
RELATED ACTIVE LITIGATION. THIS
REQUIRES CLARIFICATION AND
FORTHCOMING RESPONSE FROM THIS
BOARD. OVER THE LAST YEAR I'VE
LEARNED THAT MUCH A COMPLAINT
IS FILED. IN THE CONTEXT IN
JORDAN OF THE AGENCY COMPLAINTS
ARE LIKELY TO BE DISMISSED
WITHOUT COMPLAINT AN INTERVIEW
OR CONSULTANT REVIEW AS
LAYPERSONS THE PUBLIC IS NOT
FAMILIAR WITH ALL THE
COMPONENTS NECESSARY FOR EXTRA
SEX AFTER SEXUAL COMPLAINT AND
ASSOCIATED REVIEW. IN MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY HAS SUBMITTED A
NEW COMPLAINT THIS TIME CITED
AND SOURCED AND STILL HAVE NOT
HAD AN INTERVIEW AND ONLY AN
EMAIL REQUEST TO PROVIDE
JORDAN'S DEATH CERTIFICATE.
THIS IS THE ONLY ONE THAT JUST
RECENTLY PASSED THE CENTRAL
COMPLAINT YOU KNOW TO THE
MEDICAL CONSULTANT WHICH
DIRECTLY CONTRADICTS MISS JONES
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. THE
AVERAGE PROCESS FROM COMPLAINT
TO DISCIPLINE IF NOT DISMISS.
IT APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
DAYS WHICH IS NOT ONLY
UNACCEPTABLE BUT OFFENSIVE.
THIS IS A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM AND
THE PEOPLE HARMED BY MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE DESERVE JUSTICE AND
HEALTH CARE CONSUMERS DESERVE
BETTER. HERE'S A DOCTOR'S
POLICING THEMSELVES HAVE LED TO
NEGLIGENT DOCTORS CONTINUING TO
PRACTICE WITHOUT ANY
CONSEQUENCE. COUPLED WITH THE
CONSTRAINTS OF MICRO THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION IS LEFT
UNCHECKED. WE NEED IMPROVEMENT
IN TRANSPARENCY TO THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS AND
ENFORCEMENT I SUPPORT PREVIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR MORE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE. THE COMPLAINT STATUS
VERIFICATION BEEN CHECKPOINTS
COMPLETED FIFTY SIX TO BE
ONLINE INTERVIEWS WITH THE
COMPLAIN THAT MULTIPLE STEPS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND A
COST RECOVERY POLICIES. BASED
ON RECENT STATEMENTS AND LACK
OF PREPAREDNESS I AM NOT
CONVINCED ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
BOARD UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY OF
THE CURRENT ABYSMAL STATE OF
AFFAIRS WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD.
NOR THEIR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE PUBLIC.
SYSTEM IS BROKEN I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE OUR LIMITED STORY HERE
TODAY AND I WILL SEND THE FULL
CONTEXT OF MY STATEMENT FOR
INCLUSION IN THE RECORD THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
CALLERS ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
I HAVE FOUR WESTERN Q. OKAY
PLEASE PROCEED. I TRY TO GET
THE MALL AND I NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU BYE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME PERFECTLY CLEAR PLEASE
PROCEED. MY NAME IS MADE UP
AROUND THAT AND I AM CALLING
FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA. I
WANTED TO COME HERE AND SAY A
FEW WORDS BECAUSE IN THE END
THIS IS A MATTER OF HUMANITY
DECENCY AND RESPECT I WISH YOU
COULD HAVE IN MY HUSBAND'S
HOUSE DRAWING HEALTHY YOU ARE.
THAN HOW HE LOOKED. WHERE THERE
ARE SOME NOW HE ONLY AND CEMENT
ONE. AND READY. TO BROWSE
REQUESTS. SURGERY HE IS TO RUN
MARATHON AND TRIATHLONS. AND
NOW EVEN A WHEELCHAIR FOR THE
REMAINDER OF HIS LIFE. AND THE
MEDICAL BOARD ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN. APPLE YOU THINK YOU
NEED PEOPLE. LIKE MANY CASES
ARE TESTIFYING TODAY. IT'S NOT
JUST A MISTAKE. OFTEN THE
KEEPING THE WI FI OUR DOCTORS.
YEAR AFTER YEAR THE OTHER
PATIENTS AND THE PUBLIC.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
PRACTITIONER DATA BANK PUBLIC
USE. FILE DESPITE. THREE POINT
9% OF DOCTORS I MEAN WE- COURSE
THE SEVEN POINT 8% ALL MY
BREAKFAST. THE NINETEEN NINETY
ONE A TO DATA SEPTEMBER.
NINETEEN BY EACH OF THE DOCTORS
MAY AT LEAST TWO PAYMENTS IN
ORDER TO CASE THAT. THREE OF MY
HUSBAND NOT LINE. NOT ONCE NOT
TWICE HE- FROM THE THUNDER CARE.
THE BILL TEN TIMES
INVESTIGATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD THREE SHE WAS
NEGLIGENT BUT HE DID ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING MY HUSBAND HAS NO HANDS
AND NO LEGS AND THE MOST I
COULD DO IT RIGHT ABOUT YELP
REVIEWS. DOCTORS SHOULD NOT.
TELL THE SPECIALLY WHEN THEY
HAVE A TRACK RECORD LIKE THE
CARDINALITY OF BEING PART OF
THE VERY SAME. LOGIN WILL WE
NEED DATA NOT LOOKING FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE BOARD BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW DOCTOR SYMPATHIZE
WITH THE DOCTORS WITH THEIR
PEERS. AND NOT THE BIG THING NO
MATTER HE SAID DOCTORS MAIN
RATE OR KILL YOU OR YOUR LOVED
ONE. THEY HAVE DRUG OR ALCOHOL
PROBLEM AND THAT MAKING A
THREAT OF TREATING A PATIENT
UNDER THE INFLUENCE. OF 95%
FAILURE. RATE WE NEED WHAT
COMES. ON THE- FOR ANY SORT
JUST SYSTEM AND IS WHY I YOU
THAT ALL OF YOU ARE BECAUSE THE
PEACE OF ALL CALIFORNIA. THE
TRANSPARENT IS THE NEW FOR
BRAIN THAT AND THAT AN
INDEPENDENT LOOKING EAGLE.
INFIGHTING INDEPENDENCE SAID.
TO A QUALITY AND THAT WE- THE
PLANE WE CAN WE FOR ANY GROUP
OF LACKS THE MEDICAL BOARD OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR TIME
THANK FOR YOUR PRISON. THANKS.
PLEASE THANK YOU I'M SO EIGHT
PLEASE CALL. YEAH LITTLE DOCTOR
LOSING GOVERNOR'S AND YOU AND
USE THE U. S. FROM ANGELES I
WASN'T PRACTICE WITHOUT ELEVEN.
BEFORE TWENTY YEARS LOS ANGELES
HIS BODY OFF LITTLE HERE CAN
HOSP. AND MANY PEOPLE CALL
COSTS TO PRIVILEGE. I THINK
ABOUT IT YEAR ABOUT THE HOW
PATIENTS. AND OTHER LOCALS NO
JUST RECORD. WITH INSURANCE OR
MEDICAL AND NON BURKE CREDIT
SERVICE COOPER CALLING FOR
SEVEN WITH ALMOST TWENTY.
SOMEONE IN THE DURING MY ON I
DON'T THINK WITHIN ELSE LOS
ANGELES. A LAWYER AND THE WHITE
WORKS AT GET THE CHIEF- GENERAL
I DID NOT LIKE IT BECAUSE- ONE
OF MY THE OTHER WELL. HIS WIFE
BOTH MISTAKEN THE ON THE- ENJOY
A LITTLE PROBABLY SEE. WHAT
SORT OF THE BEACH UNITED STATES
LEGAL PROBLEMS. LEGAL JOBS OF
ISSUE THAT CAN BE WRITTEN IN
THE LOCAL. SO IT- I HAVE NEVER
HAD A PEER REVIEW ARE THE
HOSPITAL NEVER ANYTHING PATIENT
COMPLAINT NEVER HAD A SINGLE
BALL PRACTICE COMPLETE. I FEEL
FOR THESE BECOMES THE
CONTROLLED MOLD DOCTORS- IN
LEADING TO GET RECORD THEIR OWN.
AND VERY VERY IMPRESSED CALL
BECAUSE HE- THE MEDICAL BOARD
JUDICIARY. MALES PUBLIC AND
ALSO DOCTOR. DOCTOR SHOULD NOT
BE FOR THAT DOCTOR. SERVICE
FOUR YEAR NOT JUST ME BUT OTHER.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THAT WOULD
PROBABLY LONG I FORGOT MEDICAL
CHIEF OFFICER WHAT CONVICTED
YOU KNOW ACTIONS BECAUSE OF
HIGH INCOME WOULD THAT. BE ALL
CORRUPTION IN THE JUDICIARY
WITH LAWYER ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE. SO THEY DID MY LICENSE
ALWAYS RATES. AND SHE WAS I
CALL THE CORE THAT HER GO WRONG.
LEVIN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
THAT POINT OF MIND AT THE
BASICALLY. WHAT TRYING FORM
THEIR WHOLE MONTH. FOR STEALING
CREDIT CARD MONEY ALL. BUT I
THINK SHE MEDICAL BOARD SUPER.
OFFICE OFFICER MICHAEL PLAYS
THE MEDICAL EAGLE CREEK HEY
FRAZIER I NEED TO KNOW THE- AND
WE'RE GREATER LOS AFFAIRS SHE
IT SO ANYWAY GET USE ME AND
DINNER MIGHT- UNIQUELY AT THE
OLD PATIENT CO NO SINGLE INJURY
TAKE UP ONE MINUTE BOARD ON
EXPORT THAT YOU ON HIS RESUME
HE WAS A- INSTRUCTORS ARE LOYAL
UNIVERSE. HE WAS THAT HE IS AT
A THESE ONE MEDICAL BOARD
EXPORT. AND I TO PUT WITNESS
ONE THE UCLA. FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF NEUROLOGY I'M IN OUR
OFFICE PEOPLE NOTHING ALL MY
KIDS PROBATION AS WELL AS THE
OTHER THAT MORTGAGE ON MY
PROBATION. AND WE GO TO TRIAL.
GENERAL IF YOU READ ARE THE
ONES NOT BROUGHT TO TRY AND
LOST MAYBE SHE WILL CLEARED BY
HI CALLED. MENTALLY YOU
PERMANENTLY SHE CAN TESTIFY AND
DEVELOPED ON THE CHECK. WE FOR
THIS OF THE CHANGE. THEY WERE
SUPPORTING LIKE HERE. BAKER I
THOUGHT HE DID AN EXCELLENT
HERE WHEN THE REGULAR CLOTHES
AND THE POLICE ALL HOME I
DECIDED TO LEAVE HIM BECAUSE
I'M WORRIED MY FAVORITE. SO
DIDN'T WORK YOU NEED TO PICKING
OFF A GREEN TRUCK HE SAID.
SEVEN MORE BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENED TO WILL. I THINK WHAT
PART OF THE COSMETIC LOOKING
BACK. I AM LEAVING MY JOB TO
THE WHOLE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
READY TO MY- PETER LARA AND THE
DOCTORS PROVIDE YOU OFTEN. WHAT
ABOUT YOUNG. CHILDREN GO TO
HELP QUEUED A DOCTOR. I WOULD
HAVE TO YOU. TO CLOSE IT OUT
INTO SOME TO. SUBMIT YOUR YOUR
RIDDANCE TO US FOR OUR
CONSIDERATION. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT I TOOK
THE TIME TO PRESENT ONE SECOND.
I RESPECT YOUR INTELLIGENCE
YOU'RE VERY CRITICAL VERY SMART
GUY YOU CAN YOU LOS FOUR
DOLLARS I THINK I DESERVE
HOLDEN. I RESPECT YOUR HIGHLY.
AND I THINK MEDICAL BOARD
CHILDREN NOT. ALL MEDICAL
RECORD REVIEW AND TRY TO FIND
SOMETHING LIKE ON MY CASE FOR
TEN YEARS SPENDING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WIDE PUBLIC YOU'RE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE AND EVEN IF THEY
DON'T GET INTO POLITICS. PEOPLE
ONE NINETEEN SERVING FAITHFUL
TO THE COMMUNITY AND THE
PATIENT AND BECAUSE SOMETHING
HAPPENED ON THE LINE TO GET A
HEARING AID BECAUSE OF THE
WHOLE OF MY LIFE. BECAUSE
NOBODY. RIGHT DOWN HAS A SINGLE
I LOOK FORWARD READING YOUR
WRITTEN SO. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MOVE ON TO THE LEAD DAY BELIEVE
TO. FOR EIGHTEEN TO POLLS THE
PLUG MY CAR. LINE HERE SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
PLEASE SEND ME YOUR WRITTEN
STATEMENT- I PROMISE TO READ
AND INCORPORATED IN OUR IN OUR
RECORD OF THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING. THANK YOU- MODERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
ROB CARILLO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EXTENDING THE TIME AND GIVEN ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH
YOU TODAY MY NAME IS TAMMY
MECHANI LEVINSON MACULA I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR MELENDEZ.
YOUR SAFETY ADVOCATE AND BOARD
MEMBER WITH CONSUMER WATCHDOG I
BECAME ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
IMPROVING PATIENT SAFETY AFTER
MY TWENTY YEAR OLD. ALEX THAT.
WAS KILLED DUE TO MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE IT WAS MY WORST
NIGHTMARE. NOT ONLY DID I LOSE
MY CHILD BUT HE WAS KILLED BY
THE VERY MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
I ENTRUSTED WITH HIS CARE. AND
WITHIN AN ORANGE COUNTY
HOSPITAL THAT ALEX WAS GIVEN A
LETHAL COMBINATION OF
MEDICATIONS AND MANY WITH LEFT
ON MONITORED FOR MORE THAN
SEVEN HOURS. HE WAS- IT WAS
FOUND DEAD IN BED. DURING
MORNING ROUNDS AND HE WAS
ALREADY IN REPORTERS- I TURN TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
TO STOP THIS DANGEROUS DOCTOR
FROM KILLING ANOTHER PATIENT. I
THOUGHT SURELY THIS REGULATORY
AGENCY WOULD DO THE RIGHT THING
AND TAKES ACTION AGAINST THE
DANGEROUS DOCTOR WHO KILLED MY
SON. I THOUGHT THEY WERE THERE
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC BUT I
WOULD SAY OVERALL. MY COMPLAINT
AGAINST DOCTOR DANIEL HEADRICK
INVOLVING THE DEATH OF OUR-
SHIPS FOR. FOUR LONG YEARS TO
REACH A DECISION. AFTER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE FILED
AN ACTIVATION RECOMMENDING
STRICT DISCIPLINARY ACTION
INCLUDING REVOCATION OF THE
DOCTOR'S LICENSE. A SECRET
BACKROOM DEAL WESTROCK AND THE
DOCTOR GOT AWAY WITH A PUBLIC
REPRIMAND NOTHING MORE THAN A
SLAP ON THE WRIST FOR KILLING
MY SON. THE MEDICAL BOARD
COMPLETELY ONCE AGAIN THEIR OWN
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES AND
THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THE
DECENCY TO TALK TO ME I WAS
INFORMED VIA EMAIL AFTER THE
DECISION WAS FINALIZED AND I
HAD TO READ THROUGH A MULTI
PAGE DOCUMENTS TO DETERMINE THE
OUTCOME. THE COMPLAINT PROCESS
WHICH COLD. SENSITIVE TO MY
GRIEVING FAMILY ALL ALONG THE
WAY. THE MISSION OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO PROTECT HEALTHCARE.
CONSUMER BUT MY IT. VERIA CAL.
SHOW THAT WOULD RATHER PER. HER
STOCK THAT PROTECT PATIENTS. I
BELIEVE THE PROBLEM IN THE LAST
2% BECAUSE OF THE POSITION
CONTROLLED MEDICAL CORD- AND SO
I FULLY SUPPORT A PUBLIC MEMBER
MAJORITY TO HELP INSURE THAT
THE MEDICAL PORTERFIELD'S ITS
MISSION A PATIENT PROTECTION.
IT'S LONG PAST TIME FOR CHANGE.
THE FIGHT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
EIGHT YEARS AGO AND I AM DEEPLY
SADDENED AND FRUSTRATED SO VERY
LITTLE HAS CHANGED TO PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC I IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE TO HELP US TO HELP
PROTECT ALL HEALTHCARE
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE AND WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. WORK WITH
YOU ON MEANINGFUL REFORM THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR
SPENDING THE TIME GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
WE'RE TRULY SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS
MA'AM AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU STAYED ON AND
TOOK THE TIME. TO SPEAK TO US
TODAY. MODERATOR NECKS PLEASE.
THANK YOU THIRTY TWO GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
PROCEED LOUDLY. HELLO CAN YOU-HEAR ME WE CANNOT ALLOW IN
CLEAR JUST MAKE SURE YOU SPEAK
LOUDLY. THE OKAY SO I'M AND WE
CAN BECOME ADOPTED CERTAIN OUT
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY I
ACTUALLY I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
HEALTH EQUITY WITH KNOWLEDGE
YOU COMPANY MEMBERS HOLLISTER
AND I'M ACTUALLY A CONSTITUENT.
OF OUR CENTER TO LAW. WHAT I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT IS
EVERYTHING EVERYONE IS SAID I
AGREE WITH I AGREE THERE'S
DANGERS DOCTORS I AGREE THAT
THERE'S A SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT
ALLOW THE PROCESS TO PROCEED AS
IT SHOULD. I ALSO AGREE THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ADVERSITY WITHIN
HEALTHCARE. CURRENTLY 43% OF
BLACK POSITIONS ARE THAT HAVE A
LIFE THE CALIFORNIA WILL BE
REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND SUBJECT TO LICENSE YOUR
DISHES. FOR AS ASIAN AND WHITE
POSITIONS ARE IN THE TWENTIETH
PERCENTILE THIS IS THE DATA
FROM THE C. R. B. THAT WAS
PUBLISHED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. WELL I CAN TELL YOU
IS THAT COMPLAIN THEY GET SENT
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD- THE
MEDICAL MORE OFTEN WILL TRY TO
PERSUADE COMPLAINER. INCLUDING
POSITION BUT NOT THE FALL
COMPLAINING BECAUSE- A VEGAN
RETALIATION THIS INCLUDES. EVEN
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE. THE MEDICAL
BOARD EXPERTS. I'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT THEM MAY HAVE
NEED FOR WHEN IT COMES TO BEING
ABLE HAVE FULL CONFIDENCE OF
THE ACTUAL KEEP THAT THERE'S TO
REPRESENT. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE MATTER BOARD KEEP KICKING
THEM. THAT THEY THE HIGH. HIGH
CASE THE MEDICAL BOY HAS BEEN
KNOWN TO. CASE FROM. OF THE
COMMUNITY. LOS CLOSE PROXIMITY
OF THE HOT. FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD NOW LOW. AND NOT ONLY BUT
THE CITY HAHA HAVE BEEN EXACT.
AT THAT LOOKS. INTERFERE WITH
THAT HEY THIS IS ACTUAL FACT
THAT HAVE HAPPENED. WHAT
MICHAEL DID MANAGE LOOKING AT
THIS TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA- REVIEW BUREAU THE
RESEARCH REPORT I NOTICED OF
STANCIL DATA ISSUES THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF THE TEMPERATURES
ARE AWARE OF. THE DATA IN THE
TABLE HAS BEEN ALTERED FOR
INSTANCE NATIVE AMERICANS TO
SUGGEST THAT COMPLAINTS ARE NOT
AS BAD OR NOT IS A DISTRICT ARE
NOT. LESS DISCRIMINATION IS IN
THE SYSTEM. AND THE TABES IF
YOU LOOK AT IT NATIVE AMERICANS
WORK INCREASED A HUNDRED AND.
41% BETWEEN TWO TABLES. WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO MEAN THE SAME
FACTOR CAL. BUT LACKS A FIVE.
ASIAN FORTY NINE PER OF THE
CHECK. AND THIS WAS REFLECTED
IN TRYING TO REDUCE THE OVER
NUMBER TO SHOW THERE WAS NO
DISPARATE IMPACT DISCRIMINATION
WITHIN THE BOARD'S PROCEDURES.
ADDITIONALLY CRITICAL THERE ARE
VARIABLES ARE MISSING FROM THE
REPORT SUCH AS AND I THINK THIS
IS WHAT PATIENTS REALLY WANT TO
GET TO. IS THAT THERE'S NO
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION THAT
DEALS WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY MAKING THE DECISION
THAT MEANS WE DON'T KNOW THE
RACE OR ETHNICITY IN YOU NEED
TO INVESTIGATORS THE
CONSULTANTS ARCHITECTS BURKE
THESE ARE CRITICAL VARIABLES
THAT WE NEED TO KNOW WHEN HE-
DOES. THAT THERE'S ALSO NO DATA
ON WHETHER OR NOT BE COMPLETED
YOU COMING FROM HOSPITALS. OR
WHETHER THEY'RE COMING FROM
PATIENTS. BUT HAVE BEEN PLAYING
A LOT ABOUT BEING ASKED TO
LEAVE COMMUNITY DIRECTLY.
PUBLIC ENEMY. THEN IF THEY
DON'T. THE BILL THREAT WITH
COMPLAINT. OF EIGHT OH FIVE
RECALL. HERE IS RESOLUTION.
FIRST CRB REPORT INACCURATE
BROKE PEOPLE ARE AND I BELIEVE
TO SHOULD HAPPEN UNIVERSITY ARE
V. SHOULD GO BACK AND REPRODUCE
RECORD STEVIE AND INVEST IT
DEPENDED EXTERNAL REPORT. TO
INCLUDE NEVER ONE TO MISS CARE
THAT I'M- FOR THIS PURPOSE
EVERY HOT SHOULD BE IN AND OVER.
OF THOSE IN THE AND OF TO
HOSPITAL WHICH INCLUDES A
PRIEST IN X. SCREENING PROCESS
WHICH THEY NOW HAPPEN. TO
ANYTHING DID NOT TO THAT.
NUMBER THREE HISTORY THE ISSUE
OF INPUT THE BIAS THE SCREEN.
AND IT GIVE FOR PATIENTS SAFETY
MY RECOMMENDATION YET THAT
SOMEONE KILLED DOCTOR CROWD TWO
ONE THAT YOU GET AT ONE HAVE
FORCE. IN I AGREE SHOULD BE
PEOPLE NUMBER. ON THAT THAT PAN
QUICKLY. AND NINE OPPOSITION
BUT AT THE SAME TIME TO FORCE
SHOULD BE TO A- OF DENTURES IN
THIS PEOPLE WHO DEAL WITH HELLO
EQUITIES AND TO REALLY GET TO
THE OF WHAT HAPPENED ON THIS
BOARD. I APPRECIATE YOU FOR
TIME I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENACTED SPEAK THE THAT THEY ARE
THE IMPORTANT IT NEEDS TO BE.
AND I ACCEPT BACK IN. PUBLIC
WILL BUT THAT YOU CAN WRITE.
HELLO THERE WAS ONE. UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. FOR THE NINE BUT
LACKS CERTAIN OPPORTUNITY.
THANK THEY DESERVE. AND THE ARE
THE KIND OF THING THAT WE DON'T
NEED ANY HELP. BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT THAT US UP FOR PATIENTS
NOT BEING A TO ACT QUALITY HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TIME
DOCTOR THANKS FOR TESTIMONY
MONTEREY NEXT PLAY. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE OF SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK GOODNESS CRISTINA
HILDEBRAND FROM AVOID CONTRACT
ADVOCACY AND I JUST WANTED TO
COMMEND T. J. WATKINS FOR.
GIVING US WHAT HE ALWAYS DOES
THE MEDICAL BOARD MEETINGS
WHICH WE ATTEND EVERY SINGLE-
QUARTERS AND WHICH IS SPEAKING
OUT GOING CUT TRYING T SHAKE
SHAKE THE BORDER SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY-
AND RECOGNIZES WHAT EVERYONE
ELSE IS. SAYING WHICH IS THAT
THE TRUST IN THE PUBLIC. TRUST
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD IT'S JUST
NOT THERE I ONE OF THE
UNDERLYING THINGS THAT I DON'T
THINK LIKE TO POINT OUT IS THAT
THE WHILE THE POSITION PUBLIC
MEMBERSHIP IS DEFINITELY AN
ISSUE AND IT WOULD BE BETTER TO
HAVE MORE PUBLIC MEMBERS
POSITION. OUT ONE OF THE OTHER
HE ISSUE WITH THE FACT THAT ALL
OF THE POSITION MEMBERS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
AMOUNT OF LOBBYING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
DOES. TO THE MEDICAL BOARD- AND
THEY ARE TWO VERY DIFFERENT AND
HE- IS AMAZING AND THE FACT
THAT YOU KNOW. I THINK ONLY 40%
OF THE NATION'S IN CALIFORNIA
ARE PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE-
RESIDENTS AND PEOPLE THAT ARE.
STILL IN MEDICAL- GETTING THEIR
MEDICAL DEGREES AND WORK IN THE
FIRST FEW YEARS OUT OF OUT OF
SCHOOL THEY ARE NOT THE
POSITIONS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
THAT ARE HAVE BEEN PRACTICING
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN REALLY IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF. PETITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA YES THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS MADE UP MAJORITY
POSITION WHAT PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE LOBBY
AND BIAS BY THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. REALLY OFF THE
LEGISLATURE OR THINGS TO LOOK
AT THAT AND FEELING SURE THAT
WHEN POSITIONS ARE- ARE MAKE IT
OR YOU KNOW PUT IN PLACE. IN IN
THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT THEY
FROM AWAY. OF POSITIONS AND
THAT ARE NOT. A RECORD- PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL STATE OR
OFF THE TIDE WITH THE MATTER A
BIG WHICH IS ON MY BEING AN
ACTOR APPLICATION. MY COMMENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. THANK YOU I WANT SEVEN
GOING. RIGHT ONE OF SEVEN YOU
ARE NOW OPEN. YEAH I DO THINK
THAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
COULD BE. HAPPENING NOW COULD
BE. CALIFORNIA MEDICAL. THE
MOST THE INDIAN GOLDEN. GIVEN
THE CORRUPTION AND THE DEEP EDB.
THE TEACHERS UNION. CALIFORNIA
YOU. ARE TOTALLY ENTIRELY WITH.
I THINK THAT YOU A MEMBER THAT
YOU. CALIFORNIA. I KNOW YOU
SAID A LOT. BECAUSE WE- WHICH
IS WHAT HE DOES THANK YOU MAY
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS YOU AT THE
TIME. FIVE FOR THE RECORD I
WILL THAT FOR THOSE WHO THINK
WE DON'T TAKE PUBLIC. WE HAVE
ALL TO HOUR OF. PUBLIC COMMENT-
AT THIS INITIAL MEDICAL BOARD
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING
WITH AT LEAST ONE MORE. ARE
SCHEDULED IN THE FUTURE SO FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO DID NOT HAVE A
FULL OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS ONE I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU SUBMIT THEM IN WRITING INTO
I WOULD ALSO ASK THAT YOU TUNE
IN FOR THE NEXT SESSION. AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT OPPORTUNITY AS WELL.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEES ARE WITNESSES
FOR THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR SHARING YOUR
STORIES. AND FOR WEIGHING IN ON
THE ISSUES THAT WE WERE
ADDRESSING AND HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSING TODAY DURING THESE
PROCEEDINGS. I ENFORCEMENT BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD WHICH IS THE
SUBJECT OF THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING IS KEY TO ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC TRUST. REMAINS WITH THIS
MOST IMPORTANT OF PROFESSIONS.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO ME IS
THINK IT'S CLEAR TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN CLEAR TO ALL WHO
LISTEN TODAY. BUT THERE IS
STILL MUCH WORK TO BE DONE WITH
REGARD TO MANY CONCERNS ON A
VARIETY OF ISSUES HAVING TO DO
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD. OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS AS I INDICATED A
MINUTE AGO PLAN TO REVIEW THE
MEDICAL BOARD'S OPERATIONS IT'S
WORK PROCESS SEES AND EFFORTS
TO ENSURE. QUALITY PATIENT CARE
AND WILL ANNOUNCE THOSE DATES
IN THE COMING WEEKS AS DETAILS
ARE CONFIRMED ONCE AGAIN LET ME
SAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE TODAY. AND
FOR THOSE WHO DID PARTICIPATE
BUT WISH TO DO SO PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS TO THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
OR THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR BOTH.
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. I CAN
ASSURE YOU. THEN YOUR
COMMONSENSE ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. FOR TODAY THIS
JOINT SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.